This is the 99% of visible breakdown of the power broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Kalin. So today we're covering the final section of part 5, The Love of Power, and the beginning of part 6, The Lust for Power. That's chapters 27-32, pages 607-702. And later in this episode, our special guest is the Secretary of Transportation, Pete Budicic.
这是对《权力掮客》可见内容的99%的剖析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是埃利奥特·卡林。所以今天我们要讨论第五部分“对权力的热爱”的最后一部分，以及第六部分“对权力的渴望”的开端。也就是第27到32章，第607到702页。在本集节目稍后，我们的特别嘉宾是交通部长皮特·布蒂吉格。
In addition to overseeing the federal dollars for infrastructure in this country, Secretary Budicic was also responsible for several major infrastructure projects when he was mayor of South Bend, Indiana. He's also talked about acknowledging the racism built into transportation systems around the country, something he has mentioned publicly, kind of paraphrasing the power broker, and gotten a lot of pushback for. So on the last episode, Robert Moses was showing what an amazing visionary he was, but also what a petty tyrant he could be. On one hand, he was brilliantly taken advantage of these like tax assessments and federal programs
除了监督本国的基础设施联邦资金外，布蒂吉格部长在担任印第安纳州南本德市长期间，还负责过多项重大基础设施项目。他还谈到了承认全国交通系统中内置的种族主义，这是他公开提到过的事情，某种程度上是对《权力掮客》的化用，并为此收到了大量的阻力和反弹。所以在上一集中，罗伯特·摩西展现了他是一位多么了不起的远见卓识者，但同时也展现了他可以是一个多么琐屑的暴君。一方面，他巧妙地利用了这些类似税收评估和联邦计划
and archival research to complete the funding of this massive West Side Manhattan construction project, which is this amazing chapter in just like how he works down 109 million dollars to something that the city can afford. On the other hand, he's destroying neighborhoods, these historic neighborhoods. He's destroying New York's last natural wilderness space without taking anyone else's need into account and harassing the Columbia Yacht Club just because he can, because he thought that they were rude to him. It's also becoming clear how much he is using race and class
以及档案研究，来完成这个庞大的曼哈顿西区建设项目的资金筹措，这是关于他是如何将1.09亿美元砍价到城市负担得起的金额的一个了不起的章节。另一方面，他在摧毁社区，这些历史悠久的社区。他在没有将任何其他人的需求考虑在内的情况下，摧毁了纽约最后一片自然荒野空间，并仅仅因为他可以，因为他认为他们对他不礼貌，就去骚扰哥伦比亚游艇俱乐部。同样变得清晰的是，他在多大程度上利用了种族和阶层
when it comes to his park projects. Like he's deliberately underserving New York's poor people and people of color. And meanwhile, all these bridges and expressways that he's building that are meant to relieve New York's traffic problems are actually seeming to make traffic worse. And this is becoming this thing that is constant.
当涉及到他的公园项目时。就像他故意为纽约的穷人和有色人种提供不足的服务。与此同时，他正在建造的所有这些旨在缓解纽约交通问题的桥梁和高速公路，实际上似乎让交通变得更糟了。这正在变成一件不断发生的事情。
It's almost a universal truth when it comes to building bridges and more roads and more lanes. But he cannot see this. This is his only solution, no matter what the outcome actually proves itself to be. And then we've also learned in this horrible chapter, a good chapter, but a very sad chapter of Robert Moses' relationship with his own family, the decades he spent undermining the career and the success of his own brother and his disdain and sort of completely ignoring his sister
当谈到修建桥梁、更多的道路和更多的车道时，这几乎是一个普遍真理。但他看不到这一点。这是他唯一的解决办法，不管最终结果证明是什么。然后我们也在这个可怕的章节中了解到，一个好章节，但关于罗伯特·摩西与他自己家庭关系的非常悲伤的章节，他花了几十年时间破坏他自己的兄弟的事业和成功，以及他的蔑视和某种程度上完全忽视他的姐姐
and just the completely undermining the vitality and the life force of Mary, his wife. So that was on the last episode, so check it out if you haven't heard it. Now we're up to chapter 27, also again called changing, and tell us what are we in store for? I'm excited because this changing chapter is a different changing chapter from the last one.
以及完全破坏玛丽，他的妻子的活力和生命力。所以在上一集中讲过这些，如果你还没听过，去听听看吧。现在我们到了第27章，同样也叫“改变”，告诉我们接下来有什么在等着我们？我很兴奋，因为这个“改变”章节与上一个“改变”章节不同。
Remember from the last episode, that changing chapter was 75 pages long or so. And this one, this, this episode, we're going to be zooming through the zoom in through chapter. Some of the shortest chapters in the book are on this one and you can't judge a chapter by its size there's still valuable information concepts moments scenes uh it's amazing and i know last episode you probably had a lot of audience members saying something they never thought they would say before oh that poor yacht club and this this episode we're gonna have more shocks and twists like that one.
还记得上一集吗，那一章“改变”大约有75页长。而这一章，这个，这一集，我们将飞快地浏览，通过微距镜头深入阅读其中的章节。这本书中最短的一些章节就在这一部分，你不能以大小来衡量一章，这里依然有有价值的信息、概念、时刻、场景，呃，这太棒了。我知道上一集你可能有很多听众说出了他们以前从没想过会说的话：哦，那可怜的游艇俱乐部。而在这一集里，我们将迎来更多像那样的冲击和转折。
I didn't want to interrupt you, Roman, but I was thinking when you're talking about the bridges making traffic worse, I started thinking of the first line of Pride and Prejudice, and I was wishing Jane Austen could write her gloss on the book and be like, it's a truth universally acknowledged that the making of a bridge will lead to more cars on the bridge. will lead to more cars on the bridge. So this chapter, we'll start with chapter 27, changing. We're still in part five, the love of power. The love of power, that's the worst emotion you can feel for power, right? No, get ready for, we're going to get to part six and then it gets dirtier. But chapter 27 is about how Robert Moses is continuing to change from someone who, well, the previous change of Robert Moses was from someone who was an idealist to a realist,
我不是想打断你，罗曼，但当你在谈论桥梁使交通变得更糟时，我想到了《傲慢与偏见》的第一行，我希望简·奥斯汀能为这本书写下她的批注，就像：这是一个无可争议的真理，建造一座桥梁将导致桥上出现更多的汽车。将导致桥上出现更多的汽车。所以这一章，我们将从第27章“改变”开始。我们仍然在第五部分“对权力的热爱”中。对权力的热爱，那是你对权力能感受到的最糟糕的情感，对吧？不，准备好吧，我们要进入第六部分，然后情况就会变得更黑暗。但第27章讲的是罗伯特·摩西如何继续从一个——嗯，罗伯特·摩西的上一次改变是从一个理想主义者变成一个现实主义者，
someone who held so firm to their principles they could not get things done. And now they will do whatever it takes to get things done. And now Kara says, in the past, that Moses, even the realist Moses, it was because he cared about his dreams. It wasn't power that he wanted so much as he wanted to achieve these dreams.
一个对自己的原则坚持得如此坚定以至于无法把事情做成的人。而现在，他们会不惜一切代价把事情做成。现在卡罗说，在过去，摩西，甚至是现实主义摩西，那是因为他在乎他的梦想。他想要的并不是权力本身，而是实现这些梦想。
And he would do anything to make it happen. But lying in his personality, laying in wait, was this susceptibility to an addiction to power. And now this further change is he'll do anything he wants or needs to, not just to get a thing made, but to maintain his power and to accumulate more power. By 1936, which was when this chapter begins, as we've jumped around in time quite a bit at different times, but now we're firmly in 1936, he is seeking power for its own sake. And in this case, he really wants to be part of the New York City Tunnel Authority, which is going to be the new authority
他会做任何事情来让它发生。但在他的性格深处，潜伏着一种对权力的成瘾倾向。现在，更进一步的改变是，他将做任何他想做或需要做的事，不仅是为了建成某个东西，而是为了维持他的权力并积累更多的权力。到1936年，也就是本章开始的时候，因为我们在不同的时间里跳跃了很多次，但现在我们坚实地处于1936年，他为了权力而寻求权力。在这种情况下，他非常想加入纽约市隧道管理局，这将是新的管理局
that will build a Queens Midtown Tunnel and a Brooklyn Battery Tunnel. They're big passageways for getting people between Manhattan and the other boroughs. And these are big things. Tunnels are big in New York. We're gonna talk a little bit about the Holland Tunnel connecting New York and New Jersey under the Hudson River. That's a big tunnel. It's super important. Tunnels are big. They're important. Let's, we don't think about tunnels much. They're holes in the ground, but they're important holes. And the thing is, Braum Moses says, LaGuardia, make me a part of this tunnel authority.
它将建造皇后区中城隧道和布鲁克林电池隧道。它们是让人们在曼哈顿和其他行政区之间穿梭的大通道。这些都是大事。隧道在纽约是大工程。我们要稍微聊聊连接纽约和新哈德逊河下的荷兰隧道。那是个大隧道。它超级重要。隧道很大。它们很重要。让我们，我们不常想到隧道。它们是地上的洞，但它们是重要的洞。问题是，布劳姆·摩西对拉瓜迪亚说，让我加入这个隧道管理局。
And LaGuardia has smartened up a little bit since the past and he knows I need federal funds for this tunnel. And if there's one guy, the president, president Roosevelt hates, it is Robert Moses. And that got me into a lot of trouble. And you know what? Robert Moses is the master of bridges, master of roads. He doesn't know anything about underwater tunnels. So LaGuardia
而拉瓜迪亚比过去聪明了一点，他知道我需要这个隧道的联邦资金。如果说有一个人，总统，罗斯福总统痛恨，那就是罗伯特·摩西。这给我惹了不少麻烦。你知道吗？罗伯特·摩西是桥梁大师、道路大师。他对水下隧道一无所知。所以拉瓜迪亚
says, no, I'm not going to make you part of this authority. So Moses, what is he going to do? He's going to try to derail the legislation creating the authority because there's no post for him in it. And that doesn't work. And so then he tries to schmooze some cooperation from the head of the project, the engineer, Earl Singstad or, or Singstead, we had a lot of discussion before that recording, I had to pronounce it. I always thought it was old Singstead, like that's good old Singstead over there. But Olay Singstead was also thrown around. But Singstead, he's a he's someone who is not going to be pushed around quite as easily or smooth as quite easily. And I love Carol's description for him on page 607.
说，不，我不会让你加入这个管理局。所以摩西，他要做什么？他要试图破坏创建管理局的立法，因为里面没有他的职位。这行不通。于是他试图从项目负责人、工程师厄尔·辛格斯特德或辛格斯特德那里讨好并获取合作，我们在录音前讨论了很多关于如何发音的问题。我一直以为那是老辛格斯特德，就像那边那个优秀的、老旧的辛格斯特德。但奥莱·辛格斯特德也被提及。但辛格斯特德，他是一个不容易被摆布或轻易讨好的人。我喜欢卡罗在第607页对他的描述。
He says, There were engineers available outside most of this organization, most notably, Ulla Singsted, a cocky, hard-driving, table-pounding Norwegian, who had designed the then-novel ventilation system that had made the Holland Tunnel feasible, who, after tunnel designer Clifford M. Holland collapsed and died from overwork, had rammed the job through to completion, and who is regarded as the world's leading authority on underwater vehicular tunnels. And I love what a particular specialization that is, that if you're going to be the world's authority on anything, underwater vehicular tunnels is a great way to do it. But Roman,
他说：在这个组织的大多数人之外还有可用的工程师，最著名的是乌拉·辛格斯特德，一个傲慢、冲劲十足、拍桌子的挪威人，他设计了当时新颖的通风系统，使荷兰隧道成为可能；在隧道设计师克利福德·M·霍兰因过度工作虚脱而死后，他强行推进工作直至完成；并且他被视为世界上水下车辆隧道领域的首席权威。我喜欢那种具体的专业性，如果你要成为任何领域的权威，水下车辆隧道绝对是一个好方法。但是罗曼，
before the episode, you were talking about how, worth taking a moment to talk about, Singstad, Carol just says he designed the ventilation system for the Holland tunnel, but you were saying that was a big thing, it was a big deal. It was, it's such a long tunnel, it's the very beginning of sort of car traffic being carried under these long tunnels, and figuring out a ventilation system so that people didn't suffocate on carbon monoxide was a huge deal, like they spent a ton of time on it, tons of tests, probably ethically questionable tests with young engineers and graduate students and stuff.
在录音前，你谈到过，花点时间谈谈辛格斯特德是值得的，卡罗只是说他为荷兰隧道设计了通风系统，但你说这是一件大事，是个了不起的大事。是的，这太长了，这是汽车交通开始被带到这些长隧道底下的最初阶段，弄出一个通风系统让人类不至于一氧化碳中毒窒息是一件大事，比如他们在这上面花了大量时间、大量的测试，可能在道德上有争议的测试，让年轻的工程师和研究生去试。
Can you hang out in this tunnel and we'll fill it with carbon monoxide until you don't feel good? Exactly. And he's the one who cracked this and the Holland Tunnel was a huge engineering feat. And I don't think you can overstate how important Ole Singstad is to tunnel development
你能在这个隧道里待着，我们把它充满一氧化碳直到你感觉不舒服吗？完全正确。他是那个攻克这个难关的人，荷兰隧道是一项巨大的工程壮举。我认为你无法夸大奥莱·辛格斯特德对隧道发展有多么重要
as an engineering because of his ventilation systems. I mean, it's really, he's coming against someone who actually knows how to do something rather than just bully people. You know, like he knows engineering in a real sense. And Robert Moses, you were saying this before the recording, Robert Moses is thought of as a builder, but he's not an engineer. He doesn't really know the mechanics of these things. So he can BS people and he can snow them with his made up facts. And Singstead is like, well, no, I know this.
作为一个工程学上的贡献，因为他的通风系统。我的意思是，真的，他遇到了一个真正知道如何做事的人，而不仅仅是欺负人。你知道的，就像他在真正的意义上懂工程学。而罗伯特·摩西，你在录音前说过这个，罗伯特·摩西被认为是一个建设者，但他不是一个工程师。他并不真正了解这些东西的力学原理。所以他可以忽悠人，可以用他编造的事实把他们镇住。而辛格斯特德的反应是，不，我知道这个。
This is my science. I think that's it. Like if I were to sort of get to the heart of this, it's like he's a real engineer's engineer. And he might find the sort of bureaucratic phoniness of Moses and it's so like his kind of thing might not work on him. You know, like Moses' bravado might not work on Singstot. If I were to sort of cast them
这是我的科学。我想就是这样。如果我必须抓住这一点，就像他是真正的工程师中的工程师。他可能会发现摩西那种官僚式的虚伪，而且这太像他的风格了，可能对他不管用。你知道，摩西的虚张声势在辛格斯特德身上可能行不通。如果我要去选角
and make this dramatic story, I would, that's what I would focus on, yeah. Giving notes to Robert Caro, that's hubristic in its way, you know, but you know. No, no, no, I mean like. Even a cat can look at a king. I way, you know, but you know, even a cat can look at a king. I mean, if I were to cast this as a movie and I would say, you know, to someone without
并把这拍成一个戏剧性的故事，我会，这就是我会关注的重点，是的。对罗伯特·卡罗提出建议，这在某种程度上有点自大，你知道的，但是你知道的。不，不，不，我的意思是。连猫都可以看国王。我有种方式，你知道的，但是你知道的，连猫都可以看国王。我的意思是，如果我要把这拍成电影，我会对某个人说，在不
explaining, you know, the ventilation system of the Holland tunnel, I would say you're an engineer who really knows how to do this. And you see this guy as a bureaucrat pretending to be an engineer. That's the level which you should treat your like your disdain for him, uh, action. You know, that's, that's what I mean. That's really good insight. That's great insight is his character because he comes off, he's someone who we'll, we'll see later if we, if we mention it that, uh, Caro talked to him. He interviewed Sengstad before Sengstad died in 1969, I think. And he comes across as a very forceful figure who sees through Robert Moses. He does, he is not going to get fooled by any of this.
解释荷兰隧道通风系统的情况下，我会说你是一个真正知道怎么做事的工程师。而你把这家伙看作是一个假装成工程师的官僚。这就是你对待他对他的蔑视的程度，行动。你知道的，这就是我的意思。这是非常深刻的见解。对于他的性格来说，这是一个极好的见解，因为他给人的印象是，他是一个我们会看到的人，如果我们提到了的话，卡罗采访过他。他在辛格斯特德于1969年左右去世前采访了他。他给人的印象是一个非常强势的人物，他看穿了罗伯特·摩西。他的确如此，他不会被任何这些把戏愚弄。
And I just want to give a tip of my hat to Singstad. I've crossed through the Holland tunnel thousands of times in my life. And I didn't die once. So that ventilation system, I assume they're using the same one. It still works really well. Um, so Moses can't smooth Singstad, as we said, it's not going to work. So next he tries using his allies in Albany to delay the project until it loses its federal funding, but that doesn't work either.
我想向辛格斯特德致敬。我这辈子穿过荷兰隧道成千上万次。我一次也没有死。所以那个通风系统，我假设他们用的是同一个。它依然运作得很好。嗯，所以摩西无法忽悠辛格斯特德，正如我们所说，这行不通。所以接下来他试图利用他在奥尔巴尼的盟友来拖延这个项目，直到它失去联邦资金，但这也没有用。
And he's basically saying, I will either control this or I will destroy it. I will sabotage it if I can't have it. And earlier we saw him have a project he desperately wanted to build and he accrued power to make it real. Now, when someone else has a project that he can't control, he's going to try to use that power to wreck it. And for no other reason than that, he wants to have control of as project that he can't control, he's gonna try to use that power to wreck it. And for no other reason than that, he wants to have control of as much as he can.
他基本上是在说，要么我控制它，要么我毁了它。如果我得不到它，我就会破坏它。早些时候我们看到他有一个他拼命想要建造的项目，他积累了权力来让它成为现实。现在，当别人有一个他无法控制的项目时，他会试图利用这种权力去摧毁它。没有别的理由，就是因为他想控制一个他无法控制的项目，他会试图利用这种权力去摧毁它。没有别的理由，就是因为他想控制尽可能多的东西。
If there's some big transportation related project in the New York area, he wants it or he's gonna destroy it. He doesn't care what the effect is. He doesn't care who that hurts. And just to be clear, since we'd spent so much time talking about the Holland Tunnel, this is about the Brooklyn Battery Tunnel. Yes, the Holland Tunnel is built already.
如果纽约地区有任何大型交通相关项目，要么他说了算，要么他就毁了它。他不在乎结果是什么。他不在乎这会伤害谁。为了说清楚，既然我们花了这么多时间讨论荷兰隧道，这是关于布鲁克林电池隧道的。是的，荷兰隧道已经建成了。
That exists. Moses is late to the party. He can't do anything about that. This Tunnel. Yes, the Holland Tunnel is built already. That exists. Moses is late to the party. He can't do anything about that. This is about specifically the, well, the Queens Midtown Tunnel and the Brooklyn Battery Tunnel. We're going to talk about the Brooklyn Battery Tunnel a lot in this chapter. The Queens Midtown Tunnel,
那是存在的。摩西错过了时机。他对那个无能为力。这是关于特定地，嗯，皇后区中城隧道和布鲁克林电池隧道。我们将在这一章中大量讨论布鲁克林电池隧道。皇后区中城隧道，
I mean, even compared to the other tunnels in New York, it doesn't get a lot of attention. And in this book, it doesn't get a lot of attention. It's very much the neglected child of the New York Tunnels, but that's okay. So that's 1936 that's happening. Now we are moving a little forward. By 1938, the federal work relief money that Moses has been using to maintain that power, it's starting to dry up. The depression has been, they've been going through it and it feels like it's starting to end
我的意思是，即使与纽约的其他隧道相比，它也没有得到太多关注。在这本书中，它也没有得到太多关注。它非常像是纽约隧道里被忽视的孩子，但没关系。所以那是1936年发生的事情。现在我们要稍微向前推进。到1938年，摩西一直用来维持权力的联邦工作救济资金开始枯竭了。大萧条已经经历过了，感觉它开始走向结束
a little bit. The war is going to start ramping things up. That's where the money is going to go. It is storm clouds over Europe. That's where the money is going to have to be directed rather than employment at home, just for employment sake. Uh, and so Moses needs money and there's a new source of federal funds that is coming up, public housing money. This is a subject Moses has never really been super interested in. He doesn't care about housing the poor. He doesn't care about doing much of anything for the poor, but now there are hundreds of millions of dollars available for public housing
一点点。战争将开始加速事情的发展。资金将流向那里。欧洲上空乌云密布。资金将不得不流向那里，而不是为了就业而就业的国内就业。嗯，所以摩西需要钱，而一个新的联邦资金来源正在出现，公共住房资金。这是一个摩西从未真正超级感兴趣的主题。他不在乎为穷人提供住房。他不在乎为穷人做太多事情，但现在有数亿美元可用于公共住房
and he wants that money for his projects. So as with the tunneling authority, he sets out to replace the city housing authority with a group he can control. And once again, he comes up against LaGuardia showing more backbone than before because LaGuardia, he does care about public housing. He has a very personal stake in it because he believes that his wife and his child who died of tuberculosis, that they died of that because of the tenement they lived in, that it was the ventilation, the sewage, everything about it was bad. And he blames that for their deaths. And while reading this, it was just like
他想把这些钱用在他的项目上。因此，就像对待隧道管理局一样，他着手用一个他能控制的集团来取代城市住房管理局。再一次，他遇到了表现出比以前更多骨气的拉瓜迪亚，因为拉瓜迪亚确实关心公共住房。他对此有着非常个人的利害关系，因为他相信他的妻子和因结核病夭折的孩子，他们之所以死于那个病，是因为他们住的廉租公寓，通风、下水道，所有的一切都很糟糕。他将他们的死归咎于此。在阅读这段时，就好像
imagining a mayor of New York whose family lived in a tenement, not when he was a child, but when he was a married man, and who later on we'll see has no money when he leaves office and when he dies. Well, that makes me think of is like how much we spent so much time praising Moses at the time for not taking graph, not being on the take. And this whole time, like, you know,
想象一个纽约市长，他的家人住在廉租公寓里，不是在他小时候，而是在他作为一个已婚男人时，并且我们稍后会看到他在离职和去世时身无分文。嗯，这让我想到了我们在当时花了很多时间赞美摩西不拿回扣、不收黑钱。而与此同时，你知道，
LaGuardia clearly isn't doing so well for himself either. You know, like it's kind of notable, I don't know. Like, you know. It shows you, I guess, sometimes that when you publicize a thing, you can get credit for it when you don't, when other people, there's a, there's a story about Heineken years ago.
拉瓜迪亚显然也没有为自己谋取太多好处。你知道的，这有点引人注目，我不知道。就像，你知道的。我想这向你表明，有时当你大肆宣传一件事时，当你没有这样做时，当其他人——有一个关于喜力啤酒多年的故事。
I think their advert campaign was like, when back when bottles would be returned to the bottler and then reused again, they're like, we steam clean our bottles. And it was like, yeah, everybody does. But they made it sound like only they did it. Everyone else is using dirty bottles. You know? So if you publicize that you do a thing, it doesn't matter if other people do it.
我想他们的广告活动就像是，当瓶子被退回给装瓶商并再次重复使用时，他们说：我们用蒸汽清洗我们的瓶子。就像是，是的，每个人都这么做。但他们说得好像只有他们这么做。其他所有人都在用脏瓶子。你知道的？所以如果你公开宣称你做了一件事，其他人是否也做并不重要。
You get it. So this is a personal issue for LaGuardia. And Moses knows, if I'm going to steal control of public housing away from the current authority, I can't do it directly through LaGuardia. I'm going to have to kind of build a groundswell of public opinion that demands I take it. So he secretly arranges for some reform organizations to rent the auditorium of the Museum of Natural History, my single greatest, most favorite place on earth that I love the most.
你得到了认可。所以这对拉瓜迪亚来说是一个私人的问题。摩西知道，如果我要把公共住房的控制权从现有的管理局手中夺过来，我不能直接通过拉瓜迪亚去做。我必须建立一种要求我接管的公众舆论高潮。因此，他秘密安排了一些改革组织来租用自然历史博物馆的礼堂，这是我地球上最伟大的、最喜欢的、我最爱的地方。
And any trip I take to New York that I don't go to that museum is a wasted trip as far as I'm concerned. Um, so he can present a speech titled housing and recreation. He convinced his WNYC to broadcast it over the radio and he hands out to the audience, the event, these pre printed brochures proposing this enormous slum clearance and a public housing program where rather than rehabilitate pre existing buildings, which is what LaGuardia wants to do, he wants to tear them all down and build all these blocks of new housing. And he's clearly trying to recreate the triumph he had back in episode four when he gave his
我去纽约的任何一次旅行如果不去那个博物馆，对我和我而言就是白去了。嗯，这样他就可以发表一篇题为“住房与娱乐”的演讲。他说服他的WNYC通过广播播出这篇演讲，并向活动的观众分发了这些预先印刷的小册子，提议进行大规模的贫民窟清除和公共住房计划，与拉瓜迪亚想要修复预先存在的建筑不同，他想把它们全部拆掉，建造所有这些新住房街区。他显然是在试图重现他在第四集中的辉煌，当时他发表了
speech about his unified transportation plan and people loved it so much that there was no way to stop it. And the cost of his program, it's going to be $245 million. And he says he can do it without raising city real estate taxes. And his plan is clearly, I'm going to do $245 million. And he says he can do it without raising city real estate taxes. And his plan is clearly, I'm going to do what I did before. I'm going to present this plan. People are going to love it so much that it will be politically unfeasible to stand against it. Little does he know. This is the best.
关于他的统一交通计划的演讲，人们非常喜欢它以至于无法阻止它。他的计划成本将是2.45亿美元。他说他可以在不提高城市房地产税的情况下做到这一点。他的计划显然是，我要做我以前做过的事。我要提出这个计划。人们会非常喜欢它，以至于在政治上反对它是不可行的。他哪里知道。这是最棒的。
This is so great. This is children's movie level kind of like planning and plotting to undermine Moses that in a good way that LaGuardia has gotten ahold of one of these brochures ahead of time earlier that day and has arranged with the WNYC station heads to pretend to broadcast Moses's speech, even to the point of having technicians there pretending they're operating machines and giving Moses the thumbs up to start talking because they're ready for him. While the station itself actually goes off the air for the extent of the
这太棒了。这简直是儿童电影级别的规划和密谋，旨在以一种好的方式破坏摩西，拉瓜迪亚在当天早些时候提前弄到了其中一本小册子，并与WNYC电台负责人安排假装广播摩西的演讲，甚至到了让技术人员在那里假装操作机器，并对摩西竖起大拇指让他开始说话，因为他们已经为他准备好了。而电台本身实际上在整个
speech and Moses doesn't learn this until at he's finishing the speech. When I think one of his people go turns on a radio and there's nothing happen. There's nothing coming out of it. Uh, the, so he's this whole plan of his has been undermined and been basically wasted that, that he's announced the plan to the people in the auditorium, but that doesn't help him too much. This groundswell he's gonna get from the people of New York is not gonna happen.
演讲期间都处于停播状态，摩西直到演讲结束时才知道这一点。当时我想他的某个人去打开收音机，结果什么也没有发生。什么声音都没有传出来。所以，他的整个计划都被破坏了，基本上白费了，他在礼堂里向人们宣布了这个计划，但这对他没有太大帮助。他从纽约人民那里得到的这种民意高潮是不会发生的。
And LaGuardia manages just to out-think Moses in this case. He builds his own housing projects without Moses' input. And that my favorite aspect of this is, Moses then submits a bill to the government to pay for the printing of the brochures, and LaGuardia tells the comptroller, don't do it, don't pay it. Like this is, Moses can cover that amount. And so LaGuardia sees really clearly now that Moses is trying to expand his power beyond parks, beyond park-related roads, beyond roads to any kind of construction that he can take,
在这种情况下，拉瓜迪亚设法在智力上胜过了摩西。他在没有摩西干预的情况下建造了自己的住房项目。我最喜欢的一个方面是，摩西随后向政府提交了一张账单，要求支付小册子的印刷费用，而拉瓜迪亚告诉审计长，不要这样做，不要付钱。就像这样，摩西可以自己承担那个金额。所以拉瓜迪亚现在非常清楚地看到，摩西正试图将他的权力扩展到公园之外、公园相关道路之外、从道路扩展到任何他能攫取的建筑，
that he can get the money and the power from. And he decides Moses needs to be curbed in some way. And he's seeing, as Carol presents it, he's seeing that Moses is also so focused on the upper classes to the exclusion of the people that LaGuardia, as with Al Smith before him, thought of as his real people, the kind of poor New Yorkers. He still respects Moses' abilities. He still wants Moses' abilities to be working for him.
从中他可以获得资金和权力。他决定必须以某种方式遏制摩西。正如卡罗所呈现的那样，他看到摩西也如此专注于上流阶层，以至于排除了拉瓜迪亚（以及之前的阿尔·史密斯）认为是他的真正人民的普通人，也就是贫困的纽约人。他仍然尊重摩西的能力。他仍然希望摩西的能力为他工作。
But he wants to reorient Moses' goals and do that. He starts cutting the park budgets. He starts canceling projects. He feels like he's starting to get the upper hand on Moses, but what he doesn't realize, and as we'll see in the next chapter, Moses is leaving the era when it matters to him at all what the mirror of New York thinks or wants from him because he has discovered a new source of potential power that will take him to the point of his highest degree
但他想重塑摩西的目标。为此，他开始削减公园预算。他开始取消项目。他觉得自己开始在与摩西的较量中占据上风，但他没有意识到的是，正如我们将在下一章中看到的，摩西正在离开这样一个时代：纽约市长怎么想或对他的期望对他来说已经完全不重要了，因为他发现了一个潜在权力的全新源泉，这将把他带到他控制力和权力的最高峰，这将使他在纽约体系内成为一个小皇帝。那个制度就是被称为公共管理局的机构。我太兴奋能谈论公共管理局了。这将会非常棒。这就是第28章，“织机上的经线”。公共管理局。我太兴奋能谈论公共管理局了。这将会非常棒。这就是第28章，“织机上的经线”。这完全是关于公共管理局的创建。
of control and power that will make him kind of a mini emperor within the New York system. And that is the institution known as the public authority. I'm so excited about talking about public authorities. It's gonna be amazing. And this is chapter 28, the warp on the loom. public authority. I'm so excited about talking about public authorities. It's gonna be amazing. And this is chapter 28, the warp on the loom. That's all about the creation of the public authority.
并且它进行了长篇大论。我喜欢这一章。这是，我喜欢这一章。这是一个伟大的章节。这是一个，考虑到特别是，这是一个长达20或21页的关于公共管理局官僚运作以及它为
And it goes to great lengths. I love this chapter. This is, I love this chapter. It's a great chapter. This is a, it is considering especially, this is a 20 or 21 page chapter about the functioning of public authorities bureaucratically and the legal openings it creates
滥用该权力所创造的法律漏洞的章节。它是如此令人兴奋。就像是一个，一个，一个大师级的章节。听到卡罗展开这一切让人兴奋不已。所以首先他必须解释什么是公共管理局。我知道我在读这本书之前，并不真正理解它和其他东西之间的区别。
for the abuse of that authority. And it is so exhilarating. Like it's a, it's a, it's a tour de force chapter. It's exciting to hear Caro unfolding this. And so first he's got to explain what a public authority is. I know I didn't, before I read this book, I didn't really understand the difference between it and the other thing.
它们是半独立的组织。它们通过出售债券获得公共资金，有时，以及在像MTA（当时并不存在）这样的一些政府资金支持下获得资金。你知道的，我们稍后会在书里讲到，但它们有创建特定事物的具体目标。它们出售债券来资助该事物。然后它们在建设该事物的期间像私营公司一样运作。它们的记录是私密的。它们被允许向公众收取其设施的使用费，以便向债券持有人偿还债务。
They are semi-independent organizations. They're publicly funded through the sale of bonds and sometime, and through some government funding in the case of like the MTA, which didn't exist at this time. You know, we'll get to that later in the book, but they have specific goals to create a specific thing. They sell bonds to fund that thing. And then they operate like a private corporation for the duration of the construction of the thing. Their records are private. They're allowed to charge the public for the use of their things in order to pay back the bondholders.
而摩西通过他通过的一套新法律中的隐藏条款（正如我们稍后要谈到的），基本上让自己拥有了以不同于以往管理局的方式处理债券的权力，并将这个部落管理局转变成一个不朽的、自治的、个人的封地，他用它来基本上推搡成千上万甚至数百万的其他普通人。正如卡罗所说，公共管理局可以追溯到英国，可以追溯到几个世纪前。他
And Moses, through the hidden provisions, as we'll talk about in a new set of laws he gets passed, basically allows himself the power to handle bonds differently than authorities have in the past and will turn the tribal authority into this immortal self-governing, personal fiefdom that he uses to basically push other people around in the thousands, if not millions. Public authorities, as Caro says, they go back to England, they go back centuries. He
并没有像他可以做的那样，深入探讨长达数个世纪的英国公共管理局历史，考虑到他曾对长岛的创建进行了如此地质学般的详尽描述。我想我们都很感激这一点。但管理局在美洲还是比较新的。他可以做的那样，考虑到他曾对长岛的创建进行了如此地质学般的详尽描述。我想我们都很感激这一点。但管理局在美洲还是比较新的。纽约和新泽西港务局已经存在了。那是草率拼凑起来的。
does not go into as much detail in the centuries-long history of English public authorities as he could have, considering he went into such geologic detail about the creation of Long Island. And I think we all appreciate that. But authorities were relatively new in America. he could have considering he went into such geologic detail about the creation of Long Island. And I think we all appreciate that. But authorities were relatively new in America. The Port Authority of New York and New Jersey existed already. That was kind of sloppily put together.
这有点一团糟，正如去过那里的任何人所知，港务局巴士总站也是一团糟。那是个恶心的地方。坐巴士并不是一个愉快的地方。传统上，正如我所说，公共管理局专注于单一项目。它们出售债券来资助它。它们收集收入，偿还债券。然后管理局就停止存在了。
It's kind of a mess, much as Port Authority bus terminal for anyone who's been there knows is also a mess. It's a gross place to be. It's not not a pleasant place to take a bus. Traditionally, as I was saying, public authorities were focused on a single project. They sold bonds to fund it. They collected revenue, they paid off the bonds. And then the authority just goes out of existence.
而这正是公共管理局的关键所在。它们是有限期的组织。它们不会永远存在。一旦它们还清了债务，创建该事物的设施就会成为公共财产，成为城市或——的财产，而且它们不复存在了。摩西早期的管理局也符合这种模式。所以他总是让人们相信，当债券还清时，他项目上的收费就会消失。这些是临时收费，但现在他的想法正在改变，因为他的桥梁带来的收入远超任何人预期的收益。在三十年代，
And this is really key to the public authority. They are limited term existence organizations. They don't last forever. And once they get paid, once they pay off their bills, the thing that created becomes public property, becomes the property of the city or, and they don't exist anymore. And Moses early authorities fit this mold too. And so he always led people to believe that the tolls on his projects would go away when the bonds were paid off. These were temporary tolls, but now his thinking is changing because his bridges are bringing in so much more money than anyone expected them to bring in. In the late thirties,
亨利·哈德逊大桥每年获利60万美元。特里伯勒大桥每年带来130万美元的利润。在三十年代，当一个汉堡只卖五分钱的时候，你知道的，或者诸如此类。所以这是一大笔钱。这些桥梁上付费通行的汽车数量只增不减。
the Henry Hudson bridge is profiting $600,000 per year. The Trial Brower Bridge, it's bringing in $1.3 million in profit a year. In the thirties, back when a hamburger cost a nickel, you know, or whatever. So this is a lot of money. And the number of toll paying cars on those bridges, it's only going up.
每年它都在赚更多的钱。根据法律，这意味着这些桥梁上的债券可以在十年内还清，而不是原计划的四十年。然后根据法律，这意味着这些桥梁上的债券可以在十年内还清，而不是原计划的四十年。然后收费就会取消。这将是城市基础设施融资的一个重大成功故事，他建造了这座巨大的桥梁，它在运载汽车方面取得了如此巨大的成功，即使在未能
It's only making more money each year. And under the law, this means the bonds on those bridges, they could be paid off in one decade rather than four decades, which was the plan. And then the law, this means the bonds of those bridges, they could be paid off in one decade, rather than four decades, which was the plan. And then the tolls would be removed. And that it would be a major success story of urban infrastructure financing, he built this enormous bridge, it was so much more successful in carrying cars, if not in
减少交通方面不如预期的那样，然后纽约人将有30年的时间不必在这座他们以为必须付费的桥梁上交费。摩西会在乎这个吗？一点也不。他无法从城市基础设施融资的惊人成功故事中得到任何东西。不，他的权力并非植根于完成目标然后放弃实现这些目标的工具。它在于政治权力的运用，归根结底在于金钱的运用。
cutting down traffic, then it was supposed to be, and then you'd have 30 years of New Yorkers not having to pay tolls on this bridge that they thought they were going to have to. What does Moses care about that? Nothing. He can't get anything from amazing success stories of urban infrastructure financing. No, his power is not rooted in accomplishing goals and then relinquishing the tools to get those goals done. It's in the use of political power and ultimately it's in the use of money.
正如他们在《歌厅》中所说，金钱让世界转动。这不仅仅是花掉那些特定的钱，正如他们在《歌厅》中所说，金钱让世界转动。这不仅仅是花掉那些特定的钱，而是金钱赋予他的权力，去吸引银行家购买债券、提供资金，甚至允许他获得更多资金。因此，到1938年，他的管理局每年的总收入是450万美元。这和他的公园部门预算一样大。但如果他能修改法律，允许他尽可能长时间地保留这些钱，他就可以利用这450万美元来资助价值81万美元的四年期债券，作为真正的建设资金。不仅如此，因为他建造的桥梁越多，他获得的收费就越多，
As they say in cabaret, money makes the world go round. And it's not just spending that particular money, as they say in cabaret, money makes the world go round. And it's not just spending that particular money, but the power that that money gives him to entice bankers, to purchase bonds, to fund, to allow him even more funding. And so by 1938, the total income annually of his authorities is $4.5 million. That's as large as his park department budget. But if he can change the law to allow him to hold on to that money as long as he can, he can use that $4.5 million to capitalize four-year bonds worth $81 million in genuine construction funding. And not only that, because the more bridges he builds, the more tolls he's
他能够发行的债券利率就越低，他能卖出的就越多。因此，根据他的计算，根据卡罗的说法，他获得的每一美元通行费收入，他就可以为建造更多的桥梁资本化18美元。所以是18倍。他可以，他可以把这笔钱用于，一旦你建造了更多的桥梁，你就可以带进更多的收入来发行，更多的债券，来建造更多的桥梁。他只是，他可以做到，这是一个自我维持的金钱和建设机器，他的梦想越来越大，因为他并不满足。
bringing in, the lower the interest rates on the bonds that he can afford to float, the more he can sell. So by his reckoning, according to Caro, for every dollar in toll revenue that he can afford to float, the more he can sell. So by his reckoning, according to Caro for every dollar in toll revenue that he gets, he can capitalize $18 for the building of more bridges. So it's 18 fold. He can, he can use that money for, and once you build more bridges, you can bring in more revenue to float, more bonds, to build more bridges. He just, he can do, he can, it's a self perpetuating money and building machine and his dreams are getting bigger and bigger because he's not happy.
一旦你建造了一条高速公路，你怎么能满足于建造另一条高速公路呢？你必须建造一个主要的系统。一旦你建造了一座桥，你怎么能满足于此呢？你必须建造更多的桥梁。城市的很大一部分都没有高速公路穿过。有那么多的土地还没有变成巨大的球场和半满的体育场，就像那条他从未能建造的火灾岛高速公路
Once you build an expressway, how can you be building happy building another expressway? You got to build a major system. Once you built one bridge, how can you be happy with that? You got to build more bridges. There's so much of the city that does not have expressways running through it. There's so much land that has not yet been turned into enormous ball fields and half filled stadiums, like that Fire Island Expressway he never got to build
因为那两个老太太不肯卖掉她们的房子。就像他仍然可以建造那个一样。这座城市没有钱做这个。州政府不想在这上面花任何钱。联邦政府很快将不得不把资金转向摧毁纳粹德国。如果摩西能够扣留管理局的收入，他就不需要来自联邦政府的资金，
because those two old ladies wouldn't sell their houses. Like he could still build that. The city does not have the money for this. The state does not want to spend any money on this. The federal government is soon going to have to turn its money towards destroying Nazi Germany. If Moses can hold onto the revenue of the authorities, he won't need money from the federal government,
城市政府，州政府的资金。他将有自己的钱可以挥霍。他将成为自己的融资机器，这与民主政治的运作方式完全背道而驰，但这从未阻止过他。对吧？是的。因为其中的一个关键部分是，他过去依赖公众支持。那是他的看家本领。就像他身后有公众的支持一样。
the city government, the state government. He'll have his own money to play with. He will be his own funding machine, which is so totally not the way democratic politics is supposed to work, but that's never stopped him before. Right? Yeah. Cause a key part of this is like, he used to depend on public support. That was his thing. Like he had the support of the public behind him.
但正如我们上次了解到的那样，随着阿尔·史密斯的倒台，公众的支持和公众的热爱是多么脆弱的芦苇。他正在了解到，一个坚固得多的芦苇是8100万美元。是的，有个老笑话关于金钱会说话而其他东西会走路。对现在的他来说，公众支持就是那个“其他东西”。
But as we learned last time with the sort of fall of Al Smith is that public support and public love is a slender read to lean on. And he's learning that a much more robust read to lean on is $81 million. Yeah, there's an old saying about how money talks and another thing walks. And for him now public support is that other thing.
金钱是具体的，它是人们会关注的东西。有了他自己的钱，他可以做一些事情，比如无视公务员法规。正是这些公务员法规，当他年轻时曾是它们的超级粉丝，现在却一直在阻碍他。而公务员委员会唯一的权力就是它可以否决薪酬支付。它可以取消支付或阻止它们。如果他控制了一点钱，他才不在乎公务员委员会
Money is concrete, it's the thing that people will pay attention to. And with his own money, he can do things like ignore civil service regulations. Those same civil service regulations, he was such a big fan of as a young man, they are stymying him all the time. And the only power the Civil Service Commission has is that it can disapprove salary payments. It can cancel payments or block them. If he controls a little money, he doesn't care if the civil service commission's
是否不允许他付钱给某个人，他可以随心所欲。他可以雇佣任何人。他可以付给他们任何他想付的薪水。他可以给他们配专属汽车。他可以让他们住进自己的房子里。他可以组建他一直梦想的忠诚、奉献的专业人员团队。
not gonna allow him to pay somebody, he can do what he wants. He can hire whoever he wants. He can pay them whatever he wants. He can get them their own cars. He can get them in their own houses. He can assemble the loyal, dedicated staff of professionals he's always dreamed of.
然后他可以用他们来制作研究报告和蓝图。他可以资助这些研究报告和蓝图，然后将它们作为既成事实呈交给政府，因为哪个政客会冒着风险告诉公众，他们不能拥有这个伟大的新摩西项目——摩西有钱建造它，而且不会花他们一分钱，除了不得不应付它
And then he can use them to produce studies and blueprints. He can fund those studies and blueprints that he can then present to the governments as a fait accompli because what politician is gonna risk telling the public, they can't have this great new Moses thing that Moses has the money to build that will cost them nothing except having to deal with it
余下的生活以及无数后来代人的生活。金钱可以成为他绕过过去挡路之物的终极手段。他从来没有能够以他想要的方式为他认为完成工作所必需的技术拨付资金。制作比例模型来游说人们，
for the rest of their lives and for innumerable generations to come. Money can be his end run around the things that got in his way in the past. He has never been able to appropriate money in the ways he wanted for the techniques that he thinks are necessary to get things done. Making scale models to persuade people,
买游艇并在上面举行派对来拉拢媒体，雇佣猎犬去挖掘对手的黑料。你不能去公务员委员会说：“对啦，对啦，我需要钱找一个侦探来查查议会里的这家伙有没有外遇。”但如果你有自己的钱，你就可以直接这么做。
buying yachts and throwing parties on them, to woo the press, hiring bloodhounds, to dig up dirt on opponents. You can't go to the Civil Service Commission and be like, yeah, yeah, I need money for a detective to find out if this guy in the assembly is having an affair. But if you have your own money, you could just do that.
买游艇并在上面办派对来讨好媒体，雇佣寻血猎犬去挖掘对手的黑料。你不能去找公务员委员会说，对对，我需要钱找个侦探去查查议会里的这家伙有没有外遇。但如果你自己有钱，你就可以直接这么做。
And if he can keep the authority revenue, he can do whatever he wants with it. And a public authority would give him the same, some of the same powers that a sovereign state has. An authority can issue bonds, which are a legal agreement between a buyer and a seller. That is a technically a contract between the floater of the bond and the buyer of the bond. And it'll settle law in the United States of America going back almost to the beginning of
如果他能保留管理局的收入，他就可以随心所欲地使用这些资金。公共管理局将赋予他与主权国家相同的一些权力。管理局可以发行债券，这是买方和卖方之间的法律协议。这在技术上是债券发行人与债券购买者之间的一份合同。美利坚合众国的法律判例可以追溯到几乎
the country that a contract, illegal contract cannot be changed, undone, canceled, interfered with by any government office whatsoever. It's like Moses has discovered a cheat code for the law, where it's like magic, where he's like, if I just write the powers of my authority into the bonds, into the wording of the bonds that I'm selling, then that becomes a contract and the legislature, they can repeal laws, but they can't cancel contracts. And so as long as the authority exists, and he's at the head of it, he has whatever power he can write into those bonds. Now I was wondering, and I'll wonder this again possibly
国家建立之初，合同、非法的合同是绝对不能被任何政府办公室更改、撤销、取消或干涉的。这就像摩西为法律发现了一个作弊码，简直像魔法一样，他似乎在说，如果我把管理局的权力写进债券里，写进我正在出售的债券的措辞中，那么这就变成了一项合同，而立法机关可以废除法律，但他们不能取消合同。因此，只要管理局存在，且他担任负责人，他就拥有他能写进那些债券中的任何权力。现在我当时在想，我可能还会再次想到这一点
as it comes up again, what are the limits of this? Because it's not like he can write into the bonds, Robert Moses can murder people. Like there are certain laws that he can't get around, but Carroll kind of presents it as this kind of magic end run around everyone else. That if it's written in a contract, the government can't do anything about it.
当这个问题再次出现时，这到底有什么界限？因为这并不是说他可以在债券里写：罗伯特·摩西可以杀人。就像有些法律是他无法规避的，但卡罗把这描绘成了一种对所有其他人的神奇终极规避手段。如果写在合同里，政府就拿它没办法。
And I wonder, Roman, you're a professional lawyer. What's the, what's the, what's the. What are the limits of that? Yeah, the, what's the, what's the. What are the limits of that? Yeah, yeah, what are the limits of that? I mean. For anyone listening, Roman is not a professional lawyer. Please do not take legal advice from Roman.
我在想，罗曼，你是个专业律师。这其中的界限是什么？界限是什么？是的，这其中的界限是什么？是的，这其中的界限是什么？我的意思是。对于任何在听的听众，罗曼不是专业律师。请不要听从罗曼的法律建议。
Yeah. Again, I'm really, really just making stuff up here, but mostly it's like, it's just like, you know, for fraud, for things that are mistakes, you know, like yesterday as we were recording this, like Berkshire Hathaway stock went down to like, dropped 99% by some sort of technical. That sounds very visible.
是的。再说一次，我真的、真的只是在这里胡编乱造，但主要就像是，你知道的，比如欺诈，比如由于失误造成的事情，你知道的，就像昨天我们录音的时候，伯克希尔·哈撒韦公司的股票由于某种技术原因跌了99%。听起来非常明显。
And people bought it at that level. And you know, you could say that's a contract, but it got voided by regulatory authorities that just said, hey, this is a mistake. This wasn't meant to be this way. And normally that would be a contract, but it's, you know, like people recognize that two sides of the party didn't have all the information to agree to
人们在这个价位买入了它。你知道的，你可以说这是一份合同，但它被监管机构宣布无效了，监管机构只是说，嘿，这是一个错误。本来不该是这样的。通常情况下这会是一份合同，但你知道的，就像人们认识到双方并没有掌握全部信息来达成
it properly and therefore it can be voided. You know, like I think there's all kinds of reasons, but I think like a bond measure because how carefully it has to be worded, it has to be written, it has to be, you know, bought and sold, it would be extraordinary for the U.S. government to come in and void it. I guess yet that you're saying, you're saying this bond is being purchased on the understanding as written into the bond that this authority is capable of doing these things.
适当的协议，因此它可以被宣布无效。你知道的，我觉得这里面有各种各样的原因，但我认为，像债券议案由于其措辞必须极其谨慎，必须以书面形式拟定，必须被购买和出售，美国政府介入并宣布其无效将是非同寻常的。我想你刚才说的是，你是在说这笔债券是在这样的理解下购买的——即债券中明文规定该管理局有能力做这些事情。
And to take that power away, you, I guess you'd have a legal case that you are interfering with a private semi-private contract. Okay. That makes sense. I get it. But he can't write in like Robert Moses is the, is now the president of triberalsvania, you know, an independent sovereign nation, you know.
如果要剥夺这种权力，我想你会有一个法律诉讼依据，即你在干涉一份私人、半私人的合同。好吧。这说得通。我明白了。但他不能在里面写：罗伯特·摩西现在是三区公司的总统，你知道的，一个独立的主权国家，你知道的。
I think there's, yeah, there's limits in the, there's different texts in the creation that would limit its ability to do these things, but these are very basic things. You build a thing, you sell a bond for it, you get paid revenues for it to sell off that bond and interest and undermining that in a specific sense would make a sort of shaky foundation forever doing that. You know, like when you default on bonds, it's a very big deal to avoid them arbitrarily. It would just undermine a system that is extremely important that it stay in place and not be undermined.
我认为，是的，创建条例中有不同的文本会限制其做这些事情的能力，但这些都是非常基础的事情。你建造了一个东西，为此出售了一笔债券，你从中获得收入来支付该债券及利息，而在具体意义上破坏这一点，将为今后做这种事奠定一个动摇的根基。你知道的，就像当你债券违约时，任意作废它们是一件非常严重的事情。这只会破坏一个至关重要的系统，该系统必须保持原状而不能被破坏。
Like people have to believe that they're buying bonds and will be paid back. They can fail by chance, they can fail by all kinds of reasons. Um, but we count on those being, um, uh, solid contracts. So Moses, that makes sense that Moses is taking advantage of the fact that we live within a world built on a fiction that money has a value and agreements are have, have concrete truth. Yeah. Okay.
就像人们必须相信他们购买了债券并且会得到偿还。它们可能会因偶然因素而失败，可能会因各种原因而失败，嗯，但我们指望这些是、嗯、稳固的合同。所以摩西，这说得通，摩西正在利用这样一个事实：我们生活在一个建立在虚构之上的世界里，金钱有价值，协议具有具体的真理。是的。好吧。
And you can, and to, to undo his would be to undo that, to bring into question that basic fiction that our entire civilization basically rests on. That's right. That's right. Okay. That makes sense. So Carol says that in proposing doing this, Moses is effectively proposing a fourth branch of government independent of the usual three branches. And he knows that the people who make up those three branches, the legislature, the mayor, you know, the city council, the governor, say nothing of the courts who don't really come into it at this moment. They would not be okay with that.
而你可以，要推翻他的东西，就是推翻这一点，就是对我们整个文明基本上所依赖的基本虚构产生质疑。正是如此。正是如此。好吧。这说得通。所以卡罗说，在提议这样做时，摩西实际上是在提议建立独立于通常三个部门之外的第四个政府部门。他知道组成这三个部门的人——立法机关、市长（你知道的，市议会、州长），更不用说那些在这个时刻实际上并不怎么介入的法院了——是不会对此感到满意的。
So if he's going to put through a law that allows him to hold onto that revenue, he's going to have to keep his true purpose a secret from them. He'd have to write a law that eliminates some of the safeguards without seeming to eliminate them. To do that, why, you'd need the best bill drafter in Albany. You would. And luckily he didn't have to look very far to find him. Just looked the man in the mirror.
因此，如果他要通过一项允许他保留该收入的法律，他就必须对他们隐藏他的真实意图。他必须起草一项在表面上看起来没有消除、实则消除了某些保障措施的法律。要做到这一点，为什么，你需要奥尔巴尼最厉害的法案起草人。确实需要。幸运的是，他不用费神去找。照照镜子就行了。
That's what we saw. But this is the real key. Coming up with the idea to capitalize on your, to turn $4 million into $80 million is one thing. Probably that innovation could have, other people could have come up with that. But what he really has figured out here, which is really quite genius and quite evil,
这就是我们所看到的。但这是真正的关键。想出利用你的、将4000万美元变成8000万美元的点子是一回事。也许这种创新，其他人也能想出来。但他在这里真正弄明白的事情——这可以说是相当天才也相当邪恶——
is this idea of the self-imposed lifespan of a public authority and how to subvert that. And so instead of accepting that you build a thing, you sell bonds for it to pay for it, they make revenue, you pay off the bonds and those happen in 40 years, he writes into the bill, very far into the bill that people don't notice or read.
就是公共管理局自我强加的寿命这个概念，以及如何颠覆这一概念。因此，他没有接受“你建造一个东西，为了支付它而出售债券，它们产生收入，你偿还债券，这些在40年内完成”的常规做法，而是在法案中——在人们不会注意到或阅读的法案非常靠后的地方——写下了
In section nine, you gotta believe most people are stopping by section three. That's right. That the authority can issue new bonds to refund the original bonds and start the clock again on these new bonds. So effectively, you can just like keep the authority going by using new bonds to pay off the old bonds, starting the clock again and just like having to go and go and go. And that's what he figures out. And it's really something else.
在第九条中，你得相信大多数人在第三条就停下来了。没错。管理局可以发行新债券来赎回原债券，并重新计算这些新债券的期限。所以实际上，你可以通过使用新债券来偿还旧债券，重新计算期限，让它不断地持续下去，以此来维持管理局的运转。这就是他想出来的办法。这真的是非同寻常。
The authority is supposed to go out of commission when it's paid off. But if it never fully pays. The authority is supposed to go out of, out of commission when it's paid off, but if it never fully pays off, it never has to go out of commission. And now he can basically treat the limit of the amount of bonds that he's allowed to issue, not as a ceiling that he can't fund beyond, but as a credit line, essentially that he can always issue new debt to bring himself back up to that and pay off the old bonds and do new bonds and toll revenues keep coming in. And so people want to buy those bonds. They're very attractive because it's, it's incredibly stable.
管理局本应在还清债务时停止运作。但如果它从未完全还清。管理局本应在还清债务时停止运作，但如果它从未完全还清，它就永远不必停止运作。现在他基本上可以将他被允许发行的债券总额的限额，不再视为他不能超额融资的上限，而是一条信贷额度，本质上他总是可以发行新的债务来使自己恢复到那个上限，并偿还旧债券，发行新债券，而通行费收入源源不断地涌入。因此人们想要购买这些债券。它们非常有吸引力，因为它们极其稳定。
You know, you're going to get your return eventually. Right. Right. It's really something else. And it's sort of amazing that he figured this out and actually made it so that he could get away with it, but it is just, it is really anathema to actual democracy. Yes. To get the, there's, you know, there's two, people talk about people.
你知道的，你最终会得到回报。对的。对的。这真的是别具一格。而且令人惊奇的是，他居然想通了这一点，并付诸实践使其得以逃脱惩罚，但这确实与真正的民主背道而驰。是的。要获得，你知道的，有两群人，人们谈论人们。
I've read that about how Congress has kind of the Fed, US Congress has kind of two powers that it controls. There's the power of the purse and the power of the gun, essentially, you know, it can declare war, it can control what gets paid. And if you take away the need to go to the legislature for money, then they lose most of their power over you. I mean, Moses never tested the proposition that he could declare war on another. I mean, he kind of does declare war on the tunnel agency, but you know,
我读到过关于国会如何拥有美联储、美国国会控制的两种权力的文章。基本上有钱袋权和枪杆子权，你知道的，它可以宣战，它可以控制支付什么。如果你剥夺了去立法机关要钱的必要性，那么他们对你的大部分权力就失去了。我的意思是，摩西从未检验过他是否可以向另一个人宣战这一命题。我的意思是，他确实有点向隧道管理局宣战，但你知道的，
it's war by other means, but he's, it really is. Yeah. It's undermining the basic idea of democracy, which is that the people have a say in what's going on in this case, one person will have a say, Robert Moses, because also not only does he slip into that law, the bit about being able to issue new bonds to pay off the old ones and keep things self-repetuating, he puts in a thing that Triborough can handle, you know, any roads that connected to parks, any roads connected to roads connected to parts and quote facilities for the public not inconsistent with the use of the project, which just is anything. Which means anything like as Carol's like what things are inconsistent with the use of a project? Would a
这是通过其他手段进行的战争，但它确实是。是的。它正在破坏民主的基本理念，即人民对正在发生的事情拥有发言权，而在这种情况下，只有一个人拥有发言权，那就是罗伯特·摩西。因为不仅他在那项法律中偷偷加入了关于能够发行新债券来偿还旧债券并使事情自我延续的内容，他还加入了一项条款，即三区公司可以处理（你知道的）与公园相连的任何道路、与和公园相连的道路相连的任何道路，以及“为公众提供的、与项目使用不冲突的设施”，而这实际上意味着任何东西。这意味着任何东西，就像卡罗所说的那样，有什么东西是与项目的使用相冲突的？难道一栋
house, would it, would a parking building be consistent with the use of a road? Like, and he inserts provision taking the power to release the authority's money away from the city comptroller and giving it to the chairman of the authority. And this is all stuff that individually doesn't look like much. If you're a legislator who's working during the day, you've been out drinking all night with your Albany buddies. I don't know if it's the same as it was when Al Smith was there at this point in the thirties, but you have other things going on in your life. Just as somebody who, speaking for myself, I have a family.
房屋、难道一栋停车场建筑会与一条道路的使用相冲突吗？就像是，他插入了一项条款，将释放管理局资金的权力从市主计长手中夺走，交给了管理局主席。而这一切，单独来看似乎都不算什么。如果你是一个白天工作的立法者，你整晚都在和你在奥尔巴尼的酒肉朋友喝酒。我不知道这是否和当年阿尔·史密斯在三十年代那里时一样，但你的生活中还有其他事情要做。作为一个——为自己说话——我有家庭的人，
It's sometimes hard to keep on top of my work that I can't, you know, and my work is not affecting the lives of millions. Uh, you can understand that they are not, they don't are not seeing the full power of this and like we said, there's something really like exhilarating about this chapter, seeing it unfold. You can't help but get kind of caught up in it and just how exciting this implication leads to this implication, which leads to it's like watching, you know, watching the, the, the Lotus flower at the heart of creation unfold or watching a movie where a scientist
有时很难兼顾我的工作，我无法，你知道的，而且我的工作并没有影响数百万人的生活。你可以理解他们没有，他们没有看到这其中的全部威力，就像我们说的，看着这一切展开，有一种真正令人振奋的感觉。你不禁会被卷入其中，并感叹这种含义如何引出那种含义，这就像看着，你知道的，看着造物之心的莲花徐徐绽放，或者看着一部电影，科学家
makes a big discovery and suddenly they're realizing the implications of that discovery. Like it's really, it's an exciting chapter about municipal bonds and the laws governing the creation of authorities. Or any of these sort of modern movies, like the Blackberry movie or the error movie, where it's like, it's's like it's about a genius sort of business move that's figuring something out that has wide ranging implications. I mean I think the main difference here and what should kind of blunt your sense of this is just a person like figuring something out and being his best self and actualizing his
做出重大发现，突然意识到该发现的种种含义。这真是一个关于市政债券以及管理管理局创立的法律的令人兴奋的章节。或者任何这类现代电影，比如《黑莓》或《气垫传奇》（Air），它们就像是关于一个天才般的商业举措，弄清楚了一些具有广泛影响的事情。我的意思是，我认为这里的主要区别——以及应该削弱你那种“这只是一个人弄懂了某事并做最好的自己、实现自己的
dreams is that public authorities are very specific and they have tons of power that we give them. And that power to really destroy people's lives, it has the power for eminent domain, it can really, really affect people's lives in these ways that a normal corporation can't do. And the checks on these powers are this lifespan and this ability to control the money that goes to them.
梦想”的感觉的地方——在于公共管理局非常特殊，它们拥有我们赋予它们的巨大权力。而那种真正摧毁人们生活的权力，它拥有强制征收权，它能以普通公司无法做到的方式真正地、真正地影响人们的生活。对这些权力的制约就是这个寿命以及控制流向它们的资金的能力。
And it's super important. And this becomes this just mutated monster of a public authority under the guidance of Robert Moses and the laws that he is able to pass. It can do so many things that it is not intended really to do. Like they have power of eminent domain. They can create their own rules on their property and hire police to enforce those rules.
这超级重要。而在罗伯特·摩西的指导以及他能够通过的法律之下，这就变成了一个发生变异的、庞然大物般的公共管理局。它可以做很多它本来并不打算做的事情。比如它们拥有强制征收权。它们可以在自己的财产上制定自己的规则，并雇佣警察来执行这些规则。
They can do things the state can't, like just sign contracts without having any competitive bidding, which allows Moses to direct specifically where money goes and that helps him shore up his power. And all of this is encoded in the covenant between him and the bond holders. And so once he has this set up, he doesn't need the executive support. He always felt he needed in the past. Doesn't matter. He doesn't need the public support that he would rally before.
它们可以做一些州做不到的事情，比如在没有任何竞争性投标的情况下签署合同，这使得摩西能够直接支配资金的去向，这有助于他巩固自己的权力。所有这一切都编码在分摊给他的契约以及债券持有人之间。因此，一旦他建立了这个架构，他就不再需要他过去常常觉得需要的行政支持了。没关系。他不需要他以前会集结的公众支持。
The only thing he needs to do is never stop building. Because as long as he keeps building, he can keep issuing new bonds. And that works out great for him because he doesn't want to stop building because as long as he keeps building, he can keep issuing new bonds. And that works out great for him because he doesn't want to stop building anyway. Like when your goal and the evil thing you need to do to keep your power to achieve that goal are the same thing, that's a beautiful synchronicity. You know, that it's like Robert Moses, you can do this, but you have to always keep building bridges and roads.
他唯一需要做的事情就是永不停止建设。因为只要他不断建设，他就可以不断发行新债券。这对他来说结果太棒了，因为他根本不想停止建设，因为只要他不断建设，他就可以不断发行新债券。这对他来说结果太棒了，因为他本来就不想停止建设。就像当你的目标和为保持权力以实现该目标所需做的邪恶事情是同一回事时，那是一种美丽的同步性。你知道的，这就像罗伯特·摩西，你可以这样做，但你必须总是不断建造桥梁和道路。
It's like, great. That's why I'm doing this. Exactly. Exactly. And it, Carol points out this structure, it matches Moses' preferred style, which is you don't have public hearings because it's all private records and it still appears to the public as this is a public authority working for the good of the people without a salaried head.
就像，太棒了。这就是我正在做的。正是如此。正是如此。而且，卡罗指出，这种结构符合摩西偏好的风格，那就是你不举行听证会，因为这全都是私人记录，而且在公众看来，这仍然是一个为了人民的利益而工作的、没有领薪负责人的公共管理局。
You know, it's independent from partisan politics. It's free of a lot of the red tape. He's weaponizing the things that have always been kind of what people admired about him and turning them into aspects of the authority that he can do a lot of damage with. And Robert Carroll quotes Emerson. He says, an institution is the length and shadow of one man. And he's making the case that the way the tribal authority is set up is basically if Robert Moses was a government organization, you know, rather than a human being.
你知道的，它独立于党派政治。它摆脱了许多繁文缛节。他正在将那些一直以来人们对他赞赏有加的特质武器化，并将它们变成管理局的各个方面，他可以利用这些方面造成巨大的破坏。罗伯特·卡罗引用了爱默生的话。他说，任何机构都是一个人拉长的身影。他正在论证的是，三区管理局的建立方式基本上就是罗伯特·摩西化身为一个政府组织，你知道的，而不是一个活生生的人。
And the title of the chapter, The Warp on the Loom, which I can't help it, it always sounds kind of science fiction-y to me because that's where my mind goes for the word warp. But it comes from something Moses writes in a 1941 brochure about how he's always wanted to weave together what he saw as the loose strands of the metropolitan tapestry. And he's saying that the Triborough Bridge Authority has provided the warp in the Metropolitan loom, the heavier threads across which the lighter ones are woven. And that's the way he sees it. He is going to be creating basically the shape that New York is going to have to accommodate
而这一章的标题《织机上的经线》，我忍不住，它对我的感觉总是有点科幻色彩，因为那是“warp”这个词让我联想到方向。但它来自摩西在1941年的一份宣传册中写的一段话，关于他一直想把他所看到的都市挂毯中松散的线索编织在一起。他说三区大桥管理局为大都市织机提供了经线，也就是较重的线，较轻的线则横跨其上进行编织。这就是他的看法。他基本上要创造出纽约将不得不适应的形状
itself to. You know, he is the warp on the loom and he puts all his eggs in the authority basket. He's all the revenue from his parks that he controls. It's going into the authority and he builds himself a new fifth office. I don't even have one office room. I, I have to work out of my bedroom and he has five offices and this one's going to be his main headquarters. It's everyone understands. This is where the RM is going to be. It's on Randall's Island, right underneath the Triborough bridge.
本身。你知道的，他是织机上的经线，他把所有的鸡蛋都放在了管理局的篮子里。他掌控的公园的所有收入。都流入了管理局，他给自己建了第五个办公室。我甚至连一个办公室都没有。我，我不得不在卧室里办公，而他有五个办公室，这个将成为他的主要总部。大家都明白。这就是RM将要呆的地方。它在兰德尔岛上，就在三区大桥的正下方。
It's only accessible to people who have paid a toll to use the bridge. So even when the mayor comes over to see him, he has to pay a toll to go see Robert Moses, which is so amazingly symbolic. And Triborough's laws are enforced there, not the city's. And the building is under the Triborough toll plaza, basically. And it's positioned in a way that if you're driving on the bridge, you can't see it. Like you don't know it's there. There's, it's like Robert Moses is going so far out of his way to make the physical, to make the symbolic physical and concrete. He's taking metaphors for his own shadow use of power. And he's like,
它只能由支付了过桥费使用该桥的人进入。因此，即使市长来看望他，他也必须支付过桥费才能去见罗伯特·摩西，这太具有象征意义了。三区公司的法律在那里执行，而不是城市的法律。大楼基本上位于三区收费广场下方。它的位置很巧妙，如果你在桥上开车，你是看不到它的。就像你不知道它在那儿一样。这就像罗伯特·摩西费尽心机，要让象征性的东西变得实体化和具体化。他把对自己暗中行使权力的隐喻
let's build things that really represent that in a way that would seem very on the nose. If this was a novel, but it's going to do it. And he gets the law passed and set. Finally, there's a disagreement between Moses and LaGuardia about hiring somebody. And LaGuardia is like, I'll have my legal advisors look at the law. I want to assure the governor, Governor Layman, that we didn't give Moses too much power. And he discovers, as the reformers discover, as poor Truby Davison discovered, that they have inadvertently helped Moses
拿来，心想：让我们建造一些真正能够代表这一点的东西，如果这是一部小说，这会显得非常直白，但它就要这么做。他让法律通过并确立了。最后，摩西和拉瓜迪亚在雇用某人的问题上产生了分歧。拉瓜迪亚说，我会让我的法律顾问看看这项法律。我想向州长——莱曼州长保证，我们没有赋予摩西太多的权力。而他发现，正如改革派们发现的那样，正如可怜的特鲁比·戴维森发现的那样，他们无意中帮助了摩西
to gain way more power than they intended. And he can do whatever he wants now. And LaGuardia can fire him as city park commissioner, but Moses could retaliate by having the legislature basically cut state funds to city projects because of his allies there that he has financial relationships with. And LaGuardia doesn't want to try doing what Roosevelt failed to do, which was pitting himself against the people's desire to have a champion who is free from government interference to get things done.
获得了远超他们预期的权力。他现在可以随心所欲了。拉瓜迪亚可以免除他城市公园专员的职务，但摩西可以通过让立法机关基本上削减城市项目的州资金来报复，因为他在那里拥有因财务关系而结盟的盟友。而拉瓜迪亚不想去尝试罗斯福失败过的事情，那就是让自己与人民渴望有一个不受政府干涉的斗士来把事情办成的愿望对立起来。
Moses is at this point, he is just too powerful and too popular for LaGuardia to try to remove him or even risk pissing him off. And Caro says, the powers that the mayor possessed over Moses' authorities, in theory, he did not possess in practice. Political realities gave him no choice but to allow Moses to remain at their head." Moses is essentially the mayor of Triborough who is equally sovereign, in some ways more sovereign than the mayor of New York, which is terrifying. And it's only going to get
此时的摩西，权势太大、太受欢迎，以至于拉瓜迪亚根本不敢试图罢免他，甚至不敢冒惹恼他的风险。卡罗说：“市长对摩西管理局拥有的权力，在理论上他并不具备。政治现实让他别无选择，只能允许摩西继续担任其负责人。”摩西本质上就是三区的市长，他的主权地位完全对等，在某些方面甚至比纽约市长更具主权，这太可怕了。而且随着我们进入下一部分，情况只会
more so as we get into the next part. What's the title of the next part, Roman? It's called part six, The Lust for Power, which is even worse than the love of power, I guess. I don't know. Lust seems okay to me sometimes. But we'll get to that after the break. Okay, we're on to Part six, the lust for power. The first chapter in this section is chapter 29. And when the last law was down, dot, dot, dot. So.
更加如此。下一部分的标题是什么，罗曼？它叫第六部分：对权力的贪婪，这我猜甚至比对权力的热爱还要糟糕。我不知道。贪婪对我来说有时听起来还行。但我们在中场休息后就会讲到那个。好的，我们进入第六部分：对权力的贪婪。这一部分的第一章是第二9章。当最后的法律落下时，点、点、点。所以。
Roman, I'd love to try to spend some time on your surprising but stirring defense of lust as a feeling, but we got to move on. We still got lots of material. I'm just saying it has its place and it shouldn't be just treated as horrible all the time. That's fair. That's fair. That's fair. But the lust, the lust for, for, you know, for, for a lover, for a partner, but the lust for power, maybe that's not so amazing. Yeah, that's exactly.
罗曼，我很想花点时间探讨一下你对贪婪作为一种感觉的令人惊奇但又激昂的辩护，但我们得继续前进了。我们还有很多材料。我只是说它有其存在的价值，不应该总是被当作十恶不赦的东西来对待。这倒也是。这倒也是。这倒也是。但对……对，你知道的，对一个爱人、一个伴侣的贪婪，但对权力的贪婪，也许就没那么美妙了吧。是的，正是如此。
Yes. Uh, and the chapter here, it opens with a quote, uh, from the diary of former New York mayor Philip Hone from 1835 about how beautiful the Manhattan battery is, uh, for, for non New Yorkers, anyone who's listening. The battery is, it's the maritime Southern tip of Manhattan. This is, I'm sure I knew at some point the reason it's called the battery. I could have looked it up. I don't remember. I don't know either.
是的。嗯，这一章开篇引用了前纽约市长菲利普·霍恩1835年日记中的一段话，关于曼哈顿炮台公园是多么美丽——对于非纽约人、任何在听的听众来说，炮台公园是曼哈顿的海事南端。这是，我确信我曾在某个时候知道它为什么叫炮台公园（Battery）。我本可以查一下的。我不记得了。我也不知道。
But it's essentially, if you go as far South as you can possibly get in Manhattan, as far downtown as you can go until it's just water, that's the battery. And in the 1830s, he's talking about what a beautiful site it is. And the battery is going to be the central point of battle for this chapter. It's a chapter of the public battle for Moses' plans for the battery. And it's ironic because the last chapter is talking about what an unstoppable colossus Moses has built himself to be.
但它基本上是，如果你在曼哈顿尽可能向南走，尽最大可能往闹市区走，直到只剩下水，那就是炮台公园。在19世纪30年代，他在谈论这是一个多么美丽的地方。而炮台公园将成为这一章的核心战役点。这是关于公众为摩西的炮台公园计划而战的一章。这具有讽刺意味，因为上一章在谈论摩西为自己建造了一个多么不可阻挡的庞然大物。
And this chapter, right after it, the chapter is about him being stopped from doing something. Spoiler alert, he gets stopped in his plans, but the ultimate point is just how much power it now takes to stop this guy So it's 1938. I think 1938 again war clouds looming over Europe. Everybody's dancing the Charleston still probably I know there's more of a 20s dance the big hit in the theaters is a 38 so Hollywood's greatest year 1939 hasn't happened yet. I'll have to look that up, what was going on. Anyway, LaGuardia, that was, so my attempt to set the scene of 1938 has failed miserably. There's maybe the Charleston, which is 10 years out of date.
而紧接着这一章，这一章讲的是他被阻止做某事。剧透警告，他的计划被打断了，但最终的重点是，现在需要多大的权力才能阻止这家伙。所以那是1938年。我想1938年，战争的阴云再次笼罩欧洲。每个人可能还在跳查尔斯顿舞，我知道那是更偏向20年代的舞蹈，剧院里最大的热门是38年的，所以好莱坞最伟大的一年1939年还没有到来。我得去查查当时发生了什么。无论如何，拉瓜迪亚，那就是，所以我试图设定1938年场景的尝试彻底失败了。也许有查尔斯顿舞，那是落后了10年的舞。
Maybe the- People still maybe dancing it. People still do like the robot, you know? So LaGuardia, he wants to build Moses's circumferential bypass route, the big road around the city. It's gonna cost $105 million. And the city, guess what? It has no money. It never has money.
也许——人们可能还在跳它。人们依然喜欢机器人舞，你知道的吗？所以拉瓜迪亚，他想要建造摩西的环城绕行路线，即围绕城市的宏伟道路。这将花费1.05亿美元。而这座城市，你猜怎么着？它没钱。它从来没钱。
I'm starting to think New York has never had money in the history of the city. And he tries to get funding for the Brooklyn Battery Tunnel part of this circumferential bypass route, but he can't raise it anywhere. And Moses's, Tribor authority, it can raise the money for the tunnel.
我开始觉得在纽约市的历史上它就没过钱。他试图为这条环城绕行路线的布鲁克林-炮台隧道部分获取资金，但他无论如何也筹集不到。而摩西的三区管理局，它可以为这条隧道筹集资金。
But in exchange, he says, I want control of the tunnel authority. I want control of all crossings into and out of Manhattan, like a super villain with demand. Like, why would who but a villain would be like, I need to control all routes into and out of the busy, the most densely populated part of the United States of America, I control it. And LaGuardia doesn't like this. He actually writes lousy exclamation point across a memo from Moses about this. But in the end, he has to agree to the deal because he can't get the money anywhere else. So Moses, he's going to be in charge of the building the Brooklyn Battery Tunnel. He tried so hard to get involved in this last chapter. He couldn't do it, but money talks, you know, the other thing walks, like we said.
但作为交换，他说，我要控制隧道管理局。我要控制进出曼哈顿的所有交通要道，就像一个有要求的超级反派。就像，除了一个反派，谁会说：我需要控制进出美利坚合众国最繁忙、人口最稠密地区的所有的路线，由我来控制。拉瓜迪亚不喜欢这样。他在一份关于此事的摩西备忘录上甚至写下了“糟透了”并加上了感叹号。但最后，他不得不接受这笔交易，因为他在其他任何地方都筹不到钱。所以摩西将负责建造布鲁克林-炮台隧道。他在上一章里千方百计想介入此事。他没能做到，但有钱能使鬼推磨，你知道的，就像我们说的。
So he decides, you know what? I don't like tunnels. The Brooklyn Battery Tunnel, it should be a Brooklyn Battery Bridge. I like bridges. They're more appealing to investors. They're more impressive. When you say you built a bridge, that's way more impressive than to say you built a tunnel. As shown by the fact that there's a huge book about Robert Moses. I don't know how many huge books there are about Orville Singstad, you know, the master tunneler. You talk about, is there a bridge in Marvel comics? Yes, it's the Rainbow Bridge from Earth to Asgard. Is there a tunneler in Marvel comics? Yes, the Mole Man. Nobody likes him. So bridges, people just like them more. And Moses, he says, a bridge is the finest architecture made by man, while a tunnel, he says, is merely a tiled vehicular
所以他决定，你知道吗？我不喜欢隧道。布鲁克林-炮台隧道，它应该是一座布鲁克林-炮台大桥。我喜欢桥梁。它们对投资者更有吸引力。它们更引人注目。当你宣称你造了一座桥时，那比宣称你造了一条隧道要震撼得多。正如一个巨大的事实所表明的那样，有一本关于罗伯特·摩西的巨著。我不知道漫威漫画里有多少本关于奥维尔·辛格斯塔德（隧道大师）的巨著。你在谈论，漫威漫画里有桥吗？是的，那是从地球到阿斯加德的彩虹桥。漫威漫画里有打洞的人吗？是的，鼹鼠人。没人喜欢他。所以桥梁，人们就是更喜欢它们。而摩西说，桥梁是人类创造的最美丽的建筑，而隧道，他说，不过是一个贴着瓷砖的汽车
bathroom smelling faintly of monoxide. And I love the condescension towards tunnels in that. It's like, yeah, it's like a bathroom where cars are being pooped out of the city. Like, I don't want to build that. And, comptroller Joseph D. McGoldrick, he points out, if they pay for Moses Bridge, their portion of it, the city will literally have no money for any other construction or maintenance
浴室，隐隐散发着一氧化碳的气味。我喜欢这种对隧道的居高临下的态度。这就像，是的，这就像一个把汽车当成排泄物从城市里拉出来的浴室。就像，我才不想造那个。而主计长约瑟夫·D·麦戈德里克指出，如果他们为摩西的桥梁付费、支付他们那部分费用，这座城市在至少1940年之前，将字面意义上没有钱用于任何其他建设或物理基础设施的
of the physical infrastructure through at least 1940. They will not be building any schools. They will not be building any schools. They will not be building any hospitals. They will not be maintaining the subways. And New York's been building great roads and bridges of a sort, thanks to Moses, but its schools and its hospitals are crumbling. They're ancient.
维护。他们将不会建造任何学校。他们将不会建造任何学校。他们将不会建造任何医院。他们将不会维护地铁。而由于摩西的功劳，纽约一直在修建某种意义上的宏伟道路和桥梁，但它的学校和医院却在日趋破败。它们已经老旧不堪。
The subways are inadequate and also crumbling. This is the other long running thread of New York history is that the subways are always falling apart. I experienced it. My parents experienced it. It's a generations long tradition that everybody loves. The whole thing comes to a head at a board of estimate meeting where Moses implies that McGoldrick is corrupt. And he says, if you stop this bridge, it will never be possible to build this bridge ever again. The money will never be available. The project will be dead forever. You will never have a crossing
地铁既不合格又在崩溃。纽约历史上的另一个长期主题就是地铁总是状况百出。我经历过。我父母经历过。这是一个历经数代人、大家都喜爱的传统。这一切在一次估算委员会会议上达到了白热化，会上摩西暗示麦戈德里克是腐败的。他说，如果你阻止这座桥，这座桥将永远不可能再被建造。资金将永远无法到位。这个项目将彻底完结。你将永远无法在炮台公园和布鲁克林之间拥有一条通道。
between the battery and Brooklyn. And behind closed doors, LaGuardia is like, Comptroller McGoldrick, you've got, if you don't support this project, there will be a rift between you and me for the rest of my administration. And the Comptroller is like, we've got so much work to do. I can't allow a feud to exist between me and the mayor. So they get, so they approve it. And on January 22nd, 1939, Moses announces they're gonna be building a Brooklyn Battery Bridge crossing, which is going to plant enormous piers through Battery Park
而在闭门会议上，拉瓜迪亚却对主计长麦戈德里克说：“你必须，如果你不支持这个项目，我和你之间将产生一道裂痕，贯穿我整个任期。”而主计长则想：我们有那么多工作要做。我不能允许我和市长之间存在宿怨。于是他们妥协了，所以他们批准了。1939年1月22日，摩西宣布他们将建造一座布鲁克林-炮台大桥交叉口，这将在炮台公园打下巨大的桥墩，
to support a causeway that would connect the bridge to an extension of the West Side Highway. And then Caro says, and then on January 25th, the storm broke. And this big outcry comes from the powerful New York gentry who are the core of the good government and fusion groups, the goo-goos, the old fashioned goo-goos who used to be on Moses'
以支撑一条连接大桥与西侧公路延伸段的高架道路。接着卡罗写道：“然后，在1月25日，风暴爆发了。”强烈的抗议声来自纽约有权有势的士绅，他们是良政运动和融合派的核心力量——古板的“古古派”（goo-goos），也就是那些曾经站在摩西
side. They didn't stand up before for Inwood Hill. They didn't know about it. They didn't, weren't familiar with it, but these people, they work near the battery. They know lower Manhattan. They know Brooklyn Heights where the bridge is going to stomp its foot on the other side.
这一边的老派古古派。他们之前没有为英伍德山站出来。他们对此并不了解。他们并不熟悉它，但这些人，他们在炮台公园附近工作。他们了解曼哈顿下城。他们了解布鲁克林高地，也就是大桥将在另一端踏上的一脚。
And Moses announces the bridge with this artist rendering that really minimizes the size of it. But the actual board of estimate plans, they show this will seriously change lower Manhattan. This will change it in a big way. And Manhattan borough president Stanley M. Isaacs is really familiar with this. And he shows these things to the press.
摩西宣布大桥时发布了一张极力缩小其规模的艺术家效果图。但实际的估算委员会计划显示，这将彻底改变曼哈顿下城。这将以一种巨大的方式改变它。而曼哈顿区长斯坦利·M·艾萨克斯对此非常熟悉。他把这些东西展示给了媒体。
And I wanted to read a little bit of a, before we get into the history of the area, which I know Roman has some very controversial thoughts about, stay tuned for that. I want to read this here. So, the public might be interested to know Isaac said that the proposed bridge anchorage in Battery Park, barely visible on Moses's rendering,
我想在深入了解该地区的历史之前读一读一小段——我知道罗曼对这段历史有一些非常具有争议的想法，敬请期待——我想在这里读读这段。所以，公众可能会感兴趣地了解到，艾萨克斯说，拟议中的位于炮台公园的大桥锚碇在摩西的效果图上几乎微不足道，
would be a solid mass of stone and concrete, equal in size to a 10 story office building. The approach ramp linking the bridge to the West Side Highway, a ramp depicted on the rendering as a narrow path through Battery Park, would actually be a road wider than Fifth Avenue, a road supported on immense concrete piers.
它将是一个巨大的石块和混凝土实体，其规模相当于一栋10层的办公楼。将大桥连接到西侧公路的引桥——在效果图上被描绘成炮台公园内的一条小路——实际上将是一条比第五大道还要宽的道路，一条由巨大的混凝土墩支撑的道路。
It would cross the entire park, the entire lower tip of Manhattan Island, and curve around the west side of the island almost to Rector Street, at heights ranging up to 100 feet in the air. Not only would Anchorage and piers obliterate a considerable portion of Battery Park, they and the approach road would block off much of the light not only from what was
它将穿过整个公园，穿过曼哈顿岛的整个最南端，并向西绕着该岛的西侧一直延伸到雷克托街，高度在空中最高可达100英尺。锚碇和桥墩不仅会抹杀炮台公园相当大的一部分，它们和引桥还将挡住大量的光线，不仅挡住公园残存部分的阳光，
left of the park, but also from the lower floors of every large office building they passed. Because the approach ramp was really an elevated highway that would dominate the entire tip of Manhattan, it would depress real estate values throughout the entire area. Many good government leaders owned some of that real estate, and they saw Isaac's prophecy confirmed almost immediately when a corporation broke off negotiations for leasing an entire floor at 21 West Street, when it suddenly realized that the view from the windows would no longer be of the harbor,
还会挡住它们所经过的每一栋大型办公楼的低楼层光线。由于引桥实际上是一条将主导曼哈顿整个尖端的高速公路，它将压低整个地区的房地产价值。许多良政运动领袖拥有其中部分房地产，当一家公司突然意识到从窗户望出去不再是海港的景色，
but of the underside of a highway. This is some of the most valuable real estate in the United States of America. And Moses is planning to cover it with a road and block out the sun for it. And this will massively depress New York's real estate tax revenue. And Ol Singstead, who we'll hear more from, he calculates that over the next 20 years, it would cost the city more than $29 million in lost real estate taxes.
而是一条高速公路的底部时，便中断了租用西街21号整层楼的谈判，这让他们立刻看到了艾萨克斯的预言成真。这是美利坚合众国最宝贵的房地产之一。而摩西正计划用一条道路覆盖它，并挡住它的阳光。这将大幅压低纽约的房地产税收。而我们以后还会听到更多关于他的奥维尔·辛格斯塔德计算出，在接下来的20年里，这将使这座城市损失超过2900万美元的房地产税。
And I'll mention again, New York does not have money. So they need to, they don't want to lose this. And here's where Caro takes, take a specific tack. He goes into this kind of four page reverie about the beauty of the waterfront. This is where Caro, the poet comes in. This is not just about money. This is not just about facts and statistics. This is about the importance almost spiritually for the city that the waterfront is for the city that is so crowded. It's so built up.
我再次提到了，纽约没有钱。所以他们需要，他们不想失去这个。正是在这里，卡罗采取了一种独特的手法。他写了一篇长达四页的关于海滨美景的遐思。这就是诗人卡罗登场的地方。这不仅仅关乎金钱。这不仅仅关乎事实和统计数据。这关乎海滨对这座拥挤不堪、建设得密不透风的城市而言，在几乎精神层面上的重要性。
And I'm going to read a little bit of that says the buildings in which 12 million persons lived and worked in 1939 seemed to stretch out endlessly to the horizon. But from such vantage points, it could be seen that they were not only stretching out, but closing in, building up, pressing inward, crowding closer and closer together until, as if the concentrating inward surge of humanity constituted a geologic force. In the epicenter of that surge, the buildings of Manhattan were thrust upward and toward the sky. And it was near the island's southern tip, the tip jutting into the harbor, that the colossal upthrust had been greatest. In the upper part of Manhattan, the masses of concrete were mostly 60 feet high, or 70. In the center of the island, they were 150 or 200. But as
我要读一读其中的一小段：在1939年供1200万人居住和工作的建筑物似乎向地平线无休止地延伸。但从这样的制高点可以看出，它们不仅在向外延伸，而且在步步逼近、向上建造、向内挤压、越靠越近，仿佛汇聚向内的汹涌人潮构成了一种地质力量。在那股汹涌人潮的震中，曼哈顿的建筑物被向上推向天空。正是在该岛的南端——那个伸入海港的尖端——这种巨大的向上推力最为强烈。在曼哈顿的上部，混凝土建筑群大多高60英尺或70英尺。在岛的中心，它们高150英尺或200英尺。但随着
the island narrowed toward its southern tip, they were 400 feet high, 500, cramming closer and closer together, bulking up higher and higher as they loomed southward, pressing inexorably toward the island's tip. Until at that very tip, at the very end of the most crowded island in the world, at the very spot in the entire world in which buildings should have been crowded most closely together, there was suddenly, with the exception of a tiny old fort converted into an aquarium, no buildings at all. At a point at which a single square foot of land was worth thousands of dollars, at which the value of an acre was computed not in the millions of dollars, but in the tens of millions.
该岛向南端变窄，它们高达400英尺、500英尺，越聚越紧，随着向南延伸而变得越来越高大，不可阻挡地向该岛的尖端挤压。直到在最尖端，在这个世界上最拥挤的岛屿的最末端，在全世界本该将建筑物挤得最紧的那个地方，突然之间，除了一个被改造成水族馆的微小古老堡垒外，竟然没有任何建筑物。在一个土地单方英尺价值数千美元、一英亩的价值不是以数百万美元而是以数千万美元计算的地方，
There sat 967,032 square feet of land, 22.2 acres, vacant except for grass and trees, pathways between them, benches, and a broad, breezy waterfront promenade." And this is something that if you live in New York, this strikes you so hard in the heart because the experience of living in New York, it's exciting. It's wonderful. I love it there, but you feel like you live in a termite hill. There's people just constantly crawling all over each other. You are stacked on top of other people. The only way to get around is to go underground under all the people, I mean,
静静地坐落着967,032平方英尺的土地，即22.2英亩，除了草地和树木、其间的步道、长椅以及宽阔而微风习习的海滨长廊外，空无一物。”而如果你住在纽约，这会深深地击中你的心，因为在纽约生活的体验是令人兴奋的。它是美妙的。我很喜欢那里，但你觉得自己像生活在蚁丘里。人们只是不断地在彼此身上爬来爬去。你被堆叠在其他人身上。唯一的出行方式就是钻到地下，在所有人底下，我是说
a can with a lot of other people. And these spaces that are open, that are not built on are so incredibly valuable. And you'll hear this so much about, you know, the people in Mena can with a lot of other people. And these spaces that are open, that are not built on, are so incredibly valuable. And you'll hear this so much about Central Park. And Moses should know this because he's the man who rebuilt Central Park, essentially, that people say the greatest decision that the early founders of the city ever made was blocking off all this land so that it couldn't be built on. So you'd have this open space. Open space is so valuable. And this is where he goes into the history of that spot in the city and what it was
和其他许多人在一起。这些开放的、没有被修建建筑的土地是如此难以置信的宝贵。你会听到很多关于中央公园的讨论，你知道，美纳的那些人。摩西应该很清楚这一点，因为他基本上就是重建中央公园的人，人们说，这座城市早期的建立者做出的最伟大的决定，就是封锁了所有这些土地，使其无法被用于建筑。这样你就能拥有这片开阔的空间。开阔的空间是如此宝贵。在这里，他深入探讨了城市中那个地方的历史，以及它在
like in colonial days and revolutionary days, the early American Republic. And then he talks about specifically this one building in Battery Park, that fort that he mentioned, which by the late 1930s was the New York aquarium. But the fort itself dates back to 1812. And then it became a entertainment spot where Marquis de Lafayette returned to the United States from France in 1824, and Caro takes us back to that day, and he talks about other historic people who appeared at the battery.
殖民时期、革命时期和早期美利坚共和国时期的样子。接着他具体谈到了炮台公园里的那一栋建筑，也就是他提到的那座堡垒，到20世纪30年代末，那里成了纽约水族馆。但这座堡垒本身可以追溯到1812年。后来它成了一个娱乐场所，1824年拉法耶特侯爵从法国返回美国时就在这里，卡罗把我们带回了那一天，他谈到了出现在炮台公园的其他历史人物。
In 1855, it was one of the disembarkation points for immigrants to America. So much history is packed into this building, and now it's beloved as the aquarium, and I can see Roman getting so mad that history is being used to stop progress. Roman, tell him why he's wrong. Tell me why he's wrong.
1855年，这里是移民抵达美国的登陆点之一。这座建筑凝聚了太多的历史，现在它作为水族馆备受喜爱，我能看出罗曼对历史被用来阻止进步感到多么愤怒。罗曼，告诉他为什么他是错的。告诉我为什么他是错的。
I think he's right. In this case, I do not want this bridge approach. I do not want Battery Park to be annihilated. I do think that- Why are you anti-Parks, Roman? Yeah, why are you? I do think that some of this reverie about like George Washington once walked here and
我觉得他是对的。在这种情况下，我不想要这座桥的引桥。我不想让炮台公园被消灭。我确实认为——罗曼，你为什么反对公园？对啊，你为什么反对？我确实觉得，这种关于“乔治·华盛顿曾经在这里走过”以及
Lafayette had a brownstone nearby is often used to stop cities working for people of the modern day. When you have so much reverence for history, it just nothing can move forward and cities also need to function for the people who live today. And so that's always a balance. And so like, so when I read this, I can totally hear that in this case, it is the right argument for stopping the wrong project. But often, this is the wrong argument used to stop the right project. And so I hear that when I read this, a little bit of that just like, oh my God,
“拉法耶特曾在附近有一栋褐石屋”的怀旧情绪，常常被用来阻碍城市为现代人服务。当你对历史抱有如此多的崇敬时，一切都无法向前发展，城市也需要为今天生活的人们运转。所以这始终是一种平衡。因此，当我读到这段时，我完全能理解，在这种情况下，这是阻止错误项目的正确论点。但通常情况下，这是被用来阻止正确项目的错误论点。所以我读到这里时，脑海里会浮现出一种想法，那就是，天哪，
you just have to let some of this stuff go because people need to live in this city too. And I do actually believe that like, it as a park and open space is much more relevant to me than George Washington walked here once. It's so much more relevant to me than George Washington walked here once. It's so much more important to me. I think it hurts me to admit it because I love history and I love his old things and I hate new things
你必须放下一部分这样的执念，因为人们也需要在这座城市里生活。而且我确实相信，作为一个公园和开阔的空间，它对我来说比乔治·华盛顿曾经在这里走过要有意义得多。它对我来说比乔治·华盛顿曾经在这里走过重要得多。对我来说它太重要了。我想承认这一点让我感到痛苦，因为我热爱历史，我热爱古老的事物，我讨厌新事物，
and I hate modern worlds in a lot of ways, even though it's subjectively the best time to live in the history of the world. But I still, you know, I'm nostalgic for the times before I was born, which is again, is my entitled right as a straight white man that I can do those things. But I get what you're saying. You have to prioritize ideally the people who are alive over people who lived and died. And the memory of something is very valuable. It's very valuable, but it's not as valuable as the
而且在很多方面我讨厌现代世界，尽管客观上这是世界历史上最好的生存时代。但我仍然，你知道的，我对自我出生之前的时代怀有怀旧之情，这再次证明了，作为一个白人直男，我有权去做这些事情，这也是我的特权。但我明白你的意思。理想情况下，你必须优先考虑活著的人，而不是那些已经死去的人。某种事物的记忆是非常宝贵的。它非常宝贵，但它不如
life of a person today. Yeah. And there's a way to balance both things. It's just that it's not as valuable as the life of a person today. And there's a way to balance both things. It's just that it's often a cudgel against a type of progress that I think is important to the better men of people's lives. And so I hear it and a little bit of my guard is put up when I read this type of stuff. But in this case, what, you know, what Caro is demonstrating is that, you know,
今天一个人的生命宝贵。是的。而且有一种方法可以平衡这两者。只是它不如今天一个人的生命宝贵。而且有一种方法可以平衡这两者。只是它往往成为了反对某种进步的棍棒，而我认为这种进步对改善人们的生活至关重要。所以我听到这些时，当我读到这类内容时，我的防备心就会不由自主地升起一点。但在这个案例中，你知道的，卡罗所展示的是，
despite all of Robert Moses' power, he's running into all of these oppositional forces, like the weight of history, the value of open space, the wealth of these people who own buildings all around this thing. Maybe that's the most important one of all. And Caro's putting the best possible spin on that, which is not that they just have a financial interest in it, but that they know this area. Now they are finally recognizing
尽管罗伯特·摩西拥有无上的权力，他还是遇到了所有这些反对力量，比如历史的份量、开放空间价值、以及这些在四周拥有建筑的富人们的财富。也许这才是最重要的一点。卡罗对此作出了最好的诠释，并不是说他们仅仅在其中有经济利益，而是他们了解这个地区。现在他们终于意识到
what Moses is doing because it's happening in their backyard. It's happening in the space that they know as opposed to these spaces that they haven't been to. He has not yet built the cross Bronx, but when he's doing that, the same strata of spaces that they haven't been, you know, he has not yet built the cross Bronx, but when, when he's doing that, the same strata of people, they don't spend time in the Bronx. So they're not really thinking about that, but they spend a lot of time in lower Manhattan. That's where the financial district is.
摩西在做什么，因为这件事发生在他们自己的后院。它发生在他们所熟悉的空间里，而不是那些他们从未去过的地方。他还没有修建跨布朗克斯高速公路，但当他在修建时，同样阶层的人，他们不在布朗克斯花时间。所以他们并没有真正考虑过那个地方，但他们在曼哈顿下城花了很多时间。那是金融区所在的地方，
That's where a lot of the, the businesses at the time were especially located because New York's history is a history of starting at the Southern tip of Manhattan and moving up and outward. And so that's where the old families and the old money, they know that area. Exactly. They find this to be particularly galling
那也是当时许多企业特别集中的地方，因为纽约的历史就是一部从曼哈顿南端开始，向上向外发展的历史。因此，老家族和老钱都在那里，他们熟悉那个区域。没错。他们觉得这特别令人恼火，
because this is where they're from. Yes, and in that way it almost, it's like the yacht club again. It feels so weird to be like, yeah, well, he's gotta protect the ancestral heritage of the richest people in New York, but it's history, you know, politics is a weird thing, strange bedfellows, you know, and basically, but I
因为这是他们长大的地方。是的，从某种程度上说，它几乎又回到了游艇俱乐部那种感觉。让人觉得很奇怪的是，好像在说：“好吧，他得保护纽约最富有的人的祖传遗产。”但这就是历史，你知道的，政治是一件奇怪的事情，同床异梦，你知道的，基本上，但我
agree with you that here it's, Caro's bringing this historical argument into it. And it's more, I think, because the survival of the fort itself is going to be such a major part of this, but he essentially boils it down to saying, Moses wants to take a quiet park and make it the ground underneath a highway. And that's, and that is a bad deal for, especially when we know that he's already told us how the highways and the bridges, they don't really help with the traffic. They just bring more cars in. And if you're having a hard time picturing this, like what these type of concrete pillars
同意你的看法，在这里，卡罗把这个历史论据引入了进来。而且更多是因为，堡垒本身的存续将成为其中的一个主要部分，但他基本上把它归结为：摩西想要拿走一个安静的公园，把它变成高速公路底下的地面。而且，这是一个糟糕的交易，尤其是当我们知道他已经告诉我们，高速公路和桥梁并不能真正缓解交通压力，它们只会带来更多的汽车。如果你很难想象这个画面，比如这些类型的混凝土柱子
to hold up this type of approach onto the bridge, they're not just pillars, like columns in front of a building. These are 10 story tall, gigantic structures like the size of a city block. I mean, they are gigantic. They just eradicate everything that's around them. You know, if, you know, there's a neighborhood right by the Brooklyn approach of the Brooklyn Bridge,
来支撑这种通往桥梁的引桥，它们不仅仅是柱子，就像建筑前面的立柱那样。这些是高达10层楼、巨大无比、宛如一个城市街区大小的结构。我的意思是，它们巨大无比。它们彻底摧毁了周围的一切。你知道，如果你知道的话，在布鲁克林大桥的布鲁克林引桥附近有一个社区，
there's, you know, there's a, and there's Dumbo, which is under the Manhattan Bridge. It's right there in the name, but like right where the pillars are that hold up the bridges, you can't build a thing there. Like it's nothing, you know, it takes up a lot of space and you don't want to be there. It's just, yeah, anyway, it's, yeah, this would obliterate this park. And so now Carol, he gives us kind of mini bios as he likes to do of two of the reformers who are particularly opposed. There's George McEnany, longtime respected reformer, activist, current president of the Regional Plan Association, and Stanley Meyer Isaacs,
你知道的，还有一个丹波区（Dumbo），它就在曼哈顿大桥下面。名字里就包含着这些，但就像支撑大桥的柱子所在的地方一样，你根本无法在那里建造任何东西。就像那里什么都没有一样，你知道的，它占用了大量的空间，而你根本不想呆在那里。总之，是的，无论如何，是的，这将会彻底摧毁这个公园。于是现在，卡罗为我们提供了两位特别反对他的改革者的迷你小传，这也是他喜欢做的方式。其中一位是乔治·麦克安尼（George McAnany），长期受人尊敬的改革家、活动家、区域计划协会现任主席；另一位是斯坦利·迈耶·艾萨克斯（Stanley Meyer Isaacs），
Manhattan borough president in 1937, a longtime public housing reformer. And he's been mentioned earlier. He's the guy that Moses threatened to punch in the nose. I think that was in the last episode. And Carole paints Isaacs as someone who, Isaacs is another very respected beloved figure in kind of New York civic history, and Carol paints him as someone who's going after the same goals as Moses, but using more principled techniques, not making the compromise of morals that Moses was prone to. And Carol says, George McEnany was a man whom Robert Moses had once admired. Stanley Isaacs was the man whom Robert Moses had once been. And they once thought of Moses as their champion. But now, because he's playing in their backyard, they see that his values and theirs don't really align anymore. And they're finally going to get a close
1937年曼哈顿区长，长期致力于公共住房改革。他之前被提到过。就是那个遭到摩西威胁要打碎鼻子的家伙。我想那是在上一集里。卡罗将艾萨克斯描绘成这样一个人：艾萨克斯是纽约市民历史上又一个备受尊敬、深受爱戴的人物，而卡罗把他描绘成一个追求与摩西相同目标、但采用更有原则的技巧的人，他没有做出摩西那种容易妥协的道德让步。卡罗说，乔治·麦克安尼曾是罗伯特·摩西一度钦佩的人。斯坦利·艾萨克斯则是罗伯特·摩西曾经成为过的那种人。他们曾经把摩西视为他们的拥护者。但现在，因为他在他们的后院胡作非为，他们看出他的价值观与他们的价值观不再真正一致了。他们终于要
look at his methods, because now he's going to use those methods on them. And they can't turn a blind eye to it. First, the reformers, as I think we've mentioned in the past, they have that beautiful liberal dream that never works out. If I just sit down and talk to him, if I just explain to him, you know, the truth of it, then I'll change his mind. Never works. That's not how humans are. They try to get a meeting with him. He won't even reply to them.
密切关注他的方法了，因为现在他将把这些方法用在他们身上。而他们再也无法对之视而不见。首先，改革者们，正如我们过去提到过的，他们怀揣著那种永远无法实现的优美自由主义梦想：“只要我坐下来跟他谈谈，只要我把其中的真相解释给他听，我就能改变他的主意。”这从不管用。人类可不是这样的。他们试图约他见面。他甚至不理睬他们。
And they study the numbers that he's released. They see he's underestimating the cost of the bridge. He's overestimating the cost of the tunnel. He's underselling how much the battery will be changed. And the reformers, again, they make the same, again, the liberal mistake. They go, well, let's trust in the official approval process. That'll give us a chance to make our case. Guys, what are you doing?
他们研究他公布的数据。他们发现他低估了桥梁的成本。他高估了隧道的成本。他淡化了炮台公园将发生多大的改变。而改革者们，他们再次犯了同样的自由主义错误。他们说：“好吧，让我们相信官方的审批程序。这会给我们一个陈述立场的机会。”伙计们，你们在干什么？
It's that it never works that way. Um, then they see in the papers, the newspapers that Moses has requested Albany pass a law taking the authorization to build a battery crossing from the tunnel authority and give it to the Triborough Bridge Authority, something that he would only do if he that he would only do if he assumed he would get that approval, which is exactly what happens. And the planning of commission gives their approval, not because a bridge is better than a tunnel, but because as Carol says, no one was offering to
事情从来都不是那样运作的。嗯，然后他们在报纸上看到，摩西已经请求奥本尼通过一项法律，将从隧道管理局手中剥夺建设炮台跨江通道的授权，并将其交给三区大桥管理局。这种事，只有在他确信自己能获得批准的情况下才会去做，而这正是接下来发生的事情。规划委员会给予了批准，不是因为桥梁比隧道更好，而是正如卡罗所说，没有人主动提出
finance a tunnel, someone was offering to finance a bridge. Only Moses has the money to build whatever this crossing is going to be. So if Moses wants it to be a bridge, it's going to be a bridge. That's there. They are, they're, they're're gonna take the thing they can get rather than get a nothing, because the thing they can get is not exactly what they want.
为隧道提供资金，有人主动提出为桥梁提供资金。只有摩西有钱建造这个无论会是什么样的跨江通道。所以如果摩西想要它是一座桥，它就会是一座桥。就是这样。他们，他们，他们准备接受他们能得到的东西，而不是一无所得，因为他们能得到的东西并不完全是他们想要的。
Yeah. And this is another example of Moses just acting sort of like anti-fact, anti-imperialism. Like he just wants a bridge, and he must know the numbers are being cooked in a certain way to give his result that he wants. This is the guy who on Yellow Pads was able to figure out exactly how much money he needed
是的。这是摩西行事风格的又一个例子，有点像是反事实、反经验主义。就像他只想要一座桥，而且他一定知道数字经过了某种程度的篡改，以便得出他想要的结。这就是那个能够在黄色的记事本上精确算出他需要多少钱
for the West Side improvement and how he could chip away from it. So the idea that he's like, he's not doing the math to the decimal point. Yeah, it's impossible. He knows exactly what he's doing and he doesn't care. And it's just, he likes bridges. He doesn't like tunnels.
来完成西区改善工程，以及他如何从中削减资金的人。所以那种认为他没有把数学计算精确到小数点后的想法，是不可能的。他非常清楚自己在做什么，而且他根本不在乎。而且很简单，他喜欢桥梁。他不喜欢隧道。
Carol was, you know, earlier he compared him to an artist. This is the way artists work where they're like, I'm not going to do it that way. Cause it doesn't ring right to me. I just don't like it. You know, they operate on creative whims and you can do that when you're an artist, but you shouldn't really do that when you're building, when you're building a massive piece of construction running between two parts of a city, you know, I used to, I've had a, I, you know, when I've, I've written for television shows
卡罗之前，你知道的，曾把他比作一个艺术家。这就是艺术家工作的方式，他们会说：“我不会那样做，因为这不合我的心意。我就是不喜欢。”你知道的，他们凭着创造性的突发奇想行事。当你是一个艺术家时，你可以这么做，但当你建造跨越城市两个部分的大型建筑时，你真的不应该这样做。你知道的，我以前，我曾有过，我，你知道的，当我曾经为电视节目撰写剧本时，
and oftentimes if there's a joke that the boss doesn't like, they'll try to give you a reason why it doesn't work. And I always want to say to them, just tell me you don't like it. That's fine. I understand. Like you can just tell me you don't like this joke. We'll write another one. Uh, so I guess that would work pretty well with Moses.
通常情况下，如果有老板不喜欢的笑话，他们会试图给你一个它为什么行不通的理由。而我总是想对他们说：“直接告诉我你不喜欢它就行了。没关系。我理解。就像你直接告诉我你不喜欢这个笑话一样。我们会再写一个。”所以我想这用在摩西身上也会挺管用的。
Yeah. Anyway, I've been on the work pretty well with Moses. Yeah. Anyway, I've been on the other side of that conversation. Yeah. You're like, I can't just tell them. I don't like this thing. I have to tell them why it doesn't work. And the person on the other side is like, it's always, it's always much more insulting to be told you don't understand the work you're doing as opposed to, I
是的。无论如何，我曾经在那种对话的另一头。是的。你会觉得：“我不能直接告诉他们我不喜欢这个东西。我必须告诉他们为什么它行不通。”而另一端的人就会觉得，被告知你根本不理解自己正在做的工作，总是比直接听到“
just don't like this thing, you know? Um, anyway, so that's, that's a management tip to anyone, anyone who's listening. Um, so there are a number of reasons the reformers think they have a shot against Moses. They think they found a clause in the authorization bill that would force the pit city to pay $11 million to link the bridge to the West Side Highway when LaGuardia says, I don't want the city to have to pay for anything for this. And the reformers, they're united. They were strong in the recent local elections. They got their fusion candidates in, they're marshaling their total forces and their goal is modest. They just want to get a bridge to be studied.
我就是不喜欢这东西”要侮辱得多，你知道的？嗯，不管怎样，这是给任何聆听者的一个管理小贴士。嗯，改革者们认为他们有机会对抗摩西有几个原因。他们认为他们在授权法案中发现了一个条款，该条款将迫使市政府支付1100万美元，将大桥连接到西区高速公路上，而拉瓜迪亚却说：“我不想让市政府为此支付任何费用。”而且改革者们是团结的。他们在最近的地方选举中表现强劲，他们把他们的融合派候选人送了进去，他们正在调动全部力量，他们的目标很温和。他们只是想让这座桥经过论证。
They just want to study done before the bridge is agreed to. And they use that influence to see the mayor. They get their opinions printed in the papers, public opinion. It starts to turn in favor of the tunnel over the bridge. And the reformers are like, well, if we have public opinion, that's crucial in a democracy and we'll just direct that pressure at the city council before it meets about the bridge and we'll get them to get the study because the people want it. And meanwhile, most is so confident that none of this matters that he goes to
他们只是想在桥梁协议达成之前做一份可行性研究。他们利用这种影响力去见市长。他们把自己的观点发表在报纸上。公众舆论开始转向支持隧道而非大桥。而改革者们则想：“好吧，如果我们拥有公众舆论，这在民主制度中是至关重要的，我们只需在市议会开会讨论大桥问题之前，将这种压力直接施加给他们，我们就会让他们去做这项研究，因为这是民意所向。”与此同时，摩西极其自信，认为这一切都无关紧要，以至于他去了
Florida for three weeks on vacation. And Moses, he does take a moment to send LaGuardia a telegram with an ultimatum that says, I will only pay for a bridge. I will not pay for a tunnel. And so LaGuardia again,gram with an ultimatum that says, I will only pay for a bridge. I will not pay for a tunnel. And so LaGuardia again, he can't cross him. It's the money is going to be more important than, than this kind of public force. And so Caro, he takes us into the city council chamber. He describes it, mahogany panels, delicate, Wayne Scotting.
佛罗里达度假三周。而且摩西，他确实抽空给拉瓜迪亚发了一封带有最后通牒的电报，上面写着：“我只会为桥梁出资。我不会为隧道出资。”于是拉瓜迪亚再次陷入困境，带有最后通牒的电报上面写着：“我只会为桥梁出资。我不会为隧道出资。”于是拉瓜迪亚再次，他无法违抗他。金钱比这种公众力量要重要得多。因此，卡罗把我们带进了市议会大厅。他进行了描述：桃花心木镶板，精致的护壁板。
There's a ceiling mural with gold details. This is a space for democracy. This is a temple for the respect of the, of the people of New York. And the audience is filled with veteran reformers. And Carroll takes us through the city council meeting where Stanley Isaacs introduces a series of experts who systematically dismantle all of Moses' claims in favor of the bridge. And they show it's going to be more expensive than he says. It's going to be more heavily impacted by weather than a tunnel.
天花板上有带有金色细节的壁画。这是一个为了民主的空间。这是一个尊重纽约人民的圣殿。听众席上坐满了老兵级别的改革者。卡罗带我们走过了市议会会议，斯坦利·艾萨克斯在会上介绍了一系列专家，他们系统地驳斥了摩西支持大桥的所有主张。他们指出，大桥的造价将比他说的更贵。它受天气的影响将比隧道更大。
A tunnel can operate in snow. It can operate in rain. And the bridge is going to be more heavily impacted by weather than a tunnel. A tunnel can operate in snow. It can operate in rain, and the bridge is going to be impacted by that. And that battery park deserves better than to essentially become a highway on ramp. And the Reformers talked for four hours. They've really made their case. They did it. If this was the movie, then they'd make their case, and Moses would rip up his papers and walk out defeated, and the council would vote and be like,
隧道可以在雪中运行。它可以在雨中运行。而大桥受天气的影响将比隧道更大。炮台公园理应得到更好的对待，而不是基本上变成一条高速公路的引桥。改革者们讲了四个小时。他们确实陈述了自己的观点。他们做到了。如果这是一部电影，那么他们陈述了观点，摩西就会撕掉文件，战败离场，而议会将投票并表示：
well, it will be a tunnel, and they'd all celebrate. But then Moses gets up and his papers and walk out defeated. And the council would vote and be like, it will be a tunnel and they'd all celebrate. But then Moses gets up and speaks and he says, my opponents are communists. They're just naysayers. They're always wrong about everything. He refers to George McEnany as an extinct volcano and an exhumed mummy. This is what he's saying in the meeting
“好吧，这将是一条隧道，”然后他们都会庆祝。但随后摩西站起来，撕掉文件，战败离场。议会将投票并表示：“这将是一条隧道，”然后他们都会庆祝。但随后摩西站起来发言，他说：“我的反对者是共产主义者。他们只是一群唱反调的人。他们在所有事情上都一直是错的。”他把乔治·麦克安尼称为“熄灭的火山”和“被掘出的木乃伊”。这就是他在会议上对
about these people who are right there. And he just, it's a tax, it's nonsense. He refuses to answer their arguments. And when he is asked, why can't you just delay it so we can study the proposal? He goes, this is a showdown project. Either you want it or you don't want it. And either you want it now or you don't get it at all.
这些就在现场的人说的话。他只是，这是一次人身攻击，这简直一派胡言。他拒绝回答他们的论点。当被问及“为什么你不能推迟一下，好让我们研究一下这个提议”时，他说：“这是一个摊牌项目。要么你想要它，要么你不想。要么你现在就要，要么你什么也得不到。”
And the committee wants it. And they immediately vote unanimously in favor of supporting the bridge to the full city council for the vote the next day. And the reformers are, they're so shocked by his tactics that he just got up there. And instead of saying, well, actually here's why my facts and figures are correct. He says, everyone's a communist. He's a dumb old man.
而委员会想要它。他们随即一致投票赞成支持将大桥提案提交给全体市议会，以便在第二天进行投票。改革者们对此感到无比震惊，他的战术竟然是直接站上台去，
Don't listen to them. And Carol says they had no justification for such an emotion. There was nothing new about that philosophy or those tactics. It's the same thing he's always done, but now he's doing it against them. He is now using the tools that he's used to ruin and, or, and stampede over and shove aside and bully other people. He's using it against them now and they cannot avoid this. And now they're his enemies.
而不是说“好吧，实际上我的事实和数字是正确的”，而是说“每个人都是共产主义者。他是个愚蠢的老头。别听他们的。”卡罗说，他们对这种情绪没有任何正当理由。这种哲学或这些战术没有任何新鲜之处。这和他一直以来做的事情一模一样，但现在他是针对他们这么做了。他现在正在使用那些曾经用来毁掉、践踏、推开和霸凌其他人的工具。他现在把这些工具用在了他们身上，而他们无法逃避这一点。现在他们成了他的敌人。
They finally realize it. This is not the guy we thought he was. He's our enemy now. And they're also starting to realize, even if he is our enemy, even if we're opposing him, it doesn't really matter because he has so much power. He doesn't need our support. We used to feel like we were one of the pillars that was holding Moses up. And Moses himself has already just like knocked that pillar out. It was like, don't need this. I'm like, I'm in a hot air balloon now. I don't need a pillar.
他们终于意识到这一点了。这根本不是我们以为的那种人。他现在是我们的敌人了。他们也开始意识到，即使他是我们的敌人，即使我们在反对他，这其实也无所谓，因为他拥有太强大的权力。他根本不需要我们的支持。我们过去曾觉得自己是支撑摩西的柱子之一。而摩西自己却已经把那根柱子给踢开了，仿佛在说：“我才不需要这个。我现在就像在一个热气球里。我不需要什么柱子。”
It must have been a very, especially for these, especially the older members of the crowd, it members of the crowd, it must have been a very dramatic and shocking moment to just sit there and realize like, oh, this is not the game we thought we were playing. But I like Caro's indictment here. It's pretty mild. It's not like extremely forceful and condemning, but like he's saying, you know, like they have no excuse to think
这一定是一个非常戏剧性和令人震惊的时刻，特别是对这些人群中的年长成员来说，当他们坐在那里意识到：“哦，这根本不是我们以为我们在玩的游戏。”但我喜欢卡罗这里的指控。它相当温和。它不是那种极其有力且充满谴责意味的语气，但他是在说，你知道的，
that this is new behavior for Moses. And this is where like the good, you know, like they have no excuse to think that this is new behavior for Moses. And this is where like the, you know, the good, you know, progressive liberal Caro, you know, stands out. It's just, you know, like he's just like, they can't, they can't have been fooled by Moses. They had to have known this is the way he was because this is the way he was over and over and over again.
“他们没有任何借口认为这是摩西的新行为。”这就是那个优秀的，你知道的，“他们没有任何借口认为这是摩西的新行为。这就是那个优秀的，你知道的，进步派自由主义者卡罗脱颖而出的时候。”这只是，你知道的，就像他说的那样，他们不可能被摩西愚弄。他们一定早就知道他就是这样的人，因为他一次又一次、一次又一次地就是这样的人。
They just do not like it when it's pointed towards them. Either their ignorance of who this guy really is was the case which is inexcusable or they knew it and like you're Saying they didn't care because it wasn't affecting them, which is also inexcusable And it's I mean Caro is he is it is a kind of mild in the way he writes it because he is He is very enamored and attracted to these older reformers the the kind of older people who represent in earlier, New York But at times he is kind of like this judging angel of vengeance who's like, yeah, you should have realized it guys, like where were you?
他们只是不喜欢这种矛头指向自己的感觉。要么他们对这家伙的真面目一无所知，如果是这样的话，那是不可原谅的；要么他们早就知道了，就像你说的，他们根本不在乎，因为这没有影响到他们，这也是不可原谅的。我的意思是，卡罗——他，他的文风确实带有一种温和，因为他非常迷恋和倾心于这些年老的改革者——那些代表了早期纽约的年长群体。但有时他就像一个严厉的复仇天使，仿佛在说：“好吧，你们本该意识到的，伙计们，你们当时都在哪儿呢？”
You know, you brought this on yourself. It doesn't matter. The fact that he talks about, you know, it's for Moses to refer to this guy as an extinct volcano is incredibly insulting, but Caro is kind of, it in a way implicitly is like, he kind of is, like his time is, the time for this kind of reform is passed partly because of their own actions. You know, they've sown the seeds of their own obsolescence and now they are reaping what they've sown.
你知道的，这是你们自找的。这无所谓。事实上，他提到“摩西把这家伙称为熄灭的火山”是极其侮辱性的，但卡罗在某种程度上含蓄地表示：他某种程度上确实如此，这种改革的时代已经过去了，部分原因正是他们自己的行为所致。你知道的，他们种下了自己走向过时的种子，现在他们正在自食其果。
And he says this is a turning point for the city. This is the first time that everyone is against Moses' plans, privately or publicly. The reformers don't like it. The elected officials don't really like it, the press doesn't like it. There's no groundswell of opinion that says, come on, we deserve a big beach or we need a new bridge to get to this place. Nobody wants it. But Moses calls the shot. It doesn't matter. The city council, the full, it goes to the full council the next day. They vote 19 to 6 to support Moses, even though they don't want it. They don't like it. And the next day after that, the state assembly, the state Senate, they overwhelmingly approve the bills, giving Moses this authority to build the crossing. Governor Layman says he'll sign the bill right after that. All
他说这是这座城市的转折点。这是有史以来第一次，所有人都在私下或公开反对摩西的计划。改革者不喜欢它，民选官员其实也不喜欢它，媒体不喜欢它。没有任何民意浪潮在说：“拜访我们吧，我们应得一个巨大的海滩，或者我们需要一座新桥去那个地方。”没有人想要它。但摩西说了算。这无关紧要。市议会，全体，第二天提交给全体议会。他们以19比6的投票结果支持摩西，尽管他们并不想要它。他们不喜欢它。再过一天，州议会、州参议院以压倒性多数通过了法案，赋予摩西修建这座跨江通道的权力。莱曼州长表示他随后就会签署该法案。所有
Moses needs is the simplest, most unnecessary of formalities. The war department giving him permission because the bridge is built on navigable waters that are near the Brooklyn Navy yards. And that is so pro forma, he's not even thinking about it. He gets that kind of stuff all the time. The War Department has never been like, no, you can't build this thing in New York because what if we fight a war in New York someday? You know, it's just never has happened.
摩西需要的，只是最简单、最不必要的程序。战争部给予他批准，因为大桥建在靠近布鲁克林海军造船厂的可航行水域上。而这只是例行公事，他甚至都没放在心上。他总是能轻而易举地搞定这种事。战争部从来没有说过：“不，你不能在纽约建造这个东西，因为万一有一天我们在纽约打仗怎么办？”你知道的，这种事从来没有发生过。
And this one, Carol reveals the meaning of the title of the chapter, when the last law was down. It comes from some dialogue from A Man for All Seasons. And the character Roper is telling Sir Thomas More that he would cut down every law in England to get after the devil and Moore responds to him, oh and when the last law was down and the devil turned round on you, where would you hide Roper? The laws being all flat and that's exactly what these reformers have done to help Moses get things done, to help
而这一次，卡罗揭示了这一章标题的含义——“当最后一道法律倒下时”。它来自《四季之人》（A Man for All Seasons）中的一段对白。角色罗珀（Roper）告诉托马斯·莫尔爵士（Sir Thomas More），为了抓住魔鬼，他会砍倒英国所有的法律，而莫尔回答他：“哦，当最后一道法律倒下，魔鬼转过身来对付你时，罗珀，你将躲在哪里？”法律全部被推倒了——而这正是这些改革者为了帮助摩西办成事情、为了帮助
him do things like the parks and the beach. They have cut down all the laws that stood in his way and now that what he's doing is something they don't want and they need something to have stand in his way. There's no laws left for the city to hide behind. There's nothing that the city itself can do. There's nothing the state can do. And the reformers, they are out of ideas. They are, they've done the things they were supposed to do. They tried to get a meeting. They made a presentation at a city council. It didn't, it didn't work. And so they don't have to do, they turn to advice to this new character comes in, Charles Culp, C.C. Burlingham, 81 years old, from the most respected old school reformers.
他做诸如公园和海滩之类的事情而做的事情。他们砍倒了所有挡在他路上的法律，而现在，他正在做的事情是他们不想要的，他们需要有什么东西来挡住他的路。已经没有法律可以让这座城市躲在背后了。这座城市本身什么也做不了。州政府也什么都做不了。而改革者们，他们已经黔驴技穷了。他们，他们已经做了他们应该做的事情。他们试图安排会面。他们在市议会上做了陈述。这没用，根本不管用。因此他们束手无策，只好向这位新登场的人物寻求建议：查尔斯·卡尔普，C·C·伯灵恒（C.C. Burlingham），81岁，来自最受尊敬的老派改革者。
And Caro doesn't mention this, but Wikipedia describes him as being known as the first citizen of New York. He was just like a civic reformer, you know, since the late 19th century. And they go to him and Caro describes him, he thinks, and then he smiles and he says, call Eleanor. And on April 5th, 1939, Eleanor Roosevelt, who Robert Moses has called terrible names and said horrible things about, and she knows it. At this point, she's writing a daily newspaper column called My Day, and she puts a paragraph in it about the bridge. She doesn't mention Moses, but she mentions, oh, they're going to build this bridge. And she says, isn't there room for some consideration of the preservation of the few beautiful spots that still remain to us on an
卡罗没有提到这一点，但维基百科将他描述为“纽约第一公民”。自19世纪末以来，他一直是一名市民改革家。他们去找他，卡罗描述说，他思考了一会儿，然后笑了笑说：“给埃莉诺打电话。”在1939年4月5日，埃莉诺·罗斯福——罗伯特·摩西曾用极其难听的称呼称呼过她，并说过关于她的可怕言论，而她对此心知肚明。此时，她正在撰写一篇名为《我的一天》（My Day）的每日报纸专栏，她在其中写了一段关于这座桥的文字。她没有提到摩西，但她提到了“哦，他们打算造这座桥”。她说：“难道就没有空间考虑保护一下在我们这个
overcrowded island? And Caro describes this paragraph as a small ripple showing that there's larger movement going on beneath the surface of the water of this, not, you know, the New York harbors, but I mean, the metaphorical water, because as you may remember, Eleanor Roosevelt is of course married to the most powerful man in the United States of America, who is also Robert Moses' greatest enemy in the history of the world, Franklin Roosevelt. Yeah. And this problem that he has has been kicked up to the war department, which is something under Roosevelt's purview.
过度拥挤的岛屿上仅存的几个美丽的斑块吗？”卡罗将这段文字描述为一小波涟漪，表明在这片平静的水面——不是纽约港的水面，而是指隐喻的水面——之下正在发生更大的运动，因为正如你可能记得的那样，埃莉诺·罗斯福当然是嫁给了美利坚合众国最有权势的人，而这个人同时也是罗伯特·罗斯福。不对，是罗伯特·摩西在世界历史上最大的敌人——富兰克林·罗斯福。是的。而且他遇到的这个问题已经被提交给了战争部，这是罗斯福管辖范围内的事务。
This is, yeah, this is the, if there's one person who can tell the War Department to do something or not do something, it is the commander in chief, literally the highest ranking official in the military and the United States government. And so they, the reformers, they're still having letters printed in newspapers saying we should have a tunnel on a bridge, but it's the private letters that they're writing to Roosevelt that end up being decisive in this. And so the pro forma hearing for the war department report somehow mysteriously gets delayed. And Harold Icky is the, the interior secretary who we remember from before he took the blame for order number 129 and things like that. He wants this bridge to be built. He wants big
这就是，是的，如果说有一个人能够命令战争部做某事或不做某事，那就是三军统帅，字面意义上美国政府和军队中级别最高官员。因此，他们，改革者们，仍然在报纸上印刷信件，声称比起桥梁我们更应该建造隧道，但最终起到决定性作用的，却是他们写给罗斯福的私人信件。于是，战争部报告的例行听证会不知何故神秘地被推迟了。而哈罗德·伊克斯（Harold Ickes）——我们还记得他之前曾为129号令及类似事情背锅的内政部长——他希望这座桥能够建造。他希望有大型项目
projects that are going to employ people still. And he keeps bringing up in meetings. Each time Roosevelt's like, I don't know. I'm not so sure about it. And eventually it gets through to Icky's that he's going to have the war department to say that the bridge impedes navigation too much around lower Manhattan. Like Roosevelt is not going to let this bridge get built. Not because of necessarily the things that Robert Moses says about it, not necessarily even because the reformers have a good argument about it. Though I'm sure if any president would understand the importance of the battery as a place, it would be either Franklin Roosevelt or Theodore Roosevelt, who literally grew up in Manhattan
能够继续为人们提供就业岗位。他在会议上不断提出这一点。每次罗斯福都说：“我不知道。我对此不太确定。”最终，伊克斯明白了，罗斯福将让战争部发表声明，称这座桥对曼哈顿下城周围的航运造成了过大的阻碍。就像罗斯福不会让这座桥建成一样。这不一定是因为罗伯特·摩西对它说了什么，甚至不一定是因为改革者们对此有充分的论据。尽管我敢肯定，如果有哪位总统会理解炮台公园作为一个地方的重要性，那要么是富兰克林·罗斯福，要么是西奥多·罗斯福，他
and would go down to the battery. There's a story in his autobiography about going down to the maritime parts of the city and seeing a seal carcass that had been laid out on a table and that instilling in Theodore Roosevelt his interest in naturalism and animals, which would run through the rest of his life and be such a big influence on the park system, the national park system. So anyway, the Roosevelts, they understand New York and they understand water. They love water and they like New York water. So if there's any president who's going to take an interest in this, it's Franklin Roosevelt. But he may be doing this just because he hates Robert
literally在曼哈顿长大，并会去到炮台公园。在他的自传中有一个故事，讲述了他去到城市的滨海地区，看到桌上摆着一具海豹尸体，这在西奥多·罗斯福心中激起了他对自然主义和动物的兴趣，这种兴趣贯穿了他的一生，并对公园系统、国家公园系统产生了巨大的影响。无论如何，罗斯福家族，他们了解纽约，他们了解水。他们热爱水，他们喜欢纽约的水。所以如果有哪位总统会对这件事产生兴趣，那就是富兰克林·罗斯福。但他这么做可能只是因为他讨厌罗伯特·
Moses. And finally, he has a chance to get at him. So the war department, they do exactly that. They decide, nah, we're not going to give permission for this. They sit on that decision for two months before releasing it on July 17th, 1939. They go, yeah, this bridge is going to be too close to the Navy yard in Brooklyn. So if there was a war and someone bombed that bridge and it fell into the water, it would block the access. We can't build that. And Robert Carroll points out and Robert Carroll doesn't want this bridge built either, but he points out, this is pretty ridiculous. There are other bridges in the same basic position to the Navy yard.
摩西。终于，他有了机会对付他。于是战争部，他们正是这么做的。他们决定：“不，我们不会批准这个。”他们将这个决定搁置了两个月，直到1939年7月17日才公之于众。他们说：“是的，这座桥离布鲁克林海军造船厂太近了。所以如果发生战争，有人轰炸了这座桥，它掉进水里，就会阻断交通。我们不能建造它。”而罗伯特·卡罗指出，罗伯特·卡罗也不想建这座桥，但他指出，这简直荒谬。还有其他桥梁相对于海军造船厂处于基本相同的战略位置。
And it's a suspension bridge. It's not easy to knock down. Like if you bomb it from the air, the bombs are just gonna go through or blow up the deck. They're not really gonna get there. It's gonna be hard to knock it down, but that's the reasoning they give. And Moses is furious and he tries to do what he did with order 129.
而且这是一座悬索桥。它没那么容易被撞倒。就像如果你从空中轰炸它，炸弹只会穿过去或者炸毁桥面。它们无法真正摧毁它。要把它炸倒很难，但这就是他们给出的理由。摩西大发雷霆，他试图重演他对待129号令时的故伎。
He tells the press, Roosevelt is buying this decision. And when the press goes to Roosevelt, they go, did you decide this? He goes, I don't think so. I don't really care. Like a bridge, I'm not even thinking about it. And Moses tries to get LaGuardia to back them up. And LaGuardia suddenly is not that interested in the bridge anymore either.
他告诉媒体，罗斯福是在幕后操纵这个决定的。当记者去问罗斯福时，他们问：“这是你决定的吗？”他说：“我不这么认为。我根本不在乎。像这样的一座桥，我甚至压根没想过。”摩西试图让拉瓜迪亚支持他们。而拉瓜迪亚突然也对这座桥不再那么感兴趣了。
Maybe it's because by coincidence, the federal government has just extended a low interest loan to the city that will allow them to build a Brooklyn battery tunnel. Maybe that has something to do with it. And years later, even after Moses eventually does get control of this tunnel, he doesn't get to build this bridge, but he does control the tunnel eventually. He still gets furious if the subject of the bridge comes up, and he will fume about Eleanor Roosevelt's involvement and what a moron she was,
也许是因为巧合的是，联邦政府刚刚向该市提供了一笔低息贷款，允许他们建造布鲁克林-炮台隧道。也许这与此有某种关系。多年以后，甚至在摩西最终控制了这条隧道之后，他虽然没能建造这座桥，但最终还是控制了隧道。每当提起建桥的话题，他仍然会勃然大怒，并会怒气冲冲地谈到埃莉诺·罗斯福的插手以及她是个多么白痴，
and how, you know, how, what meddling it was. And to add further insult to injury, LaGuardia is like, oh yeah, Robert Moses, the city's not going to pay for the road linking the battery crossing to your parkway system. So you'll have to pay for that. This five mile gap in the belt system that he'd been dreaming about closing all this time. And weren't you just bragging that the authority has like $12 million on hand? So you should be able to pay for that fine. We don't have to help you with that at all. So not only does he not get to build his bridge, but he has to pay to build a road to link to the tunnel that he didn't want built. And the central committee of organization opposing the battery toll bridge, which is the full name
以及这如何，你知道的，是多么多管闲事。为了雪上加霜，拉瓜迪亚还表态说：“哦，对了，罗伯特·摩西，市政府不会为连接炮台跨江通道和你们公园大道的道路买单。所以你们得自己付钱。”他一直梦想着闭合的皮带路网中有这五英里的缺口。你刚才不是还在吹嘘说管理局手头上有大约1200万美元吗？所以你应该有能力自己支付这笔钱。我们根本不需要在这方面帮你们任何忙。因此，他不仅没能建起他的桥，还得自己掏钱修建一条通往他根本不想建的隧道的道路。反对炮台收费桥中央组织委员会——这是该组织的完整名称，
of the organization. I'll say it again, the organizations opposing the battery toll bridge, which is a very specific name for a group. And it's like, that's a civic group built like a public authority. It has one goal, stop a battery toll bridge, and then it's going to disband efforts. They hold a victory luncheon to celebrate winning the battle of Battery Park and Caro, again, he's like kind of shaking his head talking about it. You can imagine him going, the fools, the same way aliens do in movies where earth sets off atomic weapons or something. The aliens always go, the fools, they don't know what they're doing. He describes them as they're still ignorant on the most important lesson of this battle. Yes, they stopped Moses. That bridge is not going to be there.
我再重复一遍，反对炮台收费桥组织，这是一个针对某个团体的非常具体的名称。这就像是一个按照公共管理局模式建立的市民团体；它只有一个目标：阻止炮台收费桥，然后它就会解散。他们举办了一场胜利午宴，庆祝赢得炮台公园之战，而卡罗，再次地，他在谈到这件事时有点摇头叹息。你可以想象他一边说“这些傻瓜”，就像科幻电影里地球人触发了原子武器什么的，外星人总是会说：“这些傻瓜，他们根本不知道自己在做什么。”他将这些人描述为，他们对这场战役中最重要的一课仍然一无所知。是的，他们阻止了摩西。那座桥不会在那里了。
But in order to stop him, the president of the United States had to step in. The city couldn't stop him. The state couldn't stop him. No civic or municipal or institutional check on his power, which could stand up to him. It had to take the most powerful man in the country who has a particular mad on for this guy to stop the bridge where that bridge would be there today battery park would basically not exist and there would be a bridge there today if the president stepped in and Moses
但为了阻止他，美利坚合众国的总统不得不亲自介入。城市无法阻止他。州政府无法阻止他。没有任何市民、市政或体制上的权力制衡能够与他抗衡。必须依靠这个国家权力最大、且对这家伙抱有刻骨铭心的私人恩怨的人，才能阻止这座桥——如果那座桥今天就建在那里，炮台公园基本上就不会存在了，如果总统没有介入，那里今天就会有一座桥。而摩西
had still even after losing this this battle in the longer war of the control of New York he still has more say over the city's future than anyone else below the level of the commander in chief of the armed forces. It's really something. And this war is not over because the next battle is about to be fought and Robert Moses is going to get his revenge on the people who love the Battery Park. That is after this. So we're onto chapter 30 called Revenge. And it starts with a great chapter title.
即使在输掉了这场战斗、但在控制纽约的长期战争中，他对比武装部队总司令级别以下任何人都对这座城市的未来拥有更大的发言权。这真的很了不起。而且这场战争还没有结束，因为下一场战役即将打响，而罗伯特·摩西将向那些热爱炮台公园的人们复仇。那是在这之后的事。所以我们进入了名为“复仇”的第三十章。它以一个伟大的章节标题开篇。
Sorry. It's a really good one. It starts with a Sir Francis Bacon quote. What is that quote, Elliot? So the quote is, a man that studyeth revenge keeps his own wounds green. And this is from a short essay or writing, you know, they didn't really have essays per se,
抱歉。这个点子真的很好。它以弗朗西斯·培根的一句名言开篇。埃利奥特，那句名言是什么？所以这句话是，一个研究复仇的人会让自己的伤口永不愈合。这出自一篇短文或著作，你知道的，当时他们其实并没有严格意义上的散文，
but a short writing called Of Revenge from 1625. And it's a Francis Bacon piece all about how you should not try to get revenge. Yeah, yeah. Revenge will only, you know, as the old saying goes, he doesn't say this, but the old saying goes, when you seek revenge, dig two graves, you know. But Caro, I love, he's being very literary in this string of
而是一篇写于1625年的题为《论复仇》的短文。这是一篇弗朗西斯·培根的作品，主要讲的是你不应该试图去复仇。是的，是的，正如老话所说，复仇只会——他虽然没这么说，但老话是这么说的，当你寻求复仇时，挖两个墓，你知道的。但是卡罗，我喜欢，他在这一连串
chapters. When the last law was down, this one, he's, some would call it showing off, but I like to believe that Caro is just including the stuff that he discovered along the way while researching Robert Moses, which I think is really a fun way to do it. So revenge, what's this all about? As we know, he didn't get his bridge across from the battery to Brooklyn. He didn't get to rec battery park and turn it into the underside of an enormous highway bridge. So he wants revenge. He wants revenge on the people who did this to him. And he sits on it for a little bit. And he figures, what's the best way to strike out at these reformers? The best way to strike out these reformers is to petulantly destroy something that they
章节中表现得非常富有文学色彩。在最后一项法律被击溃时，这一次，他——有人可能会说这是在炫耀，但我愿意相信，卡罗只是把他在研究罗伯特·摩西的过程中沿途发现的东西都写了进去，我认为这真是一种很有趣的写作方式。那么复仇，这到底是怎么回事？如我们所知，他没能建成从炮台公园通往布鲁克林的桥。他没能重新规划炮台公园并把它变成巨大的高速公路桥的桥底。所以他想要复仇。他想向那些对他做过这种事的人复仇。他对此隐忍了一小会儿。然后他琢磨着，打击这些改革派的最佳方式是什么？打击这些改革派的最佳方式，就是意气用事地毁掉他们
love. And so in February 1941, when much of the world is worried about the war that's going on in Europe, he decides that Castle Clinton, which holds the New York Aquarium, is unsafe and it needs to be torn down for the Brooklyn Battery Tunnel, and he's going to demolish it immediately. And then he's gonna give land to the Bronx so they can build a $2 million aquarium close to the Bronx zoo.
所热爱的东西。因此，在1941年2月，当世界上大部分人都还在为欧洲正在进行的战争担忧时，他决定克林顿城堡——那里容纳着纽约水族馆——是不安全的，为了布鲁克林-炮台隧道，它必须被拆除，而且他要立刻将其拆除。然后他要把土地送给布朗克斯，这样他们就可以在布朗克斯动物园附近建一个价值200万美元的水族馆。
And you remember from earlier in the episode, Castle Clinton, it's an amazingly beautiful piece of New York history. Roman, you were so excited about hearing about all the famous people that came through it and how it could never be touched because it was so wonderfully historic. But you're not the only one who felt that way. Caro says that there's a storm of letters to the editor from people who love the old aquarium, love the old fort. They can't understand why for all that money, the $2 million that they say the
你还记得本集前面提到的克林顿城堡，它是纽约历史上绝无仅有的美丽建筑。罗曼，你当时听到那么多名人都曾到访过它，以及它因为具有如此奇妙的历史意义而永远不容触碰时，是多么兴奋啊。但有这种感觉的人可不止你一个。卡罗说，编辑部收到了海量的读者来信，来自那些热爱旧水族馆、热爱旧堡垒的人们。他们不明白，为什么花了那么多钱——他们说
aquarium is going to cost in the Bronx, why they couldn't use that money to update the building, rather than tear it down and build a new one. And Moses is like, people, this fort is an eminent danger of falling down. It is a public safety hazard, which is clearly a lie. Like it's a ring of eight foot thick walls that have stood for 139 years at that point. And spoiler alert, he fails in tearing it down and they're still standing, you know, another hundred years later almost. So it's fine. But he tells people it's dangerous, it's ugly. He says it's not historical. And he says, nobody wants it there but those elderly goo-goos. But ordinary New Yorkers, which is a hard phrase to say, they're upset at the idea of tearing it down. And Caro asks in the book, even if they're building a new aquarium, why
水族馆在布朗克斯要花掉200万美元——为什么他们不能用这笔钱来翻新这座建筑，而不是把它拆了再建一个新的？而摩西的反应则是：各位，这座堡垒已经面临倒塌的极度危险。这是一个公共安全隐患，这显然是个谎言。因为那是一圈厚达8英尺的墙，到那时已经屹立了139年。剧透一下，他拆除它的企图失败了，而且它在差不多又过了一百年后依然屹立不倒。所以没关系。但他告诉人们它很危险，很丑陋。他说它没有历史价值。他还说，除了那些老派的改革派，没人希望它留在那儿。但普通的纽约人——这是一个很难发音的短语——对拆除它的想法感到非常不安。卡罗在书里质问，即使他们要建一个新水族馆，为什么
did they have to tear down the old one immediately before the new one is even built? It doesn't seem like a big thing for a city to have an aquarium, especially for a maritime city that doesn't get to see the water very much, at least this is a connection to, to the creatures of the seas. But Roman, how do you feel about this tearing down the aquarium when there isn't even one there to replace it yet? I mean, it's awful. And you know, the thing is, is that there is no reason all of his reasons are trumped up nonsense. And the only answer is he's mad. Like he can't build the bridge the way he wants to the Brooklyn battery crossing is going
非要在新水族馆甚至还没建好之前，就把旧的立刻拆掉呢？对于一个城市来说，拥有一个水族馆似乎并不是什么大不了的事，特别是对于一个滨海城市而言，人们本来就很难看到水，至少这是与海洋生物的一种联系。但是罗曼，在甚至还没有水族馆来替代它的情况下，你对拆除这个水族馆作何感想？我的意思是，这太糟糕了。你知道的，问题在于，根本没有任何理由，他的所有理由都是胡编乱造的废话。唯一的解释就是他疯了。就像他没能按自己想要的方式建造大桥，布鲁克林-炮台通道
to be a tunnel. And he's going to destroy the park, which he has complete, uh, domain over like anything inside the park. He can kind of do what he wants to. And he's just taking it out on these people that wanted to preserve the park. And it's just awful. This is a situation where even the president of the United States who was able to stop him from building that bridge last time can't really do anything about it. This is park land.
将不得不变成一条隧道。而且他要毁掉这个公园，他对公园拥有完全的、呃，管辖权，就像公园里的任何东西一样。他想怎么处理就怎么处理。他只是把气撒在这些想要保护公园的人身上。这实在是太糟糕了。在这种情况下，就连上次能够阻止他建桥的美国总统也对此无能为力。这是公园用地。
Yeah. Moses has unlimited power in park lands. The courts always reaffirm that. Uh, and so Moses, he's like, I'm doing it. I'm closing battery park while construction is going on. I'm going to close the aquarium forever. And all the reformers can do their, their cold comfort is they can protest at a meeting of the board of estimate where Moses had asked for $20,000 to house the fish during the construction of the new aquarium.
是的。摩西在公园土地上拥有无限的权力。法庭总是重申这一点。呃，所以摩西就放话了：我就是要这么做。施工期间我要关闭炮台公园。我要永远关闭水族馆。而所有改革派能做的、他们仅有的一点聊胜于无的安慰，就是在估价委员会的会议上进行抗议。摩西曾在那次会议上要求拨款2万美元，用于在建设新水族馆期间安置这些鱼。
And he's like, if you don't give me the money, I'm just going to throw the fish into the sea. Like this, this is a scorched earth aquarium policy of a kinds that New York has never seen before. Because Moses, he doesn't need their permission to do any of this. He doesn't need the permission to close the park, to tear the fort down. And he's still popular enough because of his parks work that the elected officials who could make a stink about it at least, they don't want to piss them off because there's another election coming up. There's always another election coming up. And these officials who had been on the record against Moses's plan to do this, when it comes to a vote, they vote to approve it. LaGuardia does not like the aquarium plan,
而他的态度是：如果你们不给我这笔钱，我就把这些鱼直接扔进海里。就像这样，这是一种纽约从未见过的前所未有的焦土政策式的水族馆政策。因为摩西根本不需要他们的许可就能做这些事。他不需要关闭公园、拆除堡垒的许可。而且由于他之前在公园建设上的政绩，他依然拥有足够高的人气，以至于那些本可以在这件事上大做文章的民选官员，由于面临即将到来的选举，根本不想惹恼他。总是有另一场选举即将来临。而这些此前曾明确反对摩西这一计划的官员，在到了投票表决的时候，居然投票通过了它。拉瓜迪亚并不喜欢这个水族馆计划，
but he supports it, seemingly in exchange for Moses turning down the opportunity to run as the Republican mayoral candidate and publicly supporting LaGuardia's reelection. There's Moses is just still such a powerful figure in the public mind, even outside of his park power that people don't want to get on the bad side, even if they don't like what he's doing and they'll be mad afterwards when it happens. So by October 1st of that year, the aquarium is closed. The fish have been moved out, thankfully to tanks, I believe, and not just to their, their native seas.
但他还是支持了，这似乎是用摩西放弃竞选共和党市长候选人、转而公开支持拉瓜迪亚竞选连任作为交换。在公众心目中，摩西依然是一个极具影响力的人物，即使抛开他在公园事务上的权力不谈，人们也不想惹上麻烦，哪怕他们不喜欢他正在做的事，而且事后他们会为此感到愤怒。因此，到那一年的10月1日，水族馆关闭了。鱼已经被搬走了，谢意上帝，据我所知是搬到了水箱里，而不是直接扔回它们原生的大海。
Uh, and, and I just have this image. I wish, I almost wish he'd done it so there'd be a photograph of Robert Moses personally hurling fish into the water at the, at the tip of Manhattan, but it didn't happen. Uh, and he's preparing to tear down the old fort. Nothing can stop him from tearing down this old fort. But wait, there's that spoiler earlier. I said the fort's still there, right? Something does get in the way. It took the president to stop him last time. This time it takes World War II to stop him from tearing down
呃，而且，我脑海里总有这样一个画面。我甚至希望他真的那么干了，这样就能留下一张罗伯特·摩西在曼哈顿尖端亲自把鱼往水里扔的照片，但那并没有发生。呃，他正准备拆除旧堡垒。没有什么能阻止他拆除这座旧堡垒。但等等，前面不是有剧透吗？我说过堡垒还在，对吧？确实有什么东西挡了路。上次需要出动总统才能阻止他。这一次，是第二次世界大战阻止了他拆除
the fort. By this point, the war is, is starting up. America joins the war by December of 41. The war takes so much manpower out of New York that no demolition companies will bid on the job of tearing this fort down because they don't have the workers. They're busy. The workers are busy fueling the war machine that will destroy Hitler. And so Moses is, it's one of these weird things where Moses's interests are directly opposed to that of the free world because Moses wants workers available to take on the fort. So he's able to remove the fort's roof, but not those big walls.
这座堡垒。到了这个时候，战争已经打响了。美国在41年12月加入了二战。战争从纽约抽走了大量的劳动力，以至于没有任何拆迁公司愿意投标拆除这座堡垒的工作，因为他们没有工人。他们很忙。工人们正忙着为摧毁希特勒的战争机器提供动力。因此摩西面临着一个奇怪的局面，摩西的利益与自由世界的利益直接相悖，因为摩西需要工人来拆除堡垒。所以他只拆掉了堡垒的屋顶，却拆不掉那些厚实的墙壁。
And the reformers tie him up in court for a little bit, but he always wins in court because he wrote the law. The law is clear. He has supreme power over the parks and he knows he's not going to get the job done until the war is over. So he settles for just putting a fence around battery park and keeping the park closed to the public for five years, just out of spite. He doesn't need to do this.
改革派在法庭上缠了他一阵子，但他在法庭上总是能赢，因为法律是他写的。法律很明确。他对公园拥有至高无上的权力，而且他知道在战争结束之前他是无法完成这项工作的。所以他退而求其次，只是在炮台公园周围围上栅栏，仅仅出于恶意，就把公园对公众关闭了五年。他根本没必要这么做。
There's no reason. Caro spent so much time in the previous chapter to about how necessary this park is for this overbuilt up part of the city. And now most is like, well, you don't get it. Like it's really one of his more petulant acts. It truly is. It's truly awful. And, you know, during this time period, the, the people are trying to, you know,
这毫无道理。卡罗在上一章中花了大量时间阐述这个公园对于这个过度建设的城市部分有多么重要，而现在摩西的态度却是：哼，你们不懂。这真的是他最任性的行为之一。确实如此。这真的太糟糕了。而且，你知道的，在这段时期，人们正试图让
have the national park service take over the possession of the fort or store it, maintain it, you know, he puts a fence around it. He basically just does all these things to obstruct. He tells people, uh, the national park service can't take it over because I already destroyed it. Yeah. You can't see it, but it's already gone. And me, and like one of the newspapers eventually hires a plane to fly over and they're like,
国家公园管理局接管这座堡垒的所有权，或者将其妥善保存、进行维护，你知道的，他却在它周围建起栅栏。他基本上就是在用这些手段进行阻挠。他告诉人们，呃，国家公园管理局没法接管它，因为我已经把它毁了。对啊，你们看不到了，因为它已经没了。然后呢，其中一家报社最终雇了一架飞机飞过上空，他们发现：
it's still there. Like, we can see it there. And it's ridiculous that he's just going to such lengths to get this thing destroyed. And finally, in 1946, he gets a demolition authorization from the Board of Estimate. There's a new mayor, William O'Dwyer by then, and he told the fort preservers, yeah, you've got my support. And then he immediately flips and like, it's like, yeah, Moses tear down that fort. And another court battle.
它还在那儿呢！就像，我们能看到它就在那儿。他居然为了摧毁这东西而无所不用其极，这实在是太荒谬了。最终，在1946年，他从估价委员会那里得到了拆迁授权。当时已经有了一位新市长威廉·奥德怀尔，他曾对堡垒保护者们说：行吧，你们有我的支持。然后他立刻反悔了，变成：行吧，摩西，去把那个堡垒拆了吧。于是又是一场法庭之争。
And the reformers literally, they want to file a lawsuit to stop him. And there's a story where they're like, yeah, we'll file it on Monday. And the person is like, you got to file it this afternoon, Friday afternoon, because that fort will be gone this weekend if you don't do it. And eventually it takes a New York Supreme Court justice injunction to stop it from being torn down over this weekend in 1946. But the order is too late to stop Moses from taking these huge wooden doors on the fourth that have been there for over a century and just burning them. Like, just take them down. He's such a, he's such a kid, you know, such a child. And just to give you this, a little bit of idea of this, the amount of time here, what
改革派简直是——他们想要提起诉讼来阻止他。有个故事说，他们当时觉得：行，我们周一去起诉。结果对方却说：你们今天下午、周五下午就得去起诉，因为如果你们不这么做，这个周末那座堡垒就要不复存在了。最终，直到1946年，在纽约最高法院法官下达禁令之后，才总算阻止了它在那个周末被拆毁。但这项命令下达得太晚了，没能阻止摩西把堡垒上那些已经存在了一个多世纪的巨大木门直接烧掉。真的就是，直接把它们拆下来烧了。他简直就像个孩子，你知道的，就像个小屁孩。为了让你对这件事有个概念，了解一下时间跨度，
World War II has happened, uh, FDR is dead. Like, like this is like, it's president Truman now. Like, and it's one of those things that when you get, when he mentions president Truman in the book here, it's like shocking because you realize. Like it feels like one fight, like this is a really fun and exciting chapter. It's really infuriating chapter actually, but it's also just like it moves.
第二次世界大战已经发生了，罗斯福总统也去世了。就像——现在已经是杜鲁门总统当政了。就像，当你看到书里提到杜鲁门总统时，会觉得很震惊，因为你意识到——这感觉就像是一场漫长的较量。这其实是一个非常有趣、让人兴奋的章节。实际上也是一个极其令人气愤的章节，但它同时又极具推进感。
And it's like easy to lose track of the fact that it moves so much is happening or so much time is going by. This revenge is just like these wounds are green. Like this is lasting a long, long time. His main nemesis in the White House is already dead, and he just keeps on having this fight, and he cannot let it go.
而且很容易让人忽略这样一个事实：事情发展得太快了，或者说有如此多的时间正在流逝。这种复仇就像是——这些伤口依然新鲜。这持续了非常、非常长的时间。他在白宫的主要死对头已经去世了，而他却还在继续这场斗争，完全不肯放手。
He's just an addictive man. And the same time that he's still working on this, he's doing many other things. It's not like this is the one thing that he's just gnawing away at. He's got lots of stuff to keep him busy, to distract him, and yet he cannot give up the idea of destroying this thing. So when he first starts getting involved with the possibility of a Brooklyn Battery crossing, that's 1938, it's the late 30s.
他简直是个对权力上瘾的人。就在他还在折腾这件事的同时，他还在做着许多其他的事情。这并不是说这是他唯一死磕的事情。他有很多事情要让自己忙碌，来转移注意力，然而他就是无法放弃摧毁这个建筑的想法。所以，当他最初开始介入布鲁克林-炮台跨海通道的可能性时，那还是1938年，也就是30年代末。
This doesn't stop until 1950 when finally Congress passes a law naming Fort Clinton as a national historic monument that's going to be preserved by the Park Service. So you would think over the course of the nine years between when he loses the crossing fight in 1941 and when the Fort is actually protected by Congress that he would lose interest, give up, do anything else. Like we've said, Roosevelt's dead. World War II has come and gone. Like this is the 50s now when this is happening.
直到1950年这一切才算结束，当时国会终于通过了一项法律，将克林顿城堡命名为国家历史纪念碑，由公园管理局负责保护。所以你会以为，在他1941年输掉过江通道之争，到1950年国会真正保护该堡垒这九年时间里，他本该失去兴趣、选择放弃，或者去干点别的什么。就像我们说过的，罗斯福已经去世了。二战也已经来临又结束了。这都已经是50年代了。
And it's, this is a very different time in American history than we started, but he's just held out hope that he can destroy this thing until then, because when you hold onto revenge, your wounds stay green. Like your wounds don't heal, you know? And so he's still, it still bugs him. So the fort does get saved, but because it sort of houses this aquarium, there was kind of an ecosystem of attractions that made it a vibrant place. Like people wanted to go to the aquarium, it was close by on the tip of Manhattan.
而且，这与我们开始讲述时的美国历史时期大不相同，但他一直抱持着能亲手摧毁这东西的希望，直到那时。因为当你怀揣复仇之心时，你的伤口就会一直鲜血淋漓。就像你的伤口不会愈合一样，你知道吗？所以这事儿依然在折磨着他。因此，堡垒确实保住了，但因为它曾经容纳过这个水族馆，这里曾经存在某种游乐设施的生态系统，让它成了一个充满活力的地方。人们想去水族馆，它就位于曼哈顿的尖端，交通便利。
And it was free at that time. And it was free and the fort was there and they all kind of supported each other. And Fort Clinton, like it was closed for a long time and then it had nothing in it and people didn't visit it as much. The aquarium was much further out and cost money. You know, it just was one of those things, and it took a long ass time for the new aquarium to open as well.
而且那会儿还是免费的。门票是免费的，堡垒也在那儿，它们相辅相成。而克林顿城堡呢，它关闭了很长一段时间，里面空无一物，人们去的次数也少多了。新的水族馆建得更远，而且还要收费。你知道的，事情就是这样，而且新水族馆开放也花了极长、极长的时间。
Yes, it goes, so New York doesn't have an aquarium for 14 years. It doesn't open again until 1955. And Robert Caro, he really, he really kind of takes a dump on the Coney Island Aquarium. The one that's like, he's like, it's a new aquarium, but people don't really like it very much. And as a kid who went to that aquarium and has been there as recently as last year,
没错，就是这样，所以纽约有整整14年没有水族馆。直到1955年它才重新开业。而罗伯特·卡罗，他真的、真的对康尼岛水族馆嗤之以鼻。他说这虽然是个新水族馆，但人们其实并不怎么喜欢它。作为一个曾经去过那个水族馆、甚至就在去年还去过的人，
I still like it. And I was very saddened by the fact that when Hurricane Sandy hit New York, it really trashed that aquarium and the aquarium has not fully recovered from it. But I feel like Caro, he's letting the old be the enemy of the new there, where it's like, there are generations of New Yorkers who, and people in the New York area who do like that aquarium, but he's really like, he's like, the old one was great. It was musty and nice and this one sticks.
我其实还是挺喜欢它的。而且我感到非常痛心的是，当桑迪飓风袭击纽约时，那个水族馆遭到了惨重的破坏，至今尚未完全恢复。但我觉得卡罗在那里有点“以旧非新”了，就好像——纽约有整整好几代人，以及纽约地区的很多人其实都挺喜欢那个水族馆的，但他却态度坚决地说：旧的那个棒极了。它陈旧却美好，而这个简直糟透了。
It's too slick, no one goes to it. But that fort, because of its location and because of the aquarium, you're right, it was a vibrant living part of the city. And at the time that Caro was writing this book, it is now a dead thing. It's a thing that is a historic piece of architecture, but there's no reason for people to go there. It's just a monument. And of course, since the book was written, that has changed. And in 1986, it became the ticket office for the Statue of Liberty.
它太油滑了，根本没人去。但那座堡垒，由于它的地理位置以及水族馆的存在，你们说得对，它曾经是这座城市充满活力、充满生机的一部分。而在卡罗写这本书的时候，它现在已经变成了一个死物。它成了一处具有历史意义的建筑，但人们没有任何理由去那里。它只是一座纪念碑。当然，自从这本书写成之后，情况发生了变化。1986年，它成了自由女神像的售票处。
So it's now incredibly busy now. Now it's a site that, if you've ever been there, it's very crowded. And so there's some life to it there. But even 1986 is 12 years after this book came out. So it's these long stretches of time that this building that could have use. And I know Roman, like you're saying, you like things that are useful. You don't like just having a monument that just sits there, taking up space. I like plenty of monuments. When living people can do things. I just think that people lay it on kind of thick and use it as a cudgel when it really can be a place
所以它现在变得异常忙碌。如今它成了一个地方，如果你去过的话，会发现那里非常拥挤。所以它又焕发了一点生机。但即便1986年也是这本书问世12年之后的事了。所以这期间经历了漫长的时间跨度，这座本来可以发挥作用的建筑——我知道罗曼，就像你说的，你喜欢有实用价值的东西。你不喜欢让一座纪念碑就那么闲置在那里占地方。我其实喜欢很多纪念碑。前提是活人能用它们干点实事。我只是觉得人们有点小题大做，把它当作一根棍棒，而它明明可以是一个充满活力、富有历史底蕴并与时俱进的地方。我只想说这个。
that's vibrant and historic and develops with the times. That's all I'm saying. Yes, but it means that this building, because of Robert Moses' petulance for almost half a century, basically, for more than 40 years, it was just off limits. You just couldn't do anything with it because he just didn't want people doing anything with it,
是的，但这意味着这座建筑，由于罗伯特·摩西近半个世纪——基本上是四十多年来的任性妄为，它一直是个禁区。你根本无法对它做任何事情，因为他就是不想让任何人对它做任何事情，
which is astounding. You know, it's such a show of, and you think it's like he didn't fully get his revenge, but he did kind of get his revenge. Like by the time that was now a place that people would go again for the ticket office, the sexual liberty, everybody Moses fought with in the reformers movement,
这太令人震惊了。你知道的，这真是一种权力的展现。你会觉得，好像他并没有彻底复仇成功，但其实他某种程度上也算复仇成功了。因为等到这里重新成为人们会为了购买自由女神像门票而再次前往的地方时，摩西在改革派运动中与之斗争过的所有人，
I assume was either dead or elderly. Most of them did not see that ford again as a vibrant place. And it's just too bad, but it means that opinions about Moses among the majority of the reformers has now turned. He is no longer their young champion, the miracle man who occasionally oversteps and is sometimes a little reckless. Now they see him, he's a liar, he's a bully. More than one person compares him to Hitler
我猜要么已经去世了，要么都已步入晚年。他们绝大多数人再也没有看到那个堡垒重新成为一个充满活力的地方。这实在是太遗憾了，但这意味着大多数改革派对摩西的看法已经发生了转变。他不再是他们年轻时的冠军、偶尔越界且有时有点鲁莽的奇迹创造者。现在他们眼中的他，是个骗子，是个恶霸。不止一个人在跟罗伯特·卡罗交谈时
when talking to Robert Caro, which is a bit much, which is, I mean, what he's doing is bad, but it's not quite that bad. But they're reaching, they're so mad at him that they're reaching for literally the most sinister thing in their lifetime that they can think of to compare him to. And he clearly puts his own whims above the needs
把他比作希特勒，这有点过分了，我的意思是，他做的事确实很糟糕，但还没糟糕到那种地步。但他们真的是词穷了，他们对他气愤至极，以至于搜肠刮肚地找出他们一生中所能想到的最邪恶的事物来将他作对比。而他显然把自己的奇思妙想置于人民的需求之上，
of the people and his own pettiness and people recognize that now. And they're starting to realize like, Oh, just because he doesn't have a financial interest in things, doesn't mean he is disinterested. He has interest and that interest is in power and throwing his weight around. And now he has, as we've said before, now he has enemies, but those enemies. Are kind of weak. They can't really stop him from doing much.
还有他那狭隘的私心，人们现在终于认清这一点了。他们开始意识到，哦，这并不意味着他没有财务利益，他就对这些事毫无私心。他是有私心的，他的私心就是权力，以及耍弄权威。正如我们之前所说的那样，他现在有了敌人，但这些敌人——
In this case, what's their victory? That eventually he didn't finish destroying this building and just let it molder for many decades. You know? Yeah, it's really a shame, but it really shows what he is like during this period. I mean, it shows what he was always like. There's another example of maybe Carol like pointing out
有点软弱。他们根本无法阻止他做成很多事。在这种情况下，他们的胜利是什么？那就是最终他没有彻底毁掉这座建筑，只是让它荒废了长达几十年之久，你知道吗？是的，这真的是个遗憾，但它确实展现了他在这一时期的真实面貌。我的意思是，这展现了他一直以来的做派。这又是卡罗指出的一个例子：
the idea that these people should have known better at different points in Robert Moses' career. They just seemed to like the direction his bullying was pointed in, and now that it's pointed towards them, they do not like it, and it's just awful. Maybe there's something, I don't know, maybe this is a conservative thing too,
在罗伯特·摩西职业生涯的不同阶段，这些人本该更清醒才对。他们似乎只是恰好喜欢他那霸道作风所指向的方向，而现在当这股霸道指向他们自己时，他们又不高兴了，这简直糟透了。也许有些东西，我不知道，也许这也有点保守派的特点，
but liberals, they get mad at conservatives, but there's nothing that they despise more than older liberals who are kind of out of touch and don't see things that seem clear. And it feels like Caro is a little bit doing some of that stuff here where it's like, I don't like Moses, I don't like the things he did, but even more than that, I'm like disappointed in these older liberals who could not recognize the trap they were falling into. Yeah. Certainly the same way that I get mad, more mad at the baby boomers for being not as good as hippies as I wanted them to be, as I am at conservative people.
但是自由派，他们会对保守派感到愤怒，不过没有什么比那些与现实脱节、看不清显而易见的事物的年长自由派更让他们鄙视的了。感觉卡罗在这里也多多少少有点这种情绪，就好像：我讨厌摩西，我讨厌他做过的那些事，但比起这个，我更对这些未能认清自己正步入陷阱的年长自由派感到失望。没错。这绝对就像我会对婴儿潮一代没能成为我想象中的那种理想嬉皮士而感到愤怒，甚至超过我对保守派的愤怒一样。
Cause I'm like, well, of course conservatives will do stuff I don't like, but you guys, come on, you should be better than this. There's, there's some of that disappointment in there. There's a, it's funny to think about this in a book that is 50 years old, but there's, there's a generational energy there of Caro as a younger man finding fault with these older people who he otherwise admires, but who he sees the shortcomings of. And that's it.
因为我会觉得，好吧，保守派会做出我不喜欢的事那是理所当然的，但你们几个，拜托，你们本来应该表现得更好的。这种失望情绪在其中是存在的。在一本已经有50年历史的书里去思考这一点其实挺有趣的，但其中确实蕴含着一种代际能量：卡罗作为一名年轻人，对这些他本来很钦佩、却又看清了其缺点的前辈们挑出了毛病。就是这样。
It's another kind of, it's something I hadn't thought about too much before with this, but it's something that just adds to the richness of the book. It makes the book feel more like a living thing, you know, as opposed to just kind of old history. Totally, totally. I think that's really astute. It's really interesting to think about him as a disappointed young man in his 30s, looking at these old guard liberals and how they failed and keeping watch over the things that he cares about. It totally, that makes sense to me.
这又是另一种——这是我以前没怎么深入思考过的一个角度，但它确实增添了这本书的厚度。它让这本书感觉更像是一个有生命力的事物，而不单单是陈旧的历史，你知道的。完全如此，完全如此。我觉得这个看法非常敏锐。把年轻时三十多岁的他想象成一个失望的年轻人，看着这些老派自由派如何失败、如何未能守护他所珍视的事物，这种视角真的非常有趣。这完全说得通，我完全能理解。
Yeah, Robert Carroll, he wasn't always the kind of elder statesman of American biography, you know. He was a young guy who was a reporter and he wouldn't have written this book without ideals, without things that he believed in and passionately wanted to push forward. And yeah, that he's able to express that disappointment in a way that feels subtle to me and not a screed. This is not the way that like
是的，罗伯特·卡罗并非一开始就是美国传记文学界德高望重的泰斗，你知道的。他曾是个年轻的记者，如果不是心怀理想、怀揣着自己坚信并充满激情想要推行下去的信念，他是写不出这本书的。而且，他能够以一种在我看来非常微妙、而非长篇大论的方式来表达这种失望。这可不是那种风格，
Hunter S. Thompson would write this book where Hunter S. Thompson would just be kind of out on the page being like, these old farts that didn't really, I mean, saying the kind of stuff that Moses would say, honestly, you know, being openly insulting, these dinosaurs falling into tar pits, unable to see the asteroid flying towards them, you know, that's a, this is me. I'm not as good a writer as Hunter S. Thompson, so I'm not doing a good job of parodying him, but it's that he's able to layer that, that emotion into it.
就像亨特·S·汤普森会写的那样——亨特·S·汤普森大概会直接在书页里写道：这些老家伙其实根本没——我的意思是，老实说，说一些摩西会说的话，公开进行侮辱，把他们比作陷入沥青坑的恐龙、看不到飞向自己的小行星，你知道的，我模仿得不太好，因为我的文笔不如亨特·S·汤普森，但这就是他能够将这种情感层层编织进文字之中的能力。
It just, it's just a, it, it's a, it really shows why on this 50th anniversary of the book, it bears taking us back, taking ourselves mindset wise back to the year it was written and not just the year that we were reading it. That's right. That's right. So Moses has demonstrated his power and his vindictiveness in this fight. And if we sort of go back in time a little bit again, because now we're in a roll back from 1950 to the end of this fight, into back when the Brooklyn battery crossing was done, he's going to get even more power
这真的展现了为什么在这本书出版50周年之际，我们有必要将心态带回它被写就的那个年份，而不仅仅是我们阅读它的那个年份。没错，没错。所以摩西在这场斗争中展示了他的权力和报复心。如果我们再次把时间稍微往回拨一点——因为现在我们要从1950年倒回这场斗争的尾声，回到布鲁克林-炮台通道落成的时候——他将获得更大的权力，
and the power of a monopoly. That is on chapter 31, Monopoly, where Moses gets the second chance to take over the battery tunnel, a thing that he wanted nothing to do with, but now that it exists, he really thinks that he should control all the ins and outs of this city.
也就是垄断的权力。这就是第31章《垄断》的内容，在这一章中，摩西迎来了第二次机会，得以接管炮台隧道——这个他曾经避之不及的东西，但现在既然它已经存在了，他真心觉得这座城市的每一个进出口都应该由他来掌控。
We'll talk about this a little bit later on when he achieves this, but it's like, he's essentially kind of a super villain at this point, where he's like, no one will cross Intor out of Manhattan without my having control, like, no, only with my leave will this city live. Like it's such a, it is a scale of needing power that is on a comic book level, you know?
我们稍后会详细谈到当他达成这一点时的情景，这感觉就像是：此时此刻他本质上有点像个超级大反派，那种态度是：没有人能在未经我允许的情况下进出曼哈顿，这座城市只有在我的准许下才能呼吸运转。这种对权力的渴望，已经达到了漫画书的级别，你知道的！
Like this is the kind of thing that Batman is fighting against, you know, that a villain is going to take control of all the water crossings in and out of Gotham. But he's got his chance because of World War II. World War II got in the way of him tearing down that fort, but don't worry, silver lining. World War II gives him more opportunities to get power and take over that tunnel. He uses his new position that he only holds for seven weeks as head of the city's scrap
这就像是蝙蝠侠正在对抗的那种反派，一个要控制哥谭市所有水上交通要道的恶棍。但他借着第二次世界大战的机会抓住了这个契机。二战阻碍了他拆除那座堡垒，但别担心，塞翁失马焉知非福。二战为他提供了更多的机会来获取权力并接管那条隧道。他利用自己担任城市废金属
metal drive. He says, hey, there's 28,000 tons of steel, in quotes, lining the tunnel that's under construction. And we need to stop work on that tunnel so we can strip that steel and then we won't finish the tunnel to the wallers over because we need that steel for the war effort. And in reality, the tunnel, it only had a couple more years left of work to go. It could have been up and running before the war was done. And the steel that he wanted was actually cast iron that was unsuitable for military use.
回收运动负责人仅短短七周的新职位，公开发声：嘿，隧道建设工地上排列着28000吨钢材（加引号）。我们必须停止那条隧道的施工，这样我们才能把那些钢材拆下来，结果直到战争结束我们也没能建好隧道，因为我们需要把这些钢材留给战争机器。而实际上，那条隧道当时只剩下几年工期了。它本可以在战争结束前就投入运营。而他想要的钢材实际上是铸铁，根本不适合军事用途。
The military did not want it, but he's able to kind of confuse people's knowledge of metals enough to convince them to shut down tunnel construction. And the War Production Board is like, yeah, we're kind of worried that the public will see this tunnel continuing and think, well, that effort should go towards the war. So we won't finish the tunnel for the duration of the war, which means the tunnel authority is not collecting toll money on that tunnel, which means they can't cover the interest payments on their bonds. Even though the federal bondholders say, we're willing to wait, but Moses uses this situation to present a kind of dubious financial statistic to convince LaGuardia that the tunnel authority
军方并不想要它，但他通过成功混淆公众对各种金属的认知，成功说服了人们下令关闭隧道施工。而战时生产委员会的反应则是：好吧，我们确实担心公众看到这条隧道仍在建设会觉得纳闷，认为这些精力应该投入到战争中去。所以我们在战争期间将不再完工这条隧道，这意味着隧道管理局无法从该隧道收取通行费，也就意味着他们无法支付债券的利息。尽管联邦债券持有人表示：我们愿意等待，但摩西却利用这种局面，抛出了一种可疑的财务统计数据，说服拉瓜迪亚相信隧道管理局
cannot meet its needs. It's falling behind on its bond payments. It's doing this because of a situation Moses has orchestrated, the kind of thing we see a lot in politics now where a politician will stop a project or stop a law from passing and then be like, well, I told you it wouldn't work, that it wouldn't happen. And even though they're the person who stopped it from happening. And he badmouths Ola Sinstad, the tunnel engineer. He says the only solution to solve this revenue shortfall for the tunnel is for Trib-brow to take over the tunnel authority, even though, and he doesn't mention this tri-brow is also facing a revenue shortfall because there's a war
无法满足其资金需求。它的债券偿付已经落后了。而这一切的发生，都是因为摩西精心策划了一场危机——就像我们在如今的政坛经常看到的那样，一个政客先是叫停一个项目或阻止一项法律通过，然后宣称：“瞧，我早就说过它行不通、不会成功的”，完全忽略了他们自己正是那个导致其无法成功的人。他还公开诋毁隧道工程师奥拉·辛斯塔德。他说解决隧道收入缺口的唯一办法，就是让三区大桥管理局接管隧道管理局，尽管——而他没有提及的是——三区大桥管理局其实也面临着收入缺口，因为当时正打着仗呢，
on it's the biggest war in the history of the world is going on. There's few people driving to work across across the tri-brow bridge. You know, that's, but he also has a secret up his sleeve. Moses's bloodhounds. We hear a lot about the bloodhounds in mentions, but we don't hear a lot about what they dug up in the book, but we do hear this. And what they dug up here is pretty relatively underwhelming,
这是世界历史上最大规模的战争正在进行。没多少人开车穿梭在三区大桥上。你知道的，情况就是这样，但他手里还藏着一个秘密。摩西的猎犬们。我们在很多地方都听说过这些猎犬，但在书里我们并没有听说太多他们具体挖出了什么，不过我们确实听说了这个。而他们在这里挖出来的东西其实相对来说比较平淡无奇，
but they find out that Ola Singstad's brother-in-law purchased some tenements in the area where the tunnels entrance plaza is supposed to go. And obviously that's a possibility of corruption that his brother-in-law had inside knowledge, bought those buildings, is gonna sell them to the city for an inflated price. An investigation shows that Singstad was not involved
但他们查到奥拉·辛斯塔德的连襟在隧道入口广场预计修建的区域购买了一些廉价公寓。显而易见，这存在一种腐败的可能，即他的连襟利用内幕消息购买了这些建筑，然后准备以高价卖给城市。调查显示，辛斯塔德本人并未参与
with the purchase, was mad at his brother-in-law for doing it and made him lower the price that he was selling the land to the tunnel authority for and that he didn't even wanna put the plaza there in the first place, that his plans had been changed. But he's totally blameless in this, but he never reported his brother-in-law's interest because he was worried Moses would find out about it and smear him. Unfortunately someday. I don't know what he's going to do. He's going to run for president. He's going to run for president.
这次购买，而且对连襟的做法非常恼火，并强迫他降低了将土地卖给隧道管理局的价格，甚至他一开始根本就不想把广场建在那里，他的规划后来已经更改了。在这件事上他完全是清白无辜的，但他从未上报他连襟的利益相关性，因为他担心摩西会查出此事并以此抹黑他。不幸的是，有朝一日。我不知道他会怎么做。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。
And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president.
他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。
And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's going to run for president. And he's was caught in his graft, that he's corrupt, you can't trust him, he's just lying.
他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他要去竞选总统。他被抓到了贪腐的证据，他腐败了，你不能信任他，他满口谎言。
And LaGuardia is like, I'm going to run for president someday. I don't want to have any whiff of scandal involved. LaGuardia, of course, will never run for president. He won't live to run for president. So in 1945, Moses again says, give me control of the tunnel authority. And LaGuardia, after years and years of saying, no, you can't have control of this thing, he gives in and he gives it to him. When's he going to be able to do it?
而拉瓜迪亚的想法是：我总有一天要竞选总统。我可不想沾上任何丑闻的嫌疑。当然，拉瓜迪亚永远不会去竞选总统。他活不到去竞选总统的时候。因此，在1945年，摩西再次提出：把隧道管理局的控制权交给我。而拉瓜迪亚在经历了年复一年、断然拒绝“你不能控制这个机构”之后，最终妥协并将权力交给了他。他究竟是什么时候得以实现这一点的呢？
There's three members in the tunnel authority because each, even though it's called an authority and it's a big organization, there's essentially always like a committee that runs it, you know, and there's three people on that committee. In 1943, one of the members dies and the other two members are like, well, we're not doing any work on the tunnel. I guess there's no rush to recommend a replacement to LaGuardia and And whenever it's time, we'll tell him and he'll hire that one. So we're not going to bother telling him who we think should fill the seat. And Moses is like, take my guy, put him in there to LaGuardia. He says, put my guy in there.
隧道管理局里有三名成员，因为尽管它被称为管理局而且是个庞大的组织，但本质上总是有一个委员会来管理它，你知道的，那个委员会有三个人。1943年，其中一名成员去世了，另外两名成员心想：反正我们也没在隧道上做什么工作，我想也没必要急着向拉瓜迪亚推荐替代人选，等什么时候需要了再告诉他，他就会雇那个人。所以我们才懒得费心告诉他我们认为谁应该填补这个空缺呢。而摩西则向拉瓜迪亚提议：用我的人，把他安插进去。他说：把我的人安插进去。
And LaGuardia says, no. But this means in 1945, another authority member, his seat expires. There's now two vacancies to fill. And the authority member who was in that seat, he's like, well, I'm sure I'll be reappointed just as I was before. There's no reason to think LaGuardia wouldn't reappoint me. I'll just open this letter from LaGuardia that I'm sure is saying that he's reappointing me. What? Thanking me for my service? Appointing somebody else? And LaGuardia announces he's merging the tunnel and tribal authorities. He appoints Moses and one of Moses' men as commission members.
拉瓜迪亚拒绝了。但这意味著到了1945年，另一位管理局成员的任期到期了。现在有了两个空缺需要填补。而原本坐在那个席位上的管理局成员心想：好吧，我确信自己会像以前一样被重新任命。没有任何理由认为拉瓜迪亚不会重新任命我。我只要拆开这封拉瓜迪亚的信就行了，我确信信里说的是他要重新任命我。什么？感谢我的服务？任命了别人？接着拉瓜迪亚宣布他将合并隧道管理局和三区大桥管理局。他任命摩西和摩西的手下之一为委员会成员。
And Moses essentially bullies the final authority board member into resigning and has him replaced by another member of the Triborough board. And so now Moses has total control of the tunnel authority. He cleans house, he fires all the previous leaders, he fires Singstad and his engineers. And now, like we said, he is the successful supervillain who has control as, as Kairos says, of every modern water crossing within the city's borders. Not only those above the water, but those beneath it. Not only every bridge, but every tunnel constructed within the city's borders for the use of motor
而摩西基本上是霸凌逼迫最后一位管理局董事会成员辞职，并让三区大桥董事会的另一名成员取而代之。于是现在摩西完全掌控了隧道管理局。他进行大清洗，开除了所有先前的领导层，开除了辛斯塔德和他的工程师们。正如我们所说，现在他成了那个成功的超级恶棍，正如卡罗所说的那样，他控制了市内所有现代化的水上通道。不仅是水面上的，还有水面下的。自1909年以来，市内为机动车修建的每一座桥梁、每一条隧道，现在都置于他所控制的管理局的管辖之下。更重要的是，所有新的水上交通要道也将置于他的控制之下。只有他、只有他一个人能够决定修建哪些过江通道以及何时修建，它们的形状和设计会是怎样，引道将通往何处。此外，只有他、只有他一个人能够决定这些通道收取多少过路费。
vehicles since 1909 was now under the control of authorities that he controlled. More important, all new water crossings would also be under his control. He and he alone would be able to decide which crossings will be built and when, what their shape and design would be, and where their approach roads would run. He and he alone, moreover, would decide what tolls would be charged on these crossings.
所以他拥有了——他拥有了垄断权。他成功了。他消除了竞争对手。他垄断了进出曼哈顿的交通。就像他垄断了——他成功了。他消除了竞争对手。他垄断了进出曼哈顿的交通。就像他垄断了跨越哈德逊河、东河以及布朗克斯河的通道一样。这太惊人了。因此卡罗写道：
So he's got, he's just, he has a monopoly. He did it. He's eliminated his competitors. He has a monopoly on going into or out of Manhattan. Like he has a monopoly. He did it. He's eliminated his competitors. He has a monopoly on going into or out of Manhattan. Like he has a monopoly on crossing the Hudson and East rivers and the Bronx river. Like it's amazing. And so Carras says,
此后在他掌权的剩余四分之一个世纪里，没有一个司机能够在不向他的管理局缴纳“朝贡”费用的情况下，使用纽约市的任何现代桥梁或隧道。这对他的政治生涯来说是一笔惊人的意外之财和巨大的政变，正如我们之前讨论的那样，只要他有源源不断的收入，他就能发行债券，
henceforth for the remaining quarter of a century in which he would be in power, no motorist would be able to use a modern bridge or tunnel in New York city without paying his authority, his tribute. And this is an amazing windfall and coup for him, as we talked about earlier, as long as he's bringing in revenue, he can float bonds
并且能从中筹集更多资金来建造更多的东西。现在他所拥有的隧道收入将证明，他公开夺取隧道管理局控制权的斗争虽然失败了，但卡罗指出，暗地里争夺这一控制权的斗争却成功了。关键在于，其中涉及的赌注是巨大的。
and he can make more money to build more things off of that. And now he has what the tunnel revenue is gonna be, says that his public battle to take over the tunnel authority had failed, but Kara notes that the private battle to do so had succeeded. And it's just that the stakes battle to do so had succeeded. And it's just that the stakes involved are enormous.
涉及的资金数额极其巨大。它们每年将带来数亿美元的收入。不仅如此，摩西现在拥有了如此庞大的权力。他控制着美国最大城市的交通。这一切基本上都集中在一个人手中，而这一切的决定过程都是背离这座城市的公众视线的。卡罗写道，当时根本没有任何报纸报道摩西试图接管隧道局的新闻。
The amounts of money are enormous. They're going to bring in hundreds of millions of dollars per year. And beyond even that, Moses now has such vast power. He controls transportation in the biggest city in the United States. It's essentially invested in one man, and this is all being decided away from the public eyes of the city. Carr says there were no newspaper stories about Moses trying to take over the tunnel 30
涉及的资金数额巨大。它们每年将带来数亿美元的收入。不仅如此，摩西现在拥有如此巨大的权力。他控制着美国最大城市的交通。这一切基本上都集中在一个人身上，而这些决定都是在公众的视线之外做出的。卡尔说，当时没有任何报纸报道摩西试图接管30号隧道的事。
in all of 1942, 1943, 1944. Now again, these are big years. World War II is going on. How many Einstein stories are there? Exactly, yeah, that's true. But I mean, these are, but the newspapers got to fill all, there's a city edition, you know,
在整个 1942、1943 和 1944 年。当然了，这些都是特殊的年份。第二次世界大战正在进行。到底有多少关于爱因斯坦的故事？确实如此，没错，这倒不假。但我的意思是，这些都是……不过报纸总得填满版面，你知道的，有城市版面，
maybe they could do one story on it. But he is, Moses, he now has this total control. And part of his doing this is he immediately has to denigrate all Sincstead's engineering abilities. This is a guy who is not an engineer, is denigrating the world's greatest builder of underwater tunnels. And he goes on to use the Sincstead's plans exactly as they're drawn, aside from one change in waterproofing the tunnel that they end up having to go back to the original plan on and change because the new version doesn't work as well. But even while he's using Sinkstad's plans, he talks about how bad he is engineering and he goes out of his way to remove all public credit for him. He's not invited to the opening of the
也许他们可以做一篇相关的报道。但他——摩西，现在拥有了完全的控制权。他这么做的一部分原因，就是他必须立即贬低辛克斯塔德的所有工程能力。这家伙根本不是工程师，却在贬低全世界最伟大的水底隧道建设者。他继续完全按照辛克斯塔德的图纸来使用这些计划，除了对隧道的防水处理做了一处修改，而他们最终又不得不回到最初的方案进行修改，因为新版本的效果并不好。但即便在采用辛克斯塔德的图纸时，他也大谈对方的工程水平有多糟，并且不遗余力地抹杀公众对他的所有功劳认可。他甚至没有被邀请参加他自己设计的
tunnel that he designed. The promotional brochures, they list 21 engineers, but they don't list him. And Sinkstad, he would live in New York for the next 24 years. He would never again build anything in New York city or New York state. And Caro describes interviewing Singstead in his office and he's that housing status basically told that Singstead would bid on jobs and would be told you're never going to build a New York state as long as Robert Moses is alive and that he's going to build a New York state in the next 20 years. And he's going to build a New York state in the next 20 years. And he's going to build a New York state in the next 20 years. And he's going to build a New York state in the next 20 years. And he's going how Singstead is basically told that Singstead would bid on jobs and would be told,
隧道的开通仪式。宣传手册上列出了 21 名工程师，却没有他的名字。而辛克斯塔德在纽约度过了接下来的 24 年。他再也没有在纽约市或纽约州建造过任何东西。卡罗描述了他在办公室采访辛克斯塔德的情景，基本上就是告诉读者，辛克斯塔德去竞标工作时，会被人告知：“只要罗伯特·摩西还活着，你就永远别想在纽约州建造任何东西。”而辛克斯塔德基本上就是被这样告知的：
you're never gonna build a New York state as long as Robert Moses is alive. And the scene here, it's really powerful. The way he writes it is really, you just gets a sense of Singstead as this, just this forceful figure caught in a box that in his own, he's made his home city, he's just been cut out and there's nothing he can do about it. And it has nothing to do with anything he's made his home city. He's just been cut out and there's nothing he can do
“只要罗伯特·摩西还活着，你就永远别想在纽约州建造任何东西。”这里的场景真的非常有感染力。卡罗的笔触真切地传达出这样一种感觉：辛克斯塔德就像是一个充满力量的人物，却被困在一个盒子动弹不得——在他自己深爱的这座城市里，他被彻底排挤在外，却对此无能为力。这和他所做过的一切都没有关系，他只是被排挤在外，对此无能为力，
about it and it has nothing to do with anything he's done. Other than that, I guess he refused to roll over and let Moses take over and be an ally for him. And it just, it's of all the, of the many heartbreaking things in this, this is one of the smaller heartbreaking moments because again, he's still hugely successful, but there's still a little bit of heartbreak to it.
而且这和他的所作所为毫无关系。除此之外，我想大概是因为他拒绝俯首帖耳，让摩西独揽大权并成为他的附庸。总之，在书中众多令人心碎的事件里，这只是一个相对较小的心碎时刻，因为毕竟他依然非常成功，但这其中仍然带有一丝令人心碎的遗憾。
Yeah, yeah. And then it turns out in the end that all this is a lie. All the pretext for taking over the Brooklyn Battery Tunnel is a lie. The tunnel was not in financial distress. I mean, it was a little bit from the war, but as soon as the war wasn't happening, the tunnel was profitable. And so much so that in the end,
是的，是的。结果到头来，这一切都是个谎言。接管布鲁克林炮台隧道的全部借口都是个谎言。这条隧道并没有陷入财务困境。我的意思是，受战争影响确实有一点点，但战争刚一结束，隧道就盈利了。盈利多到什么程度呢？以至于到最后，
it contributed 20% of Tribor authorities total revenues at the end. Like there was just, I mean, it was more successful than his bridges, most of them. And so it's just kind of a crazy thing that he got away with. Like he was, he had this ability. I mean, Moses had command of so many facts
它贡献了三区管理局总收入的 20%。那种感觉就是……我的意思是，它比他的大多数桥梁都要成功。所以他能蒙混过关，这简直太疯狂了。他当时有这样一种能力。我是说，摩西对如此之多的事实了如指掌，
at his fingertips and he sort of like opened up the fire hose of facts and his authority on so many facts at his fingertips, and he sort of like opened up the fire hose of facts and his authority on so many subjects that people just didn't question this stuff as much as they should have. In the beginning, maybe he was a little more on the level, but by the end, he was just making completely, you know, just erroneous lies about what was going on
信手拈来，他就像是打开了事实的水龙头，他对这么多领域的权威事实信手拈来，以至于人们没有像本该有的那样去质疑这些东西。一开始，也许他稍微还算实事求是，但到了后来，他完全是在胡说八道，你知道的，只是在虚构关于城市交通状况的
in terms of transportation in the city. It was just, it's just, he just made stuff up. His whole argument was these tunnels are unprofitable. My bridges are necessary to bail them out. And by the sixties, the tunnels are bailing out the bridges. The tunnels are what's keeping Triborough float. And it's just, yeah, it's amazing. And it reminds me of what you're saying
各种错误谎言。这简直……完全是胡编乱造。他的整个论点就是这些隧道不赚钱。我的桥梁对于拯救它们是必不可少的。而到了六十年代，反而是隧道在拯救桥梁。是隧道在维持三区管理局的运转。这真是太令人惊叹了。这让我想起了你刚才所说的，
about this kind of firehose of facts and people can't really check it. They just kind of take it as truth, even when it's made up. I read a book once about life in the 13th century and they were saying that to be kind of like a wise man or an intelligent man or scholar, the emphasis was on how much you know, not how true the things you know are. It was better for you to know a thousand things about which type of frogs you have to insert into your mouth overnight to cure the mumps than it is to know one thing about, you know,
这种铺天盖地的事实攻势，人们根本无法真正去核实。他们只是把这些当成了真理，哪怕它们全是编造的。我曾经读过一本书，讲的是 13 世纪的生活，书中提到，要想成为某种智者、聪明人或学者，重点在于你知道多少东西，而不是你所知道的东西有多大真实性。相比于了解一条关于闪电中的电流是如何运作的知识，你还不如知道一千种关于“为了治愈腮腺炎，你必须把哪种青蛙塞进嘴里过夜”的冷知识，（你知道的，）
how electricity works in lightning or something like that. You know, it's, it's, it's better to know everything about dragons than to know one thing about, you know, measles. And it's kind of the way Moses works. He will bamboozle you with so many pieces of information that you don't have the expertise or the time to check. And my old AP psychology professor, Mr. Bester Covey, he used to say, if you can't dazzle them with brilliance,
了解关于龙的一切，总比了解关于麻疹的一点知识要好。这有点像摩西的工作方式。他会用海量的信息把你搞得晕头转向，让你没有专业知识或时间去核实。我以前的 AP 心理学教授贝斯特·科维先生过去常说：“如果你不能用才华震撼他们，
baffle them with bullshit. That was his advice on how to write papers for his class and for college classes. And that's what Moses is doing. He will baffle you until you don't know which way is what and you have to give in because he's so confident and you're so swimming in, in argument that you don't have a choice.
就用废话把他们搞糊涂。”这就是他对如何为他的课堂以及大学课程写论文的建议。这也是摩西正在做的事情。他会把你绕晕，直到你分不清东南西北，只能选择妥协，因为他是如此自信，而你又深陷于争论的海洋中，别无选择。
Totally, totally. Um, well, it's amazing that he just, at this point, he just has a lock on nearly everything. And so this leads us to the, the, the next chapter is chapter 32, quid pro quo. Uh, it's the shortest chapter in the book. It's, it's quite short, it's only three pages long. It's three pages.
完全是这样，完全是这样。嗯，最神奇的是，到了这个时候，他几乎对所有事情都拥有绝对的掌控权。这就引领我们来到了下一章——第 32 章“权钱交易”。这是书中极短的一章，相当短，只有三页纸长。总共就三页。
Considering we had a 75 page chapter last episode, I'm like, three pages? Robert, Carol, are you feeling okay? Are you feeling healthy? And it's all concerned about Mayor LaGuardia, who has another sort of ignominious end in his life, like we've seen a number of times. It's very reminiscent of the end of Al Smith.
考虑到上一集我们有一章长达 75 页，我当时就想：才三页？罗伯特·卡罗，你感觉还好吗？你身体健康吗？这一章主要关注的是市长拉瓜迪亚，他的人生以另一种略显不光彩的结局收场，正如我们之前已经见过好几次的那样。这非常让人想起阿尔·史密斯的结局。
Yeah, and it makes you wonder, does anyone leave New York politics successful or satisfied or happy or healthy? Probably not, I don't know. They all seem kind of angry when they leave, but it's 1945, we're kind of in between where those other chapters were. Mayor LaGuardia is dying. He has cancer that run for national office. That's not going to happen. He's in frequent pain, leaves him drained and tired. His popularity has cratered. His political
是的，这不禁让人琢磨：难道没有人能带着成功、满足、快乐或健康的身体退出纽约政坛吗？大概没有吧，我不知道。他们离开时似乎都有点愤怒。不过那是 1945 年，我们的进度正处于前面那些章节之间的空当。市长拉瓜迪亚正在走向生命尽头。他患有癌症，曾竞选过国家公职但未能成功。这注定不会实现。他经常感到疼痛，这让他精疲力竭。他的受欢迎程度已经跌入谷底，他的政治
sport has cratered. He has been privately refused the fusion and GOP nominations to run for mayor again. So he announces he will not run for reelection. And LaGuardia backs this new fusion candidate against the Tammany Democratic candidate, William O'Dwyer. And Moses, he has spent years attacking the Tammany machine. He has been the fusion champion all this time. The campaign comes and he pretty much stays out of it. He doesn't really want to get involved
支持率也已跌入谷底。他私下里被拒绝了再次竞选市长的融合派和共和党提名。于是他宣布不再竞选连任。拉瓜迪亚支持这位新的融合派候选人，来对抗坦慕尼民主党候选人威廉·奥德怀尔。而摩西多年来一直在攻击坦慕尼机器。他一直都是融合派的斗士。竞选来临之际，他却几乎置身事外。他其实并不想卷入其中，
and he doesn't say a word against O'Dwyer. And the reason is because four days before a word against O'Dwyer. And the reason is because four days before the election, O'Dwyer goes on the radio and he says, if he's elected, he'll appoint Moses to a new post, coordinator of construction with power over public housing. Finally, he'll get public housing and all the major public works in the city.
也没有对奥德怀尔说一句反话。原因就在于，在选举前四天，奥德怀尔在电台上发表了讲话，他说如果自己当选，将任命摩西担任一个新职位——建设协调员，并赋予其对公共住房的管理权。最终，他将掌控公共住房以及市内所有的重大公共工程。
And O'Dwyer wins in a land side. Partly thanks to the way having Moses on his team makes him seem less like a Tammany hack. The press, they still don't get it. So they're like, how will the noble, incorruptible Moses, how will he possibly function in this administration that's bound to be full of back-scratching Tammany grafters? And the Herald Tribune says, how long?
奥德怀尔以压倒性优势获胜。部分归功于将摩西拉入阵营，这让奥德怀尔看起来不那么像一个坦慕尼的政客傀儡。媒体依然没有搞懂状况。所以他们在想：高尚、清廉的摩西，怎么可能在一个注定充满了互相勾结的坦慕尼贪腐分子的政府里运作呢？《先驱论坛报》发问：还要多久？
How long would Mr. Moses last under an administration that was dominated by the more selfish and corrupt elements of Tammany Hall? At a good guess, we would give him about six weeks. And Caro continues, the guess off by approximately 15 years was about as good as the assumption that underlay it. An assumption revealing only the depth
摩西先生在由坦慕尼协会中那些更加自私和腐败的分子所把持的政府统治下，究竟能坚持多久？大胆猜一下，我们觉得他大概能撑六周。卡罗接着写道：这个与实际相差大约 15 年的猜测，和支撑这一猜测的假设一样离谱。这个假设仅仅暴露出人们对摩西真实性格的
of the misapprehension about Moses' true character. For the Robert Moses about whom the Herald Tribune was editorializing hadn't existed for a long time. The Robert Moses of 1945 was not the foe of the practical politician, but the essence of that peculiar animal. He was the complete realist, willing in order to accomplish his purposes, purposes which in 1945 revolved around the retention and acquisition of power, to throw onto the table any chip he held.
误解有多深。《先驱论坛报》社论中谈论的那个罗伯特·摩西，其实早已不复存在了。1945 年的罗伯特·摩西不再是务实政客的死敌，而是这种特殊政治动物的精髓所在。他是一个彻底的现实主义者，为了达成自己的目的——在 1945 年，这些目的主要围绕着权力的保留与获取——他愿意将手中拥有的任何筹码全部押在桌面上。
He had, in the election of 1945, with a chance to obtain more power than he had ever possessed before thrown onto the table the most valuable of all his chips, his name. He is at this. It's he's gone as far as he can go at this point. He's like, yeah, Tammany use me. You're going to give me power over all major construction in the city. Yeah, definitely. I'll do it.
在 1945 年的选举中，当有机会获得比以往任何时候都多的权力时，他将自己手中所有筹码中最有价值的一个——他的名字——扔上了赌桌。他正在经历这一切。他此时已经走到了他所能到达的极致。他想的是：对，坦慕尼，利用我吧。你们要给我对全市所有重大建设项目的控制权？没问题，绝对可以，我干！
That's all I care about. And I just love that. They're like, we give it six weeks. And I have to imagine at the seventh week, they were like, any day now. And then 15 years later, they're like, we're pretty sure this isn't going to last too much. Like they were still holding on to it. And by the end of the chapter, we're reaching this. Moses sees LaGuardia for the last time in 1947 when the ex-mirror is on his deathbed. And Moses is kind of shaken by it. And Carrow ends the chapter with
这正是我唯一关心的。我真是太喜欢这个桥段了。他们当时说：“我们赌他撑六周。”我简直可以想象，到了第七周，他们还在说：“就快倒台了吧，随时都会垮。”然后 15 年过去了，他们还在说：“我们很确定这不会持续太久了……”他们居然还在死撑着不放。到了本章末尾，我们迎来了这一幕：摩西在 1947 年最后一次见到拉瓜迪亚，当时这位前市长已经病入膏肓。摩西为此感到有些震动。卡罗在这一章的结尾讲述了
the story of a moment in 1946 before LaGuardia dies when this engineer and reformer Walter Binger, he sees LaGuardia eating lunch somewhere by himself looking gloomy and he comes over to talk to him and LaGuardia is like, he's got too much power now. Moses has too much power. And Binger says, well, Major, who gave it to him? And Binger recalls LaGuardia answering, sadly, yes, but I could control him. Now no one will be able to control him. And Caro ends the chapter saying the first part of the ex mayor's statement was not completely accurate. The second part was like LaGuardia to his deathbed is still like, I was the
1946 年拉瓜迪亚去世前的一个时刻：工程师兼改革家沃尔特·宾格看到拉瓜迪亚独自一人在一处地方吃午饭，神情沮丧，于是走过去跟他聊天。拉瓜迪亚感慨道：“他现在权力太大了。摩西的权力太大了。”宾格说：“长官，那权力是谁给他的呢？”宾格回忆说，拉瓜迪亚伤感地回答：“是的，但我以前还能控制他。现在没人能控制他了。”卡罗在章节结尾写道：前市长的第一句话并不完全准确，但第二句话千真万确。拉瓜迪亚直到临终前依然觉得：我是唯一能够驾驭摩西的人，但他最终也没能驾驭得了，没人能。
only one who could harness Moses, but he couldn't, nobody can. And thanks to LaGuardia, no one maybe ever will ever again. He may still be running New York City to this day, Roman. We have to read the rest of the book to find out. We do have to find out. And this is really interesting because again, it sort of mirrors the Al Smith chapter. But at this point,
多亏了拉瓜迪亚，或许以后再也没有人能驾驭他了。罗曼，直到今天，他可能依然在统治着纽约市。我们必须读完这本书的剩余部分才能找到答案。我们确实得一探究竟。这真的很有趣，因为这再次呼应了阿尔·史密斯那一章。但在此时，
because Moses is such a different character or sort of has such a different relationship with LaGuardia than he did with Al Smith, you know, LaGuardia is aware of what he's created here. I mean, it's a little bit like, you know, just like, there was a, oh, just a real, I don't know, a callow, weak-willed kind of like quality to him, where you're just like, oh, come on, like,
由于摩西是一个截然不同的人物，或者说他对拉瓜迪亚的态度与他对阿尔·史密斯时有着如此不同的关系，（你知道的，）拉瓜迪亚其实很清楚自己在这里创造出了什么怪物。我的意思是，这有点像……你知道的，就好像有一种……真是一种软弱无能、毫无意志力的特质在里面，让你忍不住想说：“拜托，
this whole thing, like, you knew what was going on here. Well, there's an overconfidence in LaGuardia. It's almost like he saw himself having a similar relationship to Moses that Al Smith had, not realizing one, Moses is smarter than him. And two, Al Smith made Moses, like Al Smith raised and taught Moses and made him like, the relationship between Moses and Al Smith was almost father and son.
这一切……你明明知道这里面是怎么回事。”嗯，拉瓜迪亚身上有一种盲目的自信。这简直就像他觉得自己和摩西的关系类似于阿尔·史密斯和摩西的关系一样，却没有意识到第一，摩西比他更聪明；第二，阿尔·史密斯造就了摩西，阿尔·史密斯抚养、教导了摩西，并造就了他——摩西和阿尔·史密斯之间的关系几乎情同父子。
And the Guardia is like, I'll run him the way Al Smith ran him. And it's like, no, no, no, you are at best an equal colleague and at worst, someone that Moses sees as a temporary lever of power and someone to get more power. And I think it's, maybe it's the egotism of, of anyone who runs for executive office, you know, that they assume they're the top guy who can control everything or else they wouldn't go for it. But I feel with Al Smith, there's that last scene with him and Moses and Al Smith is basically like, learn from my example, I'm warning you that eventually the public will turn on you. And Moses like, nah. And with LaGuardia, it's more being like,
而拉瓜迪亚却觉得：我能像阿尔·史密斯驾驭他那样驾驭他。结果却是：不，不，不，你最多只能算是一个平起平坐的同僚，最坏的情况则是，在摩西眼里，你只是一个用来获取更多权力的临时权柄杠杆。我想，这或许是所有竞选行政职位的人身上都有的一种自负吧，你知道的，他们总觉得自己是能够掌控一切的最高长官，否则他们根本不会去竞选。但我总觉得在阿尔·史密斯身上，有他和摩西的最后一幕，阿尔·史密斯基本上是告诫他：吸取我的教训吧，我警告你，公众最终会抛弃你的。而摩西的反应是：才不会呢。但在拉瓜迪亚这里，更多的是一种……
not quite, but almost bringing himself, he's realizing the mistake he made, but he can't bring himself to realize how he was the one who was not in the power position in this dynamic, in this relationship. Yeah, no, he has this thing of like, of thinking that, oh, now all of a sudden, Moses is gonna be so much worse. And he was bad this whole time.
虽然不完全是，但已经非常接近了：他开始意识到自己犯下的错误，却又无法真正面对自己在这种权力动态、这种关系中其实并非处于掌控地位的事实。是的，没错，他有这样一种心态，觉得：“哦，现在突然之间，摩西要变得更坏了。”其实他一直以来都很坏。
He just feels like it's worse because he's now on the O'Dwyer team and he has control over so many more things. But, you know, had he gone control over so many more things. Um, but you know, had he gone after that stuff with LaGuardia, um, he probably would have gotten it then too. Yeah. The idea that LaGuardia was the one holding him back, you know, who the only, the only, you know, guardrail of Liberty of democracy that was holding him is, is kind of silly. But also we should always remember this book is written for a real
他只是觉得现在情况更糟了，因为摩西现在加入了奥德怀尔的阵营，并且掌控了更多的事情。但是，你知道的，如果当初他对拉瓜迪亚采取那些手段……嗯，他可能在那个时候就已经得逞了。是的。那种认为拉瓜迪亚才是阻拦他的那个人——也就是唯一守护着自由与民主的护栏——的观点，其实是有点荒谬的。不过，我们也应该时刻记住，这本书是以一种
Moses centric position. And when Garty has got other things going on in running New York and just dealing with Robert Moses, the same way that the book makes it seem like Franklin Roosevelt is just sitting in the white house, kind of stewing over Robert Moses for years when he is dealing with the depression of World War II. And I think maybe it's easier for me to come to this if only because I read, uh, the Al Smith biography that I mentioned in an earlier episode was sitting on my to be red shelf. And it was not the book that the power broker is,
极度以摩西为中心视角来写的。当拉瓜迪亚还要忙着治理纽约、应付罗伯特·摩西时，这本书却把富兰克林·罗斯福写得好像整天坐在白宫里，为罗伯特·摩西的事纠结好几年一样，而实际上当时他正焦头烂额地应对大萧条和第二次世界大战。我想，我之所以能更容易地接受这一点，或许仅仅是因为我读了我在之前一集里提到过的那本放在我的“待读书架”上的阿尔·史密斯传记。那并不是《权力掮客》这本书，
but there was something kind of refreshing of seeing the story of Al Smith and Robert Moses mentioned in it, but it is not the story of Al Smith mentor of Robert Moses. It's the story of Al Smith man and governor. And Robert Moses is a player in that and remembering that to all these people, they are not supporting players in the story of Robert Moses, the way they are in this book. They're all people with their own lives. And so I can kind of forgive LaGuardia a little bit because it's not like
但在其中看到关于阿尔·史密斯和罗伯特·摩西的提及，还是有一种耳目一新的感觉。然而那并不是一本关于“阿尔·史密斯作为罗伯特·摩西导师”的书，那是一本关于“阿尔·史密斯作为普通人和州长”的书。罗伯特·摩西只是其中的一个参与者。我们必须记住，对所有人而言，他们并不是罗伯特·摩西故事里的配角，不像在这本书里被写的那样。他们都是有着自己独立生活的人。因此，我可以对拉瓜迪亚多一点宽容，因为拉瓜迪亚并不是
LaGuardia was even spending all day every day being like, Moses, Ooh, how do it either the way that like in the, in the Tim Burton Batman movie, Joker is just sitting around watching Batman on TV going like, Ooh, Batman, what do I do next? You know, like this, the, uh, I've been talking about Batman so much in this episode compared to the other episodes. Uh, but maybe, but maybe that's the same thing. He thought with all this stuff that he's got to take care of as mayor, he can still keep Moses in control. And perhaps it,
整天、每分每秒都在念叨着：“摩西，哦！该怎么对付他呢？”就像在蒂姆·伯顿的《蝙蝠侠》电影里，小丑只是无所事事地坐在电视机前看着蝙蝠侠，然后说：“哦，蝙蝠侠，我接下来该做什么呢？”你知道的，我在这一集里聊到蝙蝠侠的次数比其他任何一集都多。不过，也许……也许情况是一样的。他以为凭借自己作为市长需要处理的所有杂务，他依然能把摩西控制在掌心。或许，
it just helps Moses that he's off and up against people who are either not as powerful as him or potentially powerful, but also their attention is split. Yeah, and when you're busy and you have power, there's nothing you love more than having people who work for you or with you, who can handle things without you dealing with them on a day-to-day basis. And there's a real logic to like the Triborough Authority
这只是对摩西有利，因为他的对手要么没有他那么强大，要么虽然潜在实力雄厚，但注意力也被分散了。是的，当你公务繁忙且手握大权时，你最喜欢的事情莫过于手下有一群能干的人，能够在你无需事事过问的日常中把事情处理妥当。将三区管理局
taking over the tunnel crossing. And like, you just like, okay, I don't have to deal with this, these vacancies on this commission, I can do this, I can put it all together, I know he knows how to run things. There's a real logic to that. Obviously he had some warning bells going off that, you know, kept it from happening for those years. But eventually you can totally see why it's just like, okay,
接管隧道跨江交通这一举措，其实有着很强的逻辑合理性。你会觉得：好吧，我不用去管这个了，不用去管委员会里这些空缺的职位了，我可以搞定这个，我可以把一切统筹起来，我知道他懂得如何运作。这背后确实有着合理的逻辑。显然，他当时也听到了一些警报铃声，正是这些警报在过去的那些年里阻止了这一切的发生。但最终，你完全可以理解为什么他会想：好吧，
just run it, just don't bother me again. You know, like, you know, like, and you just want to, you want one thing to be easy, because I'm sure everything else is, is so hard. What I do wonder about this is that, so Robert Caro was intending to write a biography of LaGuardia after he finished The Power Broker. It was kind of the next idea that he had. And he started working on it. And then he ended up abandoning that to commit to the LBJ project and commit he did. Literally committed the rest of his working life to it. But I do wonder if Caro wrote the LaGuardia biography, how much Moses would be in it?
让他去运营好了，别再来烦我了。你知道的，就好像……你只想让某一件事情变得简单，因为我确信其他所有事情都已经够难了。我对此一直有个疑问：罗伯特·卡罗原本是打算在写完《The Power Broker》之后接着写一本关于拉瓜迪亚的传记。那是他脑海中的下一个构想。他甚至已经开始着手写了。但后来他最终放弃了这个计划，转而全身心投入到林登·贝恩斯·约翰逊（LBJ）的项目中，并且说到做到。字面意义上将他余下的职业生涯全部倾注在了那个项目上。不过我一直在想，如果卡罗真的写了拉瓜迪亚的传记，摩西在书中会占据多大的篇幅？
Would he feel like he was still the center because that's where Robert Caro's mind is at? Or would he really be so off to the side because once you dug into LaGuardia as the main character, Moses maybe wasn't that important or not. I don't know. I would love to kind of get an idea of that to see if, you know, Moses loomed so large
他会觉得摩西依然是核心吗？因为那是罗伯特·摩西卡罗当时思考问题的出发点；还是说摩西会被大大边缘化？因为一旦你把拉瓜迪亚当作主角深入挖掘，摩西或许并没有那么重要，或者说没那么大分量。我不知道。我很想对这一点有个概念，看看如果从那里切入，
in the LaGuardia biography if you were to start from there. It's a good question. It's a good what if, like in this alternate world where Caro did write the LaGuardia biography, how would it look? And also what would it mean for the power broker in terms of the power broker being the statement on New York political power during this period of history,
摩西在拉瓜迪亚传记中的身影是否依然显得如此庞大。这是一个很好的问题。这是一个绝妙的“如果”假设：在那个卡罗真的写了拉瓜迪亚传记的平行世界里，那本书会是什么样子？而且，这对《权力掮客》又意味着什么呢？作为对这段历史时期纽约政治权力的一份终极宣言，如果存在另一本由同一位作者从不同角度审视同一主题的书，他是否会重新评估他原本的想法？这就好像存在另一个世界，在那里他的拉瓜迪亚传记成了同一作者对前作的有力反驳，或者是一次绝佳的补充。不过我认为，
if there was this other book that was looking at it by the same author from a different angle and whether he would have been reevaluating things that he thought, like it's almost like there's another world where his LaGuardia biography becomes a rebuttal by the same author of the previous one or becomes a supporting one. But I think the, for that reason, I think that's probably one of the reasons that it was probably better for him to take on Alinda Johnson books. I think that was the thinking was he started working on LaGuardia and then he and Robert
出于这个原因，这可能也是为什么他选择接手林登·约翰逊传记是一个更好的决定。我想当时的想法是，他开始写拉瓜迪亚传记，然后他和罗伯特·戈特利布（Robert Gottlieb）交流后觉得：纽约的题材太多了，我已经写过纽约了……当时的想法是，他开始写拉瓜迪亚传记，然后他和罗伯特·
Gottlieb were like, too much New York. I did New was the thinking was he started working on LaGuardia and then he and Robert Gottlieb were like too much New York, I did New York already. It's time to do something different. Yeah, I think he felt like he knew it, he'd already really said it. But I do wonder what the result would be like because of that. I mean, Robert Caro has told us that he doesn't think
戈特利布一商量，觉得：纽约的题材太多了，我已经在纽约深耕过了。是时候做点不一样的了。是的，我想他觉得自己已经完全摸透了这个领域，并且已经把该说的话都说尽了。但我确实很好奇，如果因为这个原因写出来，结果会是怎样。我的意思是，罗伯特·卡罗曾对我们说过，他认为
that Robert Moses would be remembered today if it wasn't for the power broker. And I wonder in the examination of another history of the same time period, if that would kind of also be the case, like that there would be a kind of under the radar quality of Robert Moses, even during the, you know, writing about the contemporaneous period,
如果没有《权力掮客》，罗伯特·摩西今天可能根本不会被人记住。我很好奇，在对同一历史时期的另一番审视中，是否也会出现这种情况：即使是在撰写那个同期历史时，罗伯特·摩西身上也会有一种“隐于雷达之下”的特质——
if Robert Moses was able to kind of like, kind of stick his head above to get notice when he needed stuff and then sort of stay under and be a functionary when he didn't. And I just wonder how that would play out if you were doing it from the LaGuardia perspective. I mean, in a way I'm very surprised by this scene with Walter Banger, like that LaGuardia is thinking
如果罗伯特·摩西能够在需要办成事情时探出头来引起注意，而在不需要时则潜入幕后扮演一个普通的职能官员。我只是很好奇，如果从拉瓜迪亚的视角来做这件事，最终会如何演变。从某种程度上讲，我对沃尔特·宾格这个场景感到非常惊讶，拉瓜迪亚竟然能在某种程度上
about Moses at all in a way. But maybe he thought about Moses all the time. Like I would just be curious to know how much he really thought about Moses when you took the totality of all of his tasks and the things he had to take care of in the city. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know. I mean, there's something, it sounds like an amazing project for another biographer to tell the story of a time through biographies of each,
还会想起摩西。但也许他一直都在想着摩西。我只是很好奇，当把他在市内所有的职责和需要处理的事情全部加起来时，他到底在多大程度上真正把摩西放在心上。是的，是的。我不知道。我的意思是，这听起来像是为另一位传记作家量身打造的一个绝妙项目：通过每个人互相交织的传记，来讲述那个时代的故事，这样你就能看清当时到底发生了什么。
like interlocking biographies of each of the people so that you can see what was going on. Because you're right that part of Moses's benefit to LaGuardia and the other mayors and governors he served under was you hand him a project and he does it. And the book as it's written, it leads you to believe that there was just this nonstop series of scandals. You know, everyone's always fighting Moses all the time and He's always stepping on toes. But the benefit was he gets things done and often gets things done in a way that doesn't splatter back on the mayor or the governor. And so probably a lot of his time was spent just working under the radar, working furiously, you know, with his own staff, but not, um, not in a way where every day LaGuardia
因为你说得对，摩西对拉瓜迪亚以及他曾效力过的主管官员们的价值之一，就在于你把一个项目交给他，他就能把它办成。而按书中所写的那样，它会让你误以为当时有一连串永无止境的丑闻。你知道的，每个人似乎都在随时随地跟摩西作对，他总是踩到别人的痛脚。但好处在于他能把事情办成，而且通常办成的方式不会把烂摊子溅到市长或州长身上。所以他的很多时间可能都花在默默无闻地工作上，疯狂地与自己的团队合作，而不是以那种让拉瓜迪亚
walks in and is like, okay, what did Moses do this time? You know, give me the Moses report. Well, Mayor, oh boy, this guy, you know, why else would LaGuardia put him in charge of the federal money at the beginning of the depression if he doesn't think of this guy as scandal prone and is then surprised to find out that he picked the one guy that the president of the United States hates the most in the world. But he still holds onto him even through that,
每天走进办公室就质问“摩西这次又搞出了什么名堂？快给我拿摩西的报告来”的方式。好吧，市长，哦天哪，这家伙……你知道的。否则的话，如果拉瓜迪亚不认为这家伙是个天生招惹丑闻的体质，为什么还要在大萧条初期把联邦资金交由他掌管呢？而当他发现自己选中的竟然是美国总统在全世界最讨厌的家伙时，他居然还感到惊讶。但他即便在知道了这一点之后，
like learning that. And I think the other thing that is great about this section and really sort of begins to solidify a pattern that you see is this, the changing administrations and how, you know, normally, when a new mayor comes in, a new governor comes in, a new president comes in, everybody remotely connected to the last administration is out the door.
依然对他委以重任。我认为这一节另一个精彩之处，并且真正开始巩固一个清晰规律的，就是政府的更迭。你知道的，通常情况下，当新市长上台、新州长上台、新总统上台时，所有跟上一届政府沾亲带故的人都会被扫地出门。
There is no part of them that lingers. Moses manages to get more powerful with each of these new elected officials. It's really, I don't know if I've ever heard of anything else like that. The only parallel I can think of is J. Edgar Hoover with the FBI, where he stays as head of the FBI for 40 years. And each new president coming in is like, we've
没有一个人能赖着不走。而摩西却总能在每一位新当选官员手下变得更加强大。真的，我不知道自己是否还听说过其他类似的事情。我能想到的唯一平行对比就是联邦调查局（FBI）的J·埃德加·霍弗（J. Edgar Hoover），他在 FBI 局长的位置上稳坐了 40 年。每一位新上任的总统都信誓旦旦地说：“我们必须对霍弗采取点行动了，”但他们却无可奈何，因为他要么
got to do something about Hoover and they can't because he's, he has, he has either dirt on them or he's just the only guy who they think he's the only guy who can run it. Or he's just so similar to Moses, like so beloved in the national consciousness, not as like a guy you want to, you don't want to hang out with J.F. Hoover, but like he's America's policeman, you know? And there's a, but yeah, otherwise it's hard for me to think of somebody who exactly in that position where they can not just avoid getting thrown out with the other political appointees, but like can amass
掌握着他们的黑料，要么他就是大家心目中唯一一个能胜任这份工作的人。或者他跟摩西太像了，在国民意识中深受欢迎——倒不是说你想跟 J·E·霍弗出去闲逛，而是觉得他是“美国的警察”，你知道的。除了他之外，很难让我再想起另一个人，能够恰好处于那种不仅能避免跟其他政治任命官员一起被扫地出门、甚至还能聚敛
more power. You know, he's, he's set up the law so it's hard to get rid of him. But it's not like he put in a law that said every new mayor has to give me more stuff to do, you know, has to give me more control of things. No, no, no. He just, he's able to take it. Manages to get it. It's amazing. I think that this is so funny because I've just been circling the new, um, Hoover biography, G-Man.
更多权力的位置上。你知道的，他把法律设计得很难把他赶下台。但并不是说他立了一条法律，规定“每一位新市长都必须给我更多事情做，必须给我更多事情的控制权”，不，不，不。他只是有能力把权力抓在手里。他总能办到。这太神奇了。我觉得这非常搞笑，因为我最近一直在关注一本关于
I literally was looking at it on Amazon today. Like, like that I kind of want to check it out. And so maybe this is a, that would be also an interesting parallel with the power broker. Yeah, what he does for law enforcement is very similar to what Moses does for municipal transportation,
霍弗的新传记《G-Man》。我今天在亚马逊上看到它了。就好像……我挺想拜读一下的。所以也许这也会成为与《权力掮客》一个有趣的平行对比。是的，他为执法部门做的事，非常类似于摩西为城市交通做的事，
where it's like, I'm going to modernize this. It's going to be impressive looking. I'm going to crush a lot of people. I'm not going to treat people well, but my image is so strong that you're going gonna keep me doing it You know because the idea of getting rid of me is is impossible politically there. Yeah, he's like he's like the Gentile Robert Moses jayker Hoover
那种感觉就像是：我要把这套系统现代化。它看起来要气派。我要粉碎许多人。我不会对他们客气，但我的公众形象如此强大，以至于你不得不让我继续干下去，因为从政治上讲，想要摆脱我简直是不可能的。是的，他就像……他就像是犹太版的罗伯特·摩西——J·埃德加·霍弗。
Not the gentle but the gentle Coming up our interview with Transportation Secretary Pete Buttigieg. And now our interview with Pete Buttigieg, Secretary of Transportation in the Biden administration. We wanted to talk with Secretary Pete about his philosophy on large-scale infrastructure projects in current times and also learn more about his experience at the local level when he was mayor of South Bend, Indiana. One thing I've always remembered about his time as mayor was when he led the city's overhaul of its wastewater system, something that feels like the opposite of a Moses project, an infrastructure improvement that is totally necessary and totally unseen.
不是犹太版，是绅士版……接下来，我们将播出对交通部长皮特·布蒂吉格（Pete Buttigieg）的采访。现在，让我们收听对拜登政府交通部长皮特·布蒂吉格的采访。我们想和皮特部长聊聊他当前对大规模基础设施项目的理念，同时也想深入了解他在担任印第安纳州南本德市长期间在地方层面的经验。关于他担任市长期间，我一直记得的一件事是，他领导了该市废水处理系统的全面改造，这感觉就像是一个反向的“摩西项目”——一项绝对必要却又完全隐形的基础设施改善工程。
We recorded this interview back in early June. So thanks so much for doing this, I really appreciate it. Yeah, nice to see you both. I think, Roman, you may know this, but you were responsible for one of my favorite episodes as mayor, which is getting a new South Bend flag designed. Because I saw your talk, evaluate our flag and found that it literally hit every single qualification you identified of a bad flag. It didn't just have a picture on a flag or text on
我们是在今年 6 月初录制的这次采访。非常感谢你能抽出时间，我真的很感激。很高兴见到你们两位。我想，罗曼，你可能也知道，你曾促成了我担任市长期间最喜欢的集数之一，那就是重新设计南本德市的市旗。因为我看到了你的演讲，评估了我们的市旗，发现它简直完美符合你所列出的所有糟糕市旗的特征。它不仅在旗帜上印了图案或文字，
a flag, it had a flag on a flag. It was a flag on a seal on a blanket. And we thought, we're going to change this. And I'm really glad we did. It was great. Yeah, I was really honored to see that I had some influence in that regard. That was really nice to see. Well, thank you, Secretary Pete Buttigieg for being on the 99% invisible breakdown of the power broker. Thanks for being here. Thanks for having me on. So my first question is, early on in the Biden presidency, you said this in a press conference. I'm still surprised that some people were surprised when I pointed to the fact that if a highway was built for the purpose of dividing a white in a black neighborhood, or if an underpass was constructed such that a bus carrying mostly black and Puerto Rican kids
它甚至在旗帜上印了一面旗帜。它是印在毯子上的徽章上的旗帜。我们当时就想：我们要改变这一切。我真的很高兴我们这么做了。这太棒了。是的，看到我能在这方面产生一些影响，我感到非常荣幸。那真是太棒了。好的，感谢交通部长皮特·布蒂吉格做客《99%无形》对《权力掮客》的深度剖析节目。感谢您的到来。感谢邀请我参加。我的第一个问题是：在拜登总统任期刚开始时，你在一次新闻发布会上说过这样的话：“我仍然对某些人感到惊讶——当我指出这样一个事实时，如果一条公路的修建是为了把白人社区和黑人社区隔离开来，或者如果一座立交桥的设计高度被压得太低，导致载着大多是黑人和波多黎各儿童去海滩的公交车无法通行（这种情况在纽约确实发生过），那么这显然反映了融入那些设计选择中的种族主义。我认为，直面这个简单的事实，我们没有什么可失去的；而通过承认它并进而处理它，我们将赢得一切。”
to a beach, or it would have been, in New York was designed too low for it to pass by, but that obviously reflects racism that went into those design choices. I don't think we have anything to lose by confronting that simple reality, and I think we have everything to gain by acknowledging it and then dealing with it. And so all the power broker heads in the world knew exactly what you were talking about when you said that. But many people, maybe some in good faith, maybe some in bad faith, were surprised or at least they feigned surprise in some way.
因此，世界上所有《权力掮客》的资深拥趸在你讲出这番话时，都完全明白你在指什么。但许多人——或许有些是出于善意，或许有些出于恶意——还是感到惊讶，或者至少在某种程度上假装惊讶。
Can you talk about the variety of responses you got from that statement? Yeah, certainly I was taken aback by how controversial it was. I know there's always controversies about what to do next in transportation policy, but I imagined perhaps naively that it was widely understood that these decisions about where roads and other pieces of infrastructure go, sometimes also about where they don't go, reflect these patterns of exclusion. And this is something that was documented, it was documented certainly in some of the anecdotes that emerge in the power broker, but also just known as something that happened, not just in the South,
你能谈谈你因这番言论而收到的各种反应吗？是的，当然，它所引发的争议之大让我始料未及。我知道在交通政策的下一步走向方面总是存在各种争议，但我曾天真地以为，大家已经广泛理解：关于道路和其他基础设施修建位置的决策——有时也包括它们不修在哪里的决策——都反映了这些排他性的模式。这是有据可查的，
but in places from St. Paul, Minnesota to Pittsburgh, to Syracuse, to places like Birmingham and Atlanta. And part of what was really puzzling to me was who today stands to lose by acknowledging this historic fact. And that's part of what I was trying to get at too, in my remarks is nobody's worse off because we're taking this seriously.
不仅在《权力掮客》中浮现的一些轶事里有据可查，而且它也被普遍认为是一种曾经发生过的现象，不仅在南方，而且从明尼苏达州的圣保罗到匹兹堡，从雪城到伯明翰和亚特兰大等许多地方都存在。当时令我感到非常困惑的一部分是：在今天，承认这个历史事实究竟会损害谁的利益？这也是我在发言中试图表达的一部分，那就是：没有人会因为我们严肃对待这件事而处境变糟。
In fact, when what's exciting to me about this moment and what's in the Biden infrastructure package is the resources to do something about it. So when we talk about these problems, we're not just wallowing in the harms, we're taking account of the harms and then getting involved in the remedy. And that's what's really exciting about this moment.
事实上，让我对这个时刻以及拜登基础设施一揽子计划感到兴奋的是，其中包含了采取行动的资源。所以当我们讨论这些问题时，我们不仅仅是在沉溺于过去的伤害，而是在正视这些伤害，并着手进行补救。这正是这个时刻真正令人兴奋的地方。
Not that we're, you know, erasing every historical harm, but that we're finding specific places where federal dollars help to divide a community. And we're using federal dollars to help reconnect those same communities. Can you talk about that? Like what does the current infrastructure bill, and we're using federal dollars to help reconnect those same communities. Can you talk about that? What does the current infrastructure bill,
并不是说我们要抹去所有的历史创伤，而是我们要找出联邦资金曾被用来割裂社区的具体地点，并利用联邦资金来帮助重新连接这些相同的社区。你能谈谈这一点吗？比如目前的基础设施法案是如何……并利用联邦资金来帮助重新连接这些相同的社区。你能谈谈这一点吗？目前的基础设施法案，
how does it address those past injustices and how do you make it so it connects a community? So what's really extraordinary in the infrastructure bill is it contains dedicated funding for this. We just put out about $3.3 billion through a program called Reconnecting Communities and Neighborhoods. For folks who are watching really closely, which probably includes some of your listeners,
它是如何解决过去的这些不公正现象的？你又是如何做到让它重新连接一个社区的呢？在基础设施法案中真正非凡之处在于，它为此包含了专项资金。我们刚刚通过一个名为“重新连接社区与邻里”（Reconnecting Communities and Neighborhoods）的项目投入了大约 33 亿美元。对于那些密切关注此事的人来说——可能包括你们的一些听众，
it actually stitches together two sets of funds. One was in the Inflation Reduction Act. Another was in the Infrastructure Bill itself. But they all added up into these billions of dollars to do things like stitch back together Chinatown in Philadelphia, where a route called the Vine Street Expressway, really in a slow motion disaster for the Chinatown community, in a process that began in the 60s and continued through the 90s,
它实际上是将两笔资金拼凑在了一起。一笔来自《削减通胀法案》，另一笔则来自基础设施法案本身。但它们加起来形成了这数十亿美元的资金，用于诸如将费城的唐人街重新缝合在一起——那里有一条被称为藤街高速公路（Vine Street Expressway）的路线，它对唐人街社区来说真是一场缓慢的灾难，这一进程始于 60 年代并延续到了 90 年代，
cut that community up. And we're capping over it to put them back. We're doing something similar in Atlanta. There the project is called The Stitch. We're over $150 million in to help that. In Buffalo, it's the Kensington street expressway that came out of our first round of this programming, where we're teaming up with the state of New York to put a cap in there.
将那个社区割裂开来。我们现在正在其上方加盖顶棚，把它们重新连回一体。我们在亚特兰大也在做类似的事情。那里的项目被称为“缝合计划”（The Stitch）。我们已经投入了超过 1.5 亿美元来协助推进。在布法罗，则是肯辛顿大街高速公路（Kensington street expressway），它出自我们这一系列计划的第一轮资助，我们将与纽约州合作，在那里加盖顶棚。
It's not always putting a cap over a depressed highway. Sometimes there are other approaches too. Sometimes you can mitigate this disconnection with something a little more modest than decking over a highway. Sometimes it's a transit mitigation or a pedestrian that's going to be a little bit more difficult to navigate. there are other approaches too. Sometimes you can mitigate this disconnection with something a little more modest than decking over a highway. Sometimes it's a transit mitigation or a pedestrian bridge. But what all these projects have in common is that they are knitting back together
这并不总是意味着给下沉式高速公路加盖顶棚。有时也有其他方法。有时你可以用一些比给高速公路加盖顶棚更温和的方式来缓解这种割裂。有时是通过公交缓解措施或行人天桥。但所有这些项目的共同点在于，它们正在重新编织
a place that was divided. And importantly, we're also funding the planning. Sometimes it's going to take a lot of federal dollars just to get the idea on the drawing board so that it can turn into a proposal to go on and do the construction on. But another thing, and I think folks who are attentive to what happened in the Robert Moses era will recognize why this matters, we're investing in a process that engages and empowers the community so that these projects are being done with them and not to them. Yeah, yeah. So what is your experience with the book The Power Broker? I wish I could claim to have read every page of it. It is on my bedside table. I would say
一个曾经被割裂的地方。更重要的是，我们还在为规划提供资金。有时候，仅仅是为了把这个想法搬上图纸，就需要花费大量的联邦资金，以便它能变成一个提案，进而开展施工。但还有一件事，我认为关注罗伯特·摩西时代的人会明白为什么这很重要，我们在投资一个能让社区参与并赋予其权力的流程，这样这些项目就是与他们一起完成的，而不是强加给他们的。对，对。那么，你对《权力掮客》这本书有什么看法？我真希望我敢说自己读完了它的每一页。它就放在我的床头柜上。我会说
that I have consulted it more than I could honestly claim to have read it. But like everything from Robert Caro, it is so absorbing. You look at a big brick of a book like that and can't imagine it to be a page-turner, and yet it is. And I can't remember actually when I was first exposed. I think like a lot of people, readers of my generation, I knew about the LBJ books before learning that the power broker was kind of Robert Caro's arrival.
我查阅它的次数，远超过我诚实说自己读过它的次数。但就像罗伯特·卡罗的所有作品一样，它是如此引人入胜。你看一本像那样的大部头砖头书，根本无法想象它会是一页让人停不下来、急于翻阅的书，但它确实是。我其实记不清自己是什么时候第一次接触到它了。我想和许多人一样，我这一代的读者，在了解到《权力掮客》可以说是罗伯特·卡罗的成名作之前，我就已经知道他关于林登·约翰逊的书了。
But I'm also just fascinated with him as a figure. I have a nerdy fascination with people's daily routines, I think partly because I could never quite figure out my daily routine in a way that's stable, or at least it's always evolved. And his unbelievable discipline, especially in a field, you know, being a historian, being in the humanities, which is known for, you know, somewhat chaotic work styles and lifestyles, his unbelievable methodical nature, coupled with, I think, the reporter's instinct. He started out as a reporter, right?
但我也对他的为人本身深深着迷。我对别人的日常作息有一种书呆子式的迷恋，我想部分原因是我从来没能以一种稳定的方式弄清楚我自己的日常作息，或者说它总是在演变。他那令人难以置信的自律——尤其是在历史学、人文学科这样一个以某种程度上混乱的工作风格和生活方式而闻名的领域里，他那种令人难以置信的井然有序的性格，再加上我认为的记者的直觉。他一开始是个记者，对吧？
Yeah. I think coupled with the reporter's instinct for how to make things readable and relevant and the knows for context, I just think it's something that is really compelling. And of course now, I first got interested in these things as a mayor, a mayor of a smallish city, South Bend, about a hundred thousand people,
对。我认为，再加上记者那种如何让内容易读、相关并注重背景的直觉，我只是觉得这非常引人入胜。当然，我最初对这些事情感兴趣是在我担任市长的时候，南本德一个小城市的市长，大约十万人，
but where we were wrestling with these kinds of questions. And now being in a city, which is famously all about the use and exercise of power. And knowing that, that, uh, you know, the power broker represents one of the most thorough going and, um, insightful accounts of how all of that actually works. I was hoping it was going to turn out that
但我们在那里纠结于这类问题。而现在身处一个以权力的使用和行使而闻名的城市。并且知道，呃，你知道，《权力掮客》代表了关于这一切实际上是如何运作的最透彻、最深刻的记述之一。我本希望结果是
you had been inspired directly by the power broker, because when you were mayor of South Bend You did a lot deliberately to make the downtown more pedestrian friendly And I imagined you reading Robert Moses and being like a punk rocker Listening to Led Zeppelin when punk artists were like this song is too long All of my songs are gonna be really short that you read and you'd be like too much cars My streets are gonna be for pedestrians. So that's my fantasy of the situation at least. I wish I was that cool and that quick to turn ideas into action.
你曾直接受到《权力掮客》的启发，因为当你担任南本德市长时，你刻意做了很多事情来让市中心对行人更友好。我想象你读着罗伯特·摩西的书，就像一个听着齐柏林飞船的朋克摇滚乐手，当时朋克艺人们觉得这首歌太长了，我的所有歌都要写得非常短，而你读了之后会觉得，汽车太多了，我的街道要留给行人。所以，至少这是我对当时情景的幻想。我希望我有那么酷，能那么快地把想法付诸行动。
But you know, I will say I surrounded myself as a young mayor with people who knew a lot about architecture and urbanism. The University of Notre Dame's architecture school is especially committed to some of the principles of new urbanism, which many of which I think were a response to urban renewal and the kinds of things Robert Moses was involved with. And that certainly trickled into the kind of intellectual architecture of what we were trying to do. I definitely set out as a mayor, partly because I was so new at it
但你知道，我可以说，作为一个年轻的市长，我身边聚集了一群非常懂建筑和城市规划的人。圣母大学的建筑学院特别致力于新城市主义的一些原则，我认为其中的许多原则是对城市更新以及罗伯特·摩西所参与的那类事情的回应。这当然渗透到了我们当时正试图做的事情的智识架构中。我作为市长确实一开始就着手去做——部分是因为我对此还很生疏，
and partly because it's how I do things, to say, okay, what are some principles to go by before we jump into this work? Even the most kind of unglamorous and day-to-day things, there need to be some principles at stake. I challenge myself and my team, for example, to say, okay, what's our philosophy of public work? What's our philosophy of wastewater?
部分是因为这就是我做事的方式——我想说，好吧，在我们一头扎进这项工作之前，有哪些原则可以遵循？即使是最不迷人、最日常的事情，也需要有一些原则在其中。例如，我向自己和我的团队发起挑战，说，好吧，我们对公共工程的哲学是什么？我们对废水的哲学是什么？
And the more we thought about it, it was about freedom and it was about the idea that your freedom depends on not having to think about wastewater or water. And then we realized that translated into really reliability and then affordability being our kind of main things we were shooting for and how you run a water utility. Similarly, trying to connect the big things to the small things, the concepts and the ideas to the everyday, definitely motivated what we tried to do when we were reimagining our streets. The streets of my hometown were basically designed to just evacuate the downtown, to blast vehicles through it as quickly as possible.
我们越是思考这个问题，就发现它关乎自由，关乎这样一种理念：你的自由取决于你不必去考虑废水或水。然后我们意识到，这转化为真正的可靠性，接着是负担能力，成为我们努力的主要目标，以及你如何运营一个水务公用事业。同样，试图将大事与小事联系起来，将概念和想法与日常生活联系起来，这绝对激发了我们在重新构想街道时所做的事情。我家乡的街道基本上就是为了疏散市中心而设计的，为了让车辆以尽可能快的速度穿过它。
In a pair of the main, two main kind of north-south streets of our downtown had been turned into this pair of one ways which Cars were going by so quickly. It was hostile to pedestrians You wouldn't want to walk on that sidewalk and by changing that we created a different more vibrant downtown It's funny. Obviously we were far from the only or the first community to take that approach, but some of the battles we had Within the community, you would have thought that I had made this up single-handedly in the shower.
我们市中心原本两条主要的南北走向的街道，被变成了一对单行道，汽车从旁边飞驰而过。这对行人很不友好，你绝不想在那个人行道上走，通过改变这一点，我们创造了一个不同的、更有活力的市中心。这很有趣。显然，我们远不是采取这种方法的唯一或第一个社区，但在社区内部我们经历的一些争端，你可能会觉得是我一个人在淋浴时凭空想出来的。
And. You invented the roundabout. Yeah. And that we were more or less imposing it on everybody and basically banning the automobile. And it actually helped to get some top cover from this department where I now serve. We got an award.
而且。你发明了环岛。是的。而且我们或多或少把它强加给每个人，基本上是在禁绝汽车。而从我现在供职的这个部门获得一些最高层的支持，实际上对推动这一切有所帮助。我们得了一个奖。
It might have been the first time I came into this building that I'm now sitting in as I speak to you, was to receive an award from the then Secretary of Transportation, Anthony Foxx, for the work that we were doing. Back then there wasn't a giant infrastructure bill to fund us to do the work, but even just getting a lot of top cover to say we might be on the right track was a big shot in the arm that helped us pursue that philosophy and that strategy on our streetscapes. Yeah. That makes me think of another difference between you and Robert Moses, because if Robert Moses was in that room getting that award, he would have been thinking, I'm going to take this guy's job someday. I'll be Secretary of Transportation someday.
这可能是我第一次来到我现在坐着对你说话的这座大楼，是来接受时任交通部长安东尼·福克斯的颁奖，表彰我们当时正在做的工作。那时还没有巨额的基础设施法案来资助我们开展工作，但仅仅是获得大量支持，证明我们可能走在正确的轨道上，就是一剂强心针，帮助我们在街景设计上贯彻那种哲学和战略。是的。这让我想到了你和罗伯特·摩西之间的另一个区别，因为如果罗伯特·摩西在那个房间里领那个奖，他心里想的会是：总有一天我要取代这个家伙的工作。总有一天我会成为交通部长。
Yeah, it definitely did not cross my mind when I was here then that I'd be coming back to the building in that capacity. But now you gotta watch out for everyone you hand an award to that they're coming after you, yeah. So in this section of the book that we were talking about for this episode, the big drama that concerns it is about whether the Brooklyn Battery Crossing
是的，当时我在这里时，脑子里绝对没有想过我会以这种身份回到这座大楼。但现在你得提防你颁奖的每个人，他们可能都是冲着你来的，是的。所以在我们为这期节目讨论的书的这一部分中，其中的主要戏剧冲突是关于布鲁克林电池跨海通道
should be a tunnel or a bridge. And every piece of empirical evidence is Brooklyn battery crossing should be a tunnel or a bridge. And every piece of empirical evidence is that that crossing should be a tunnel. But Robert Moses wants it to be a bridge and he has the funds to build it to enforce his will and only the power of the president stops him. And you know, there are a lot of weird biases when it comes to infrastructure that is worthy and exciting. But I feel like you really only understand the importance of infrastructure if you love replacing a lead pipe or putting sensors in the sewer as much as you love building a bridge. You know what I'm saying?
究竟应该是建隧道还是建桥。而每一条经验证据都表明，那个跨海通道应该是一条隧道。但罗伯特·摩西希望它是一座桥，他有资金去建造它来强行推行自己的意志，只有总统的权力才阻止了他。你知道，在关于值得投资且令人兴奋的基础设施方面，有很多奇怪的偏见。但我觉得，只有当你和喜欢建造桥梁一样，同样热爱更换铅管或在下水道里安装传感器时，你才能真正理解基础设施的重要性。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, I think so. I mean, look, a sewer system, or for that matter, a lot of tunnels, but definitely a wastewater resource, isn't something you can point to. It isn't something that you can put your name on. Again, to my earlier point, its elegance often is in the fact that you don't think about it. The way I always approach and conceptualize these things
是的，我想是的。我是说，看，一个下水道系统，或者就此而言，许多隧道，但绝对是废水资源，不是那种你可以指出来炫耀的东西。这不是那种你可以把自己的名字刻上去的东西。再次回到我刚才的观点，它的精妙之处往往在于你根本不会去想它。我一向对待和构想这些事情的方式是，
is the less you have to worry about whether you're going to get a glass of clean safe drinking water, or for that matter whether there's a hole in the road on your way to work, the more free you are to concentrate on whatever lifts your soul, you know? I mean, whatever matters to you in life. Raising your kids, practicing your faith, starting a business, being a scholar, whatever it is. Now having said that, I mean, bridges are also beautiful. And there are pieces of our infrastructure that play this elevating role in addition to this functional role.
你越是不需要担心是否能喝到一杯干净安全的水，或者就此而言，上班路上会不会遇到路坑，你就越是能自由地专注于任何能提升你心灵的事情，你知道吗？我是说，无论生活中对你来说最重要的是什么。抚养孩子、践行信仰、创业、做学者，无论是什么。话虽如此，我是说，桥梁也很美。在我们的基础设施中，有些部分除了这种功能性作用之外，还扮演着这种提升精神的作用。
And I think about that a lot, although even that too, I think is best understood by bringing it back down to the everyday. And what I mean by that is, you know, a bridge, the beauty of a bridge, if it is beautiful, just like its utility, if it is useful, matters most because somebody's day goes different, both admiring that nice bridge on the skyline and, you know, getting to where you're going on time. They do add up into somebody's everyday life goes
我经常思考这一点，尽管即使是这一点，我也认为最好还是通过把它带回到日常生活来加以理解。我的意思是，你知道，一座桥，如果它很美的话，桥的美丽——就像它的实用性如果是有用的话——之所以最重要，是因为某个人的日常生活变得不同了，既能欣赏天际线上那座漂亮的桥，又能在规定时间到达你要去的地方。它们最终汇聚成一个人的日常生活
a little bit better because that thing is there. Yeah. It sounds a lot like you're, you're articulating very well a, our kind of in-house philosophy that we talked about on previous episodes, that an acronym that I call noticeably improved people's lives or NIPL. And it's a, for term I'm not having a lot of success or luck. Yeah, I might work out a different acronym for use in federal policy here. But yeah, what was it again? Noticeable.
变得稍微好了一点，因为那个东西就在那里。是的。这听起来很像你，你非常清楚地表达了我们的一种内部哲学，我们在之前的节目中讨论过，我给它起了一个首字母缩略词叫 NIPL，意思是“明显改善了人们的生活”。这是一个我没有取得很大成功或好运的词。是的，我可能会为联邦政策的使用制定一个不同的缩写词。但，是的，它到底是什么来着？显著。
Noticeably improved people's lives. But you could what was it again? Noticeable? Noticeably improve people's lives. But you could just say nipple and people know what you mean, I think most of the time. Yeah. I'm really coming off as the shock chuck of the two co-hosts on this podcast. You're making me think though, because I think part of the tension in what we do as a department is some of it is noticeably improve people's lives for sure. Like I want you to see these great airport concourses that we're investing in improving.
明显改善了人们的生活。但你可以——它到底是什么来着？显著？明显改善了人们的生活。但你直接说这个缩写，大家多数时候也知道你是什么意思，我想。是的。在这两个播客联合主持人的对比中，我真的显得挺语不惊人死不休的。不过这让陷入了思考，因为我认为我们部门工作中的部分紧张关系在于，有些工作确实是明显改善了人们的生活。比如，我希望你能看到我们正在投资改善的这些棒极了的机场大厅。
And I want you to know that this happened because we got this bipartisan infrastructure law and it happened because of President Biden's leadership. On the other hand, like the most important things we work on in transportation should not be that noticeable. I mean, especially because first and foremost, we're a safety organization, right? So like you shouldn't notice that you didn't get injured or killed, you know, on your way to work. Like that should be something you don't even have to think
并且我希望你知道，这是因为我们通过了这项两党基础设施法案，这是在拜登总统的领导下实现的。另一方面，我们在交通领域开展的最重要的工作，其实不应该那么引人注目。我是说，特别是因为首先我们是一个安全机构，对吧？所以，你不应该注意到自己没有在上班路上受伤或丧命，你知道吗？这应该是一件你甚至不需要去思考的事。
about. And that side of our work is actually one where, you know, no news is good news. So I'm half with you. I think a lot of times, especially when you're trying to get credit for good policy, it's very important to noticeably improve people's lives and make sure you remind people how it got done too. And there's this whole set of questions in moral as well as political about how credit is accumulated and distributed, which I might have some more thoughts on if you want to explore that. But then there's the other side of it where kind of the less people know you're there, the better. And that's how a lot,
而在我们工作的那个方面，实际上是“没有消息就是好消息”。所以我有一半同意你的看法。我认为很多时候，特别是在你试图为主张好的政策争取功劳时，明显改善人们的生活并且确保提醒大家这是怎么做成的，这非常重要。关于功劳是如何积累和分配的，这里面有一整套道德以及政治上的问题，如果你想探讨的话，我可能对此还有更多的想法。但另一方面，人们越是不知道你在那里，情况可能就越好。这也是许多——
maybe part of that's my mentality from having been in the military and being involved in counter-terrorism too, where like, you know, a good day is when nobody even knows that you did what you're doing. You just protected them and they get to go about their lives. Yeah. It's curious that you bring up the idea of credit, especially because so much of Moses's ability to navigate politics was about the apportioning out of credit for things, that he got a certain amount of credit for parks and people liked him, but he was always sure to include elected officials
也许部分原因来自于我的军旅生涯以及参与反恐的心态，你知道，美好的一天就是没有人知道你做了你正在做的事。你只是保护了他们，而他们得以继续他们的生活。奇怪的是你提出了功劳这个概念，特别是考虑到摩西驾驭政治的能力很大程度上在于如何分配事情的功劳，他因为公园而获得了一定程度的功劳，人们也喜欢他，但他总是确保把民选官员
in the debuts of the openings of his projects so that their names would be attached because he knew they wanted the credit and they would support him if they could get it. And I wonder if that kind of calculation is kind of like a sinister way to describe it. That part of the calculation is part of the politics of running a department like this, where like you're saying, some things are noticeable, some are not, and how the credit gets spread around in order to get that kind of support
纳入到他的项目开幕式中，这样他们的名字就会被挂钩，因为他知道他们想要功劳，如果能得到功劳就会支持他。我在想，这种计算方式——用这种词来形容可能有点阴险。这种算计其实是运营这样一个部门的政治的一部分，就像你说的，有些事情很明显，有些则不然，以及功劳是如何分配的，以便获得那种支持
or that kind of approval or other types of checkpoints met to get projects accomplished? Yeah, look, that's a thing, right? And up to a point, not to sound too naive, but up to a point, that's a really healthy thing. Like, part of how it's supposed to work in a democratic system is you, as a government official, deliver something for people. They notice that you delivered it for them,
或者那种批准，或是达到完成项目所需的其他检查点？是的，看，这就是现实，对吧？在某种程度上——听起来别太天真——但在某种程度上，这是一件非常健康的事情。比如，在民主体制中，事情本该运作的一部分是，作为政府官员，你为民众兑现了某些成果。他们注意到你为他们兑现了成果，
and they give you credit for that, and you get to keep your job. Or, you know, you fail them, and they're mad at you, and you don't get to keep your job. On some level, that's the basic logic of electoral democracy. And I think, you know, it's definitely important to me as I travel the country to make sure that I talk about the different people who helped us get something done.
他们把功劳记在你头上，你就能保住工作。或者，你知道，你让他们失望了，他们对你很生气，你就保不住工作。从某种程度上讲，这就是选举民主的基本逻辑。而且我认为，当我走遍全国时，确保谈论那些帮助我们完成工作的人对我来说绝对很重要，
If I'm in Pennsylvania, I want people to know that a bipartisan law that was led by President Biden and was supported by their senator, Bob Casey, helped us get this bridge done that we're fixing in Philly or these safety dollars going to make a safer streetscape in Lancaster. Now one interesting thing about how our funding works is that the vast majority of it actually is not of the form of discretionary grants where our team puts together a list and then it's brought to me for a final sign off and we're literally picking and choosing winners and losers.
如果我在宾夕法尼亚州，我想让人们知道，由拜登总统领导并得到他们的参议员鲍勃·凯西支持的两党法案，帮助我们修建了我们在费城正在修复的这座桥，或是提供了这些安全资金，用来在兰开斯特打造更安全的街景。关于我们的资金如何运作，一个有趣的事实是，绝大多数资金实际上并不是那种由我们的团队整理一份清单，然后交给我最终签字，由我们字面意义上挑选赢家和输家的全权委托拨款。
There is a lot of that, there's a record level of that and we try to have very clear principles for how we make those choices and be transparent about them. But for every dollar that we have going out that way, we have many more dollars that go out by formula where we just give it to the state. And within certain limits, they can use it however they want. And what's really interesting to me is that some states
确实有很多这样的情况，这是创纪录的数量，我们努力为如何做出这些选择制定非常清晰的原则，并做到公开透明。但对于以这种方式支出的每一美元，我们还有更多的美元是通过公式分配出去的，我们只是把钱给到州里。在一定限度内，他们可以随心所欲地使用它。而让我真正感兴趣的是，有些州
and some governors will go out of their way to share the credit, to put up signs on the side of the road to make sure that everybody knows this happened because of President Biden's bipartisan infrastructure package and a partnership with the state. And some of them won't, right? But for those who do, I mean, the alchemy of that of that and this again I don't want to sound too Pollyanna but I really honestly believe this is true my favorite rule of political mathematics
和一些州长会不遗余力地分享功劳，在路边竖起标志，确保每个人都知道这是因为拜登总统的两党基础设施一揽子计划以及与该州的合作才得以实现的。其中一些州不会这样做，对吧？但对于那些这样做了的人来说，这种化学反应——再次声明，我不想显得太过于乐天，但我真心相信这是真的——我最喜欢的政治数学法则是，
is that if two willing parties like a federal administration and a governor or a mayor who work together if they each come in willing to share the credit, each one of them walks away with two-thirds of the credit. I don't know how it works, but there's kind of a magic to that that I love. And then, you know, look, obviously as a matter of fairness, I also consider it important if somebody tries to share in the credit for something they try to stop, like some of the members of Congress who celebrate projects that are going to their districts, funded with the bill that they voted against and in some cases attacked.
如果两个愿意合作的各方——比如联邦政府和一个愿意合作的州长或市长——如果他们每个人都愿意分享功劳，那么他们每个人最终都会带走三分之二的功劳。我不知道这是怎么运作的，但里面有一种我所热爱的魔术。然后，看，显然出于公平起见，我也认为很重要的一点是，如果有人试图分享他们曾试图阻止的事情的功劳——比如某些国会议员，他们庆祝进入自己选区的项目，而这些项目是由他们投票反对、甚至在某些情况下曾攻击过的法案资助的——
We're going to call them out on that because it's just a matter of fairness there. We're still going to fund it if it's a good project, but if they're going to be cheeky about making it sound like they're the ones who brought the project, we're going to have something to say about that. I don't think that's unnecessarily political. I think it's just about fairness. Yeah. No, I think you're right.
我们要把他们这点叫出来，因为这纯粹是个公平问题。如果这是一个好项目，我们仍然会资助它，但如果他们厚颜无耻地把项目说成是他们自己带来的，那我们就要评理了。我不认为这有多么不必要的政治化。我认为这纯粹是关于公平。是的。不，我想你是对的。
And it's interesting because something that's come up as we've talked on the series is kind of the ways that to operate productively in politics, to do things for people, you need to have traits that at least, you know, we're taught as children or through fairy tales and things are not the ideal traits. Like you need a certain amount of ambition for power in order to do things to get to, and you need a certain amount of getting the credit in order to continue that support. Whereas I feel like what we're taught when we're young is, you know, to be that kind of like Gary Cooper, Lone Ranger humility where you're like, I didn't do anything. I'm just another man, you know, I, I, I know I stopped all these people, but anyone would have done it. Whereas if you do that in politics, you will not effectively get the support you need to get the things done that you're there in the first place to do, most likely. Yeah, maybe. I don't know, I think there are a lot of different ways of being effective.
而且很有趣的是，正如我们在系列节目中所讨论的那样，出现的一个情况是，要在政治中富有成效地运作，要为人们做事，你需要具备一些特质，这些特质至少，你知道，是我们从小或通过童话故事等被教导的并非理想的特质。比如，为了达成目标、为了到达目的地，你需要一定程度的对权力的野心，为了维持这种支持，你需要一定程度的功劳。然而我觉得我们年轻时受到的教育，是那种加里·库珀式、独行侠式的谦逊，你会说，我什么都没做。我只是另一个人，你知道，我知道我阻止了所有人，但任何人都能做到。然而如果你在政治上这么做，你将无法有效地获得你需要的支持，从而无法完成你最初来到那里的目的，很有可能是这样。是的，也许吧。不知道，我认为有很多不同的方法来发挥效用。
I would definitely say some of the most effective people I've encountered since getting this job are not the ones who get their name all over the place. That's one way to do it, especially in a, you know, for elected officials. This sounds like that counterintelligence mindset again. Maybe, like, because in the military there's always the person who, like, according to the org chart is the is the person who will get something done and then there's the person who will actually get something done. Like, when I was was deployed I was a very junior officer like my most important responsibility probably was driving equipment or other
我绝对可以说，自从得到这份工作以来我遇到的一些最有成效的人，并不是那些到处都能听到他们名字的人。这是做事的一种方式，特别是在，你知道的，对于民选官员来说。这听起来又像是那个反间谍的心态了。也许吧，因为在军队里总是有一种人，根据组织图表，他是能把事情办成的人，然后还有另一种人，是真正能把事情办成的人。比如，当我被部署时，我是一个资历很浅的军官，我最重要的职责可能是开着装备车或者带着
people who typically who outranked me around Kabul or between Kabul and Bagram and we didn't actually even though that was an important part of my job I didn't actually have direct control of any vehicles. So to get a vehicle, I had to really think about it. And there were two ways to do it. There was an official way to do it. It took forever and sometimes I would never get a vehicle. And then there was this guy named Marlin,
通常军衔比我高的人在喀布尔四周转悠，或者在喀布尔和巴格拉姆之间穿梭，实际上——尽管这是我工作的重要部分——我甚至没有对任何车辆的直接控制权。所以为了弄到一辆车，我必须认真动脑筋。有两种方法可以做到这一点。有一种官方的方法。那要花很长时间，有时我可能永远也弄不到一辆车。然后还有这么一个叫马林（Marlin）的家伙，
who to this day, I don't know what his job title was. I don't know, he's a civilian. I don't know what organization he was part of. I just knew that if I stayed on his good side and made sure that I helped him anytime he needed something and gave him first dibs on the chocolate chip cookie bars that came in the care packages from South Bend, Indiana to my little mailbox in Afghanistan, I'd get my hands on a Land Cruiser when I needed one. And that really mattered. And so all of which is to say,
直到今天，我也不知道他的职位是什么。我不知道，他是个平民。我不知道他属于哪个组织。我只知道，如果我跟他保持良好关系，确保他在任何需要帮助的时候我都帮他一把，并且把来自印第安纳州南本德、寄到我在阿富汗的小邮箱的爱心包裹里的巧克力饼干条优先给他，那么当我在需要的时候，就能弄到一辆陆地巡洋舰。这真的很重要。所以总而言之，
there's a lot of different ways to do this, right? And I do think sometimes we get wrapped up in the myth of somebody who uses hard or even nefarious means to get something done is kind of the way, right? And it's fitting again that we talk about this in the context of Robert Kero book because I do think his scholarship on LBJ got a lot of people thinking about LBJ who delivered so many of these incredible results including this, you know, is in many ways credited
有很多不同的方法来做到这一点，对吧？而且我确实认为，有时候我们会陷入这样一种神话：使用强硬甚至是不正当手段来把事情做成，才是正确的方法，对吧？我们在罗伯特·卡罗的书的背景下讨论这一点，也确实很契合，因为我确实认为他关于林登·约翰逊的研究让许多人开始思考林登·约翰逊，正是他带来了如此多不可思议的成果，包括这个——在许多方面被认为
with the civil rights law that was one of the most important social leaps forward we've had as a country. But there's this idea that he, in terms of how he treated people, was a real bastard and that's what it took to get those important worthy things done. And there's a whole mythos around that, that we can have long historical debates about how much that's really the right account of what happened. But the point is, that's what people think works a lot around here, and some of them really lean into that in ways I would argue are actually counterproductive to their long-term effectiveness. That makes sense to me.
带来了民权法案，这是我们作为一个国家取得的最重要的社会跨越之一。但有一种观点认为，就他对待人的方式而言，他是个不折不扣的混蛋，而这正是取得那些重要且有价值的成果所需要的代价。围绕这一点有一整套神话，我们可以就这是否真的是对所发生事情的正确描述展开长期的历史辩论。但关键是，这正是人们认为在这里行之有效的方法，其中有些人非常倾向于这种方式，以至于我认为实际上适得其反，损害了他们长期的成效。这对我来说很有道理。
So one of the things about Robert Moses is that he had this idea for how New York should be, and it should be dominated by cars. He loved being a passenger in a car. He never learned how to drive, but he loved being a passenger in a car. He grew up in a time period in which driving was this leisurely activity. People didn't do it to commute, they did it for fun.
所以关于罗伯特·摩西的事情之一是，他对于纽约应该是什么样子有一个想法，那就是它应该由汽车主导。他喜欢坐在汽车里当乘客。他从来没有学会开车，但他喜欢坐在汽车里当乘客。他在一个驾驶是一种悠闲活动的时代长大。人们开车不是为了通勤，而是为了好玩。
And so he was really into this idea of parkways, and he shaped New York in that image. And he really did not pay attention to the changing world. He had just had an idea that was fixed. And no matter what amount of empirical evidence, sort of counter-dicting that, just didn't work on him over the decades that he ruled. And I started thinking about this when it comes to being
所以他非常迷恋公园大道（parkways）的概念，并以这种形象塑造了纽约。而且他真的没有去关注正在变化的世界。他只是有一个固定不变的想法。无论有多少与之相矛盾的经验证据，在他统治的几十年里，就是对他的这种想法毫无作用。当我开始思考这一点时，就联想到
in charge of transportation in the country and thinking about this when it comes to being in charge of transportation in the country and thinking about it, how much do you nudge? I mean, obviously, no one should do what Moses did and just steamroll over everything with this one ideology that doesn't change. But you do want to shape things and move things to be kind of different than they are now and not just build on what's already been built. How do you think about balancing that? Yeah, I think it's really important
掌管这个国家的交通，思考掌管这个国家的交通时，你该如何推动变革？我的意思是，显然，没有人应该效仿摩西，用这种一成不变的单一意识形态把一切都强行推平。但你确实想要塑造事物、推动事物朝着与现在不同的方向发展，而不仅仅是在已经建成的东西上添砖加瓦。你如何考虑平衡这一点？是的，我认为非常重要的一点是，
to come in with a vision. Again, your account of the principles, the ideas, the concepts, and sometimes that means pushing. I mean, I was definitely pushing my community back in my formative years as mayor with ideas that I believed in that I really think we were right about, like a well-placed roundabout
带着愿景上任。再次强调，你要阐述这些原则、理念、概念，有时这意味着施加推动力。我的意思是，在我作为市长的形成期，我绝对是在用我坚信的、并且真正认为我们做对了的想法来推动我的社区，比如一个位置良好的环岛
was going to save lives. And a lot of people hated it. And in a democracy, you're supposed to be accountable to where people, you're supposed to be accountable to people and at the same time have a responsibility sometimes to lead in a direction that wasn't already how people thought. I mean, in fact, you could argue by definition you're not leading if you're just going to
将能拯救生命。很多人对此恨之入骨。而在民主社会中，你本该对人们所在的地方负责，你本该对人们负责，与此同时，有时你也有责任朝着人们原本思维方式之外的方向去领导。我的意思是，事实上，你可以说，如果你只是去到
where people already are. And so then the tension becomes how can you legitimately be responsive to people, which means listening and being open to the possibility that you're wrong and being ready to adapt your plan and still be doing your job as a leader, which is to arrive with a vision and try to persuade people. So when are you persuading people and when are you letting them persuade you? I think that we have a lot of process that goes into that. If you're at the local level, like I come out of, a lot of public meetings that were
人们已经身处的地方，那按定义你就不算在领导。因此，这里的张力就变成了：你如何才能既合法地对人民有响应能力——这意味着倾听并对你可能是错的这种可能性保持开放，随时准备调整你的计划——又同时履行你作为领导者的职责，即带着愿景抵达并试图说服人们？那么，你什么时候在说服别人，什么时候又在让别人说服你呢？我认为我们在这个过程中投入了大量的流程。如果你处于我出身的地方那种地方基层，许多公众会议
probably not as much a feature of Robert Moses' life, but as a mayor. I mean, when I think about our complete street stuff, we counted into the dozens the number of public meetings we had. And I viewed them largely as persuasive, largely as an opportunity to say to the community, we really need to do this and here's why. But we really did adjust and adapt and rethink our plans because of the input we got.
可能并不是罗伯特·摩西生活中的主要特征，但作为一名市长。我的意思是，当我想到我们的完整街道项目时，我们举办的公众会议多达数十场。我主要把它们视为具有说服力的过程，主要是一个向社区表明“我们真的需要这样做，原因如下”的机会。但由于我们收到的反馈，我们确实调整、适应并重新思考了我们的计划。
And if I'm being honest, also because the city council made me to some extent, I couldn't get what I wanted to through on the first try without some adaptation. So there was that push-pull. But I still wouldn't have been doing my job if I just kind of polled people on what they already thought and went along with it. At the federal level, there's a much more
如果我诚实地说，也是因为市议会在某种程度上逼迫了我，如果不进行一些调整，我想要的东西是无法通过的。所以存在那种推拉。但如果我只是对人们已经在想的事情进行民意调查并顺从他们，我仍然算不上尽到了职责。在联邦层面，有一个更加
kind of thoroughly designed version of this, which is especially when you get into something like an environmental impact statement. So on the biggest, gnarliest, most complex projects, federal law requires that if federal dollars are involved, there's a very intensive process of getting comment. And we have had, whether it's projects or whether it's certain rules that we've been considering, literally get tens of thousands of comments. You go in on regulations.gov, which is a real website. Sounds made up and it doesn't sound very exciting,
彻底设计好的版本，特别是当你涉及像环境影响声明这样的事情时。因此，在最大、最棘手、最复杂的项目上，联邦法律规定，如果涉及联邦资金，就必须有非常密集的过程来征求意见。无论是项目还是我们一直在考虑的某些规则，我们都实实在在地收到了数以万计的意见。你登录 regulations.gov，这是一个真实的网站。听起来像是捏造的，听起来也不是很令人兴奋，
but you know, when we propose something that we're eventually gonna make into a rule or contemplating making into a rule, everybody gets to weigh in and somebody has to read all of those comments. And that's good, right? Because we're making rules that everybody has to live by. So I don't know that everybody kind of draws a line
但你知道，当我们提出最终将成为规则、或正在考虑成为规则的提案时，每个人都可以发表意见，而且必须有人阅读所有这些意见。这很好，对吧？因为我们在制定每个人都必须遵守的规则。所以我不知道每个人是否都在某处划一条线，
somewhere, but I think any leader earning their paycheck is not simply reflecting the population they serve, but also is not a good leader if they're ignoring the population and the community that they serve. And by the way, one other thing I want to say, which is the deployment of political capital, right? If you are for something unpopular and if you are right, that it is the right thing to do, then you do kind of a trust fall where you implement that policy and hope that over the years it delivers enough good results for people that they wind up giving you credit for it.
但我认为任何拿薪水的领导者，绝不只是简单地反映他们所服务的民众，但如果他们忽视他们所服务的民众和社区，同样也不是一个好领导。顺便说一句，我还想说另一件事，那就是政治资本的部署，对吧？如果你支持一件不受欢迎的事情，而且你是对的，即它是正确的事情，那么你就会进行某种信任之跃，推行这项政策，并希望多年后它能为人们带来足够好的成果，以至于他们最终把功劳记在你的头上。
That's what I felt like happened with the kind of arc of my first term as mayor. I spent the first year, a lot of people got mad at me because of the things we proposed, things we tried to do. By the fourth year, I had enough results to show for it that I could earn enough trust to get re-elected and go at it again. Here in this administration, I feel like we're on a similar arc where we spent year one, you know, just getting this infrastructure built through. Now we're in the fourth year, turning it into actual results and hopeful that that earns credit. Mm-hmm.
我觉得在我第一任市长任期的发展轨迹中发生的就是这种情况。我花了第一年时间，很多人因为我们提出的事情、我们试图做的事情而对我感到生气。到了第四年，我有了足够的成果来证明自己，从而赢得了足够的信任来赢得连任，并再次大干一场。在这里，在本届政府中，我觉得我们正处于一条类似的轨迹上，我们花了一年时间，你知道的，只是让这项基础设施法案获得通过。现在我们正处于第四年，将其转化为实际成果，并希望这能赢得功劳。嗯。
As Roman was saying earlier, this episode that we're covering before this interview airs, so the listeners will have just heard this, but I'm going to recap it slightly anyway, is about the building of the Brooklyn Battery Tunnel and how he wanted it to be a bridge. And it took the President of the United States stepping in and pressuring the War Department not to give navigable waters permission for it to get it stopped. And it feels like so much of this is emblematic of an earlier era that was not as standardized and formalized as the process that you're describing now.
正如罗曼（Roman）刚才所说，我们在这次采访播出前讨论的这期节目——所以听众刚刚才听到这个内容——但我无论如何还是会稍微回顾一下，内容是关于布鲁克林电池隧道的建设以及他如何希望它是一座桥。这需要美国总统介入并向战争部施压，不给它颁发可航行水域的许可来阻止它。感觉这一切很大程度上象征着一个早期时代，它不像你现在描述的流程那样标准化和规范化。
And there was no Department of Transportation at the time. It wouldn't be around until the 1960s when Moses was already basically out of power. And it makes me wonder how you would handle this kind of situation now, or if this kind of situation arises of sort of master builder, master planner type who has local control, local influence, and is trying to push through something very big using federal dollars that maybe isn't a good idea. Does the federal government have more tools to handle something like that now than it did back idea. Does the federal government have more tools to handle something like that now than it did back then when literally the president's wife had to say to him,
当时也没有交通部。直到20世纪60年代摩西基本失势时，交通部才出现。这让我很好奇，如果你现在遇到这种状况，你会如何处理，或者如果出现这种类型的状况——那种拥有地方控制权、地方影响力的大建设者、总规划师类型的任务，正试图利用联邦资金强行推行某种可能并非好主意的非常庞大的项目——现在的联邦政府是否拥有比过去更多的工具来处理类似的事情？当时甚至连总统的妻子都不得不对他说：
you should do something about this? And the president said, oh, yeah, yeah, let's not do that. Yeah, look, there are more tools now. We're very careful and very conscientious about the fact that a lot of these decisions are local. For example, 54,000 projects and counting that were funding through the Biden infrastructure package. Zero of those projects was invented here at the USDOT headquarters in Navy Art, all of them were developed by some city town state tribe, airport authority transit agency and then brought to us or got funding through a formula. And so we're very intentional about not dictating the terms of a
你得对这事做点什么。然后总统说，哦，好吧，好吧，那我们就别这么做了。是的，看，现在有更多的工具了。我们非常小心、非常认真地对待这样一个事实，即许多决策都是地方性的。例如，我们通过拜登基础设施一揽子计划资助的 54,000 个项目（还在增加）。这些项目中没有一个是由位于海军造船厂的美国交通部总部凭空发想出来的，所有这些项目都是由某个城市、小镇、州、部落、机场管理局或交通运输机构开发，然后带给我们的，或是通过公式获得资助的。因此，我们非常刻意地不去规定项目的条款。
project. And at the same time, we have policy goals, right? Safety, job creation, climate equity, and to the extent that the law provides for us to do so, we shape things largely by which projects we select for funding in competitive processes and by other lawful means to be a certain way. And other tools competitive processes and by other lawful means to be a certain way. And other tools that didn't exist before are really designed to protect the rights of people who could be impacted by a project, notably Title VI of the Civil Rights Law that we enforce so that if people are about to get, you know, trolled, Robert Moses style, they have recourse and we come in as a watchdog or as an enforcer really to make sure that those people are heard.
与此同时，我们有政策目标，对吧？安全、就业创造、气候公平，只要法律允许我们这样做，我们很大程度上通过在竞争性流程中选择哪些项目进行资助以及通过其他合法手段，来塑造事物的特定走向。以及以前不存在的其他工具，它们确实旨在保护可能受项目影响的人们的权利，特别是我们执行的《民权法》第六章，以便如果人们即将遭受罗伯特·摩西式的欺凌，他们有权诉诸法律，而我们作为监督者或执法者介入，以确保这些人的声音被听到。
But I'll also say this, one thing I've learned in this job or relearned in this job is the importance of informal or unofficial power. And I'll give you an example that's less in the realm of building things, but is one of the most important things we've worked on, which is how airlines treat their passengers. So there are some things we've been trying to get done and are still trying to get done through rulemaking. But the rulemaking process, the Administrative Procedures Act, the Notice and Comment, it can take years. While we were working on that, especially in the summer of 2022, and there were so many frustrations around cancellations and delays, the idea emerged that if we just put more information out in a really easy to understand form, that not only
但我也要说，我在这份工作中学会的一件事——或者说重新学到的一件事——是非正式或非官方权力的重要性。我举一个例子，它较少涉及建造东西的领域，但却是我们从事的最重要的工作之一，那就是航空公司如何对待他们的乘客。因此，有些事情我们一直试图通过制定规则来完成，并且仍在努力完成。但规则制定的过程——《行政程序法》、意见征询与公告——可能需要数年时间。在我们致力于此的同时，特别是在 2022 年夏天，当时关于航班取消和延误有太多的挫折感，于是出现了一个想法：如果我们只是以一种非常易懂的形式发布更多信息，不仅
would help passengers know which airlines would take better care of them, but knowing it was out there might actually change the airline's behavior. And living in this world where it takes months or years to do something, I asked the team, well, okay, if we set up a website, how long would that actually take? And they said, we could do it in a couple of weeks. And I said, okay, well, I'll send a letter
会帮助乘客知道哪些航空公司能更好地照顾他们，而且知道这些信息公之于众，实际上可能会改变航空公司的行为。生活在一个做事情需要几个月甚至几年的世界里，我问团队，好吧，如果我们建立一个网站，实际上需要多长时间？他们说，我们可以在几周内完成。我说，好吧，那我会发一封信
to all the CEOs of the airlines saying, hey, in a couple of weeks, we're gonna put this website up. You might wanna change your customer service plans before we do it. This is going to be a bunch of green check marks and red Xs. And they did. This was, I did not, this was not an enforcement action.
给所有航空公司的首席执行官，说，嘿，几周后我们将上线这个网站。在我们做这件事之前，你们可能想改变一下你们的客户服务计划。这将会是一堆绿色的勾和红色的叉。他们照做了。这不是，这不是一次执法行动。
We've done those. This was not a rulemaking. We're doing those. This was just saying, hey, we're like, we're going to tell people what you're doing. So you might want to think about what you're doing. And it led to real change. And so I've been amazed at how powerful those tools can be
我们做过执法行动。这不是制定规则。我们也在做规则制定。这只是在说，嘿，我们要把你们在做的事情告诉大家。所以你们可能想考虑一下你们自己在做什么。它带来了真正的改变。因此，我惊奇地发现，当这些工具与诸如规则制定、执法和花钱等工具结合使用时，它们可以发挥多么强大的作用。
when used alongside tools like rulemaking and enforcement and spending money. Yeah, yeah. Of those 54,000 projects that you mentioned, I hope I got that number right. Don't ask him to tell us every single project, Roman. No, but I'm wondering, you strike me as a real systems thinker. I hope I got that number right. Don't ask him to tell us every single project Roman. But I'm wondering, you strike me as a real systems thinker.
是的，是的。在你提到的那 54,000 个项目中，希望我没有记错这个数字。罗曼，别让他把每个项目都说一遍。不，但我在想，你给我的印象是一个真正的系统思考者。希望我没有记错这个数字。罗曼，别让他把每个项目都说一遍。但我在想，你给我的印象是一个真正的系统思考者。
You really enjoy solving a problem. And is there a certain type of project that really delights you in the way that it's the type of solution that it is? Or I don't know, the fact that I'm sort of struck by it. I've always felt like your wastewater thing, sewer thing in South Bend was just like great. You know what I mean?
你真的很喜欢解决问题。有没有哪种特定类型的项目，其解决方案的独特性质会让你感到由衷的高兴？或者说，我不知道，我经常被这类事情触动。我一直觉得你们在南本德做的那个废水项目、下水道项目简直太棒了。你知道我的意思吗？
And it is one of those things that, that absolutely passes by without notice. Is there a type of project that really delights you when you hear about it or it comes across your desk? Yeah, I love the projects that have a disproportionate impact in the places that they benefit. And often those are the actually smaller projects. They're not our marquee national headline projects.
而且这类项目往往在不知不觉中就完成了。有没有哪种项目，当你听到它或者看到它摆在你的办公桌上时，会让你感到由衷的高兴？是的，我喜欢那些在它们惠及的地方产生不成比例的影响的项目。通常这些其实是较小的项目。它们不是我们那些引人注目的国家级头条项目。
Obviously I love the high speed rail we're doing from Nevada to Southern California. We're contributing $3 billion to make that happen and it could be amazing. But again, I mentioned I was just in Lancaster, Pennsylvania. It's just fresh on my mind because it's the last one one I visited 12 million bucks we're gonna help them do safer streetscapes that is both a
当然，我喜欢我们正在建设的从内华达州到南加州的()));高速铁路。我们为此出资 30 亿美元，这可能会非常了不起。但话说回来，我提到我刚刚去过宾夕法尼亚州的兰开斯特。这刚刚浮现在我的脑海里，因为这是我访问过的最后一个地方。我们打算出资 1200 万美元帮助他们建设更安全的街道景观，这既是
kind of a vote of confidence in the mayor's and the city strategy of Adding bike lanes not just not not in the idea that it's ornamental but actually for safety purposes Taking some one-way roads turning them into two-way Accepting that traffic can be a minute or two slower in exchange for a real safety payoff, that isn't our biggest dollar amount, but is something that we know is gonna make a difference.
对市长和城市战略的一种信任投票，他们添加了自行车道，不仅仅是为了装饰，而是出于安全目的；将一些单行道变成双行道；接受交通可能会慢上一两分钟，以换取切切实学的安全回报。这虽然不是我们金额最大的项目，但却是我们知道能发挥作用的项目。
We were in Chamberlain, South Dakota. This is a community that's 2,500 people, but believe it or not, they have an airport. And that airport really matters because they do air ambulance missions in a community that's a long drive from the nearest major hospital with the trauma center. And we're just getting them a building for their airport. Right now it's basically a manufactured home. You can tell it's kind of a double-wide. They've done a nice job with it. But they need an actual brick and mortar building.
我们在南达科他州的张伯伦市。这是一个只有 2500 人的社区，但信不信由你，他们有一个机场。这个机场非常重要，因为他们在执行空中医疗救援任务，而这个社区距离最近的拥有创伤中心的大型医院有很长的车程。我们正在为他们的机场购置一栋建筑。目前它基本上是一个活动板房。你能看出它有点像双宽型的。他们把它弄得挺不错。但他们需要一栋真正的砖混建筑。
And for less than a million bucks, we're getting them one. Those kinds of things are especially gratifying because you know, maybe it's just because of where I come from, you know, I was mayor of a smaller mid-sized city, you know how impactful they're going to be. And so I stack those right up alongside the, you know, what I often call the cathedrals of our infrastructure that we're working on. Yeah. I remember when the Eastern span of the Bay Bridge, it was rebuilt, I'm from the Bay Area, and the construction was running late,
而且花不到一百万美元，我们就为他们搞定了一栋。这类事情尤其令人欣慰，因为你知道，也许这只是因为我的出身，你知道，我曾是一个较小或中等城市的市长，你知道它们将具有多么巨大的影响力。因此，我将这些项目与那些我经常称之为我们正在建设的基础设施中的“大教堂”的项目并列在一起。是的。我记得当海湾大桥东跨段重建时——我是湾区人——工程工期延误了，
and they canceled the event where you could walk across it before it opened. And I was so bummed, like I really, I wanted to take the kids, you know, like, I was like, there was this moment that I felt like that was just kind of lost in us just exalting in this idea of this thing that we built that only a government can build.
他们取消了在桥开通前步行穿过它的活动。我太失落了，我真的很想带孩子们去，你知道的，我当时觉得，有一个瞬间好像就这样失去了，我们本该为这种唯有政府才能建造的事物欢呼。
Amazon can't build it, Apple can't build it. A government builds this, and that's the collective will of the people, and I just wanted to have that moment of celebration. And I miss those, have that moment of celebration and I miss those. And I feel like, I feel like we're ripe for having that moment again, when it comes to infrastructure. I love that.
亚马逊建不了，苹果建不了。政府建造了它，这是人民的集体意志，我只是想拥有那个庆祝的时刻。我怀念这些，拥有那个庆祝的时刻，我怀念这些。我觉得，我觉得我们已经准备好再次迎来那个时刻，当谈到基础设施时。我太喜欢了。
And I think we do need to do that. And I think the challenge and the opportunity with this particular infrastructure moment is that it's in so many places at once. So there's not this like the golden spike, like the single thing you can use to mark the completion of this coast to coast project of the transcontinental railroad, right? It's literally tens of thousands of places getting their golden spike. And I think the style of celebration you're talking about is really fitting for that, and having each community come up with its version of that. And there is something in particular a little magical about
我认为我们确实需要这样做。我认为这个特定基础设施时刻的挑战和机遇在于，它同时发生在如此多的地方。所以没有那种像“金色道钉”一样的东西，没有那种你可以用来标志横贯大陆铁路这一跨州项目竣工的单一事物，对吧？这里有成千上万个地方都在拥有他们自己的“金色道钉”。我认为你所说的庆祝方式真的很适合这一点，让每个社区都想出它自己的庆祝版本。而且确实有一些特别神奇的地方，
when you give people access to a piece of infrastructure, they're already gonna use, like we will drive over the bridge every day, but when you walk it, you feel it differently. I'll tell you, that can be really powerful. I've had an experience of occasionally being on a runway to do my job, we either do a press conference on a tarmac that we're about to revamp or ride along
当你让人们接触一件他们无论如何都会使用的基础设施时，比如我们每天都会开车驶过这座桥，但当你步行走过它时，你的感觉会有所不同。我告诉你，那真的可以非常震撼。我有过这样的经历，偶尔为了工作走上飞机跑道，我们要么在一个即将翻修的停机坪上举行新闻发布会，要么搭乘
with a inspector going out on a pickup truck. And we're actually real- You're not sneaking onto runways at night, these are official. Yeah, all kosher. Yeah. But you, you know, from a distance, you could be forgiven for thinking a runway is
检查员的皮卡车一起去巡视。实际上我们真的很——你可不是在夜里偷偷溜上跑道，这些都是官方的。是的，一切都合乎规定。是的。但你从远处看，可能会误以为跑道
basically like a road and when you're on one, you realize it's more like a field. Yeah. I mean, in terms of its scope. Um, and there are things like that when you're on a bridge or, or, uh, or a runway or another piece of infrastructure that if, if you get the chance to interact with it in a non-normal way, it deepens your appreciation for it.
基本上就像一条公路，而当你身处其中时，你会意识到它更像是一片田野。是的。我是说，就其规模而言。嗯，有些事情就像这样，当你身处一座桥上，或者跑道上，或者其他基础设施上时，如果你有机会以一种非正常的方式与它互动，它会加深你对它的欣赏。
I mean, I honestly feel like there was this wave, this WPA, PWA period in which we took special pride in these things and there was an extraction period in which we didn't and we wanted to all public-private partnerships and we didn't want to. And now I feel like it's, do you feel that swell of people wanting to do this stuff a little bit more, a little bit, I don't know. It just seems like we're back into an era where we could build with abundance.
我的意思是，我真的觉得曾有过这样一个浪潮，即 WPA（公共事业振兴署）、PWA（公共工程管理局）时期，我们对这些事物感到特别自豪；而后来又有一个索取时期，我们不再为此自豪，我们想要所有的公私合营，我们不想要这些。现在我觉得，你是否感觉到人们想要做这种事情的热情又高涨了一点点，我不知道。这似乎让我们回到了一个我们可以带着丰裕来建设的时代。
So I have a couple of thoughts about this. One is that I think we need to remember that what we're building is something that should be One is that I think we need to remember that what we're building is something that should be a source of pride and is not just making up for lost time. And here we may be the victims of our own arguments a little bit, because I think we said persuasively and correctly,
所以我对此有几个想法。首先，我认为我们需要记住，我们正在建造的东西应该是——首先，我认为我们需要记住，我们正在建造的东西应该是自豪感的来源，而不仅仅是为了弥补失去的时间。在这里，我们可能多少成了自己论点的受害者，因为我认为我们曾掷地有声且正确地指出：
hey, for the last 40 years we've under-invested, we've got a huge backlog, maintenance is a problem, we gotta just fix all our stuff. And that's true, by the way, we have a whole philosophy around what's called fix it first, the importance of taking care of a backlog. But taking care of a backlog doesn't make the heart sore, right? And the truth is we're doing all of the above.
嘿，在过去 40 年里我们投资不足，我们有巨大的积压工程，维护是个问题，我们必须修复我们所有的东西。顺便说一句，这是真的，我们围绕着所谓的“优先修复”（fix it first）有一整套理念，即处理积压工程的重要性。但处理积压工程并不能让人心潮澎湃，对吧？事实是，我们正在进行上述所有这些工作。
We're definitely dealing with things that should have been done 30 or 40 years ago and making up for lost time in repairing or restoring bridges or tunnels. But we're also doing whole new things. Again, the high-speed rail sphere just being one example of it. And so I think we need to remember to think about the positive, the proactive, that how we're gonna be not just as good
我们绝对在处理那些本该在 30 或 40 年前就完成的事情，并在修复或恢复桥梁和隧道方面弥补失去的时间。但我们也在做全新事情。再次以高铁领域为例，这只是其中一个例子。因此，我认为我们需要记住去思考积极主动的一面，思考我们不仅将变得像过去一样优秀
or as far ahead as we once were, but better than ever if we get this moment right. But the other thing I think that is always in play here, especially now that it's not the 30s and 40s and we have other things we pay attention to in terms of environmental impact and workforce and frankly just safety on building things, that means there's some delayed gratification here.
或领先，而且如果我们把握好这个时刻，将会变得比以往任何时候都好。但我认为这里始终发挥作用的另一件事是，尤其是现在已经不是 30 和 40 年代了，我们在环境影响、劳动力以及坦率地说建筑安全方面还有其他需要关注的事情，这意味着这里存在一些延迟满足。
The real reason I call the biggest projects we're doing cathedrals of our infrastructure is actually not because it's a poetic word to talk about a big thing. It's a reminder of this central characteristic of cathedrals, which is that the people who built them weren't even around when they were complete. Now, unlike the builders of Notre Dame,
我把我们正在做的最大项目称为我们基础设施的“大教堂”，其真正原因其实并不是因为谈论一个宏大事物时它是一个诗意的词汇。它是对大教堂这一核心特征的提醒，即建造它们的人在它们竣工时甚至都不在人世了。现在，与巴黎圣母院的建造者不同，
I very much hope to be alive when we finish the Hudson River tunnels, but it's unlikely that I'll be Secretary of Transportation when that happens. And so, unlike a piece of great, I don't know, tax policy, and I'm super proud of the tax policy administration, the child tax credit, they did it, and almost did a stroke in a matter of months, child poverty plummeted in this country. Like, that's amazing. It doesn't work that way when you're building a big bridge or a new
我非常希望当哈德逊河隧道完工时我还能活着，但当那发生时，我不太可能还是交通部长。因此，与某种伟大的税收政策不同——我为税收政策管理、儿童税收抵免感到无比自豪，他们做到了，在几个月内几乎一气呵成，这个国家的儿童贫困率骤降。就像，那太惊人了。当你建造一座大桥或一个新的
airport terminal. And so we need to be as excited and as emotional about a project that takes years to bear fruit as we are about something that gets done almost overnight. And to me part of how we do that is we take pride in the how. One of the coolest things I get to do is spend time with high school students who are in these vocational programs and pre-apprenticeship programs that prepare them. Some of them not going to college, some of them going to college but want to learn building trades anyway, but prepare them to have a hand in this building that's going on. And for all the hand-wringing that's gone on about how our
机场航站楼时，事情可不是这样的。因此，对于一个需要多年才能见效的项目，我们需要像对待一个几乎一夜之间就能完成的项目一样感到兴奋和充满激情。对我来说，我们做到这一点的一部分方式就是为“过程”感到自豪。我能做到的最酷的事情之一，就是花时间与那些参加职业项目和学徒前置项目的、为之做准备的高中生在一起。他们中的一些人不打算上大学，一些人打算上大学但无论如何都想学习建筑行业，但这些项目让他们准备好参与到正在进行的建设中。尽管人们对我们的
country doesn't do, would shop school in high school anymore and doesn't respect building, I see a real change, a real kind of counterculture thing happening and these students stand up taller and they're part of it and my point is they might be working on a bridge two or three or four years before anybody gets to drive across it, but it's already making somebody better off. And that's something that gets me excited and that I hope we all take a level of pride in.
国家不再在高中开设手工艺学校、不再尊重建筑行业有种种焦虑，但我看到了一种真正的变化，一种真正的反文化现象正在发生，这些学生挺直了腰杆，他们是其中的一部分。我的意思是，他们可能在任何人得以驾车穿过它两三年甚至四年前就已经在桥上工作了，但它已经让某些人的生活变得更好了。这就是让我感到兴奋的事情，我希望我们所有人都能为此感到一定程度的自豪。
That's a really exciting way to think about, It feels like one of the big flaws of Moses in the book is that, is this impatience. He's got to get it done. He's got to get it done now so we can move on to the next thing. And when you're building something that will last a hundred, possibly 200 years or longer, the impatience in getting it built is only going to hurt you in the long run. And you make those mistakes that he made or make those deliberate errors that he made. And there's something very exciting about that idea of focusing on the building of it too.
这是一种非常令人兴奋的思考方式。感觉《摩西传》这本书中摩西的一个大缺点就是这种急躁情绪。他必须把它做完。他必须马上把它做完，这样我们才能进行下一件事。当你建造一个能持续一百年、甚至二百年或更久的东西时，急于把它建成的急躁情绪从长远来看只会伤害你。你会犯下他所犯的那些错误，或者犯下他那种刻意的错误。而这种专注于建设本身的理念有着非常令人兴奋的地方。
So that the period before the thing is completed isn't just a frustrating period of waiting. It's a period that you can also make the most of and take pride in. I think that's such an inspiring way to think about that process. Yeah, I mean, Roman, you talked about the participation in an event to mark a project completion, but there are also ways to do that along the way.
这样一来，在项目完成之前的时期就不再只是令人沮丧的等待期。这也是一个你可以充分利用并引以为豪的时期。我认为这是一种非常有启发性的思考过程的方式。是的，我是说，罗曼，你谈到了参与标志项目竣工的活动，但在此过程中也有其他方法可以做到这一点。
I mean, we, you know, this might be a little romanticized, but we often look back to the era of a barn raising, right, where people got together to do something and part of the fellowship that was created in the doing of it mattered. And I think that's true in a lot of service contexts in more modern versions of what we do. By the way, I would even say just the act of putting these resources together, I mean
我的意思是，我们（这可能有点被浪漫化了）经常回顾那种“齐心协力盖谷仓”的时代，对吧？人们聚集在一起做一件事，而在做的过程中建立的友情是很重要的。我认为这在我们所做事情的更多现代版本的各种服务背景中也是如此。顺便说一句，我甚至可以说，仅仅是将这些资源汇聚在一起的行为——我是说，
the political construction project that was the bipartisan infrastructure law, if only because it was a bipartisan law in a horrifically divided time, which is the Washington of 2021, is something we ought to take some pride in. But I do think, look, we need to find ways to celebrate, not just as a political matter, so that people who helped get this done get credit, but to reconnect all of us with our role
作为两党基础设施法的政治建设工程，仅因为它是在一个可怕分裂的时代（即 2021 年的华盛顿）通过的一项两党法律，就是一件我们应该感到自豪的事情。但我确实认为，听着，我们需要找到庆祝的方法，不仅仅是作为一项政治事务——为了让那些帮助完成这项工作的人获得赞誉——而是为了让我们所有人重新与我们的角色建立联系，
because each of us paid into this, right? And each of us should take some pride in this getting done. And it's a big deal. In fact, my big thing, you've got your acronym, Elliot. I've got something I'm trying to get to catch on. Okay. Let's see if it's more appropriate than mine. I don't know.
因为我们每个人都为此出资了，对吧？我们每个人都应该为这件事的完成感到自豪。这是一件大事。事实上，我最看重的事——你有你的首字母缩写，埃利奥特。我也有一个我正试图流行起来的东西。好的。看看它是不是比我的更合适。我不知道。
Let's see. So I want the sum total of the Biden era investments in infrastructure, whether it's the stuff I work on or the getting rid of lead pipes or the internet access or any of these other things to come to be collectively known as the big deal. There was, there was the new deal, the square deal, the fair deal.
让我们拭目以待。所以我希望拜登时代在基础设施方面的投资总和——无论是我的项目，还是铅管改造、互联网接入，还是任何其他这些事情——统称为“大事件”（the big deal）。曾经有过“新政”（New Deal）、“公平交易”（Square Deal）、“公正 DEAL”（Fair Deal）。
I think nothing could be more fitting for President Biden's infrastructure work than the big deal. So I'm going to keep calling it that. We'll see if it catches on. I like it. Well, Secretary Pete Buttigieg, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a real pleasure to talk to you. Same here. Thanks for having me on. And thanks for your attention to these things. Of course. They really matter and they're more fun to talk about and think about than people might realize. And that is this month's episode
我认为没有什么比“大事件”更适合拜登总统的基础设施工作了。所以我打算一直这样称呼它。我们看看它会不会流行起来。我喜欢它。好吧，皮特·布蒂吉格部长，非常感谢您做客我们的节目。和您交谈真是一大快事。我也是。感谢邀请我来。也感谢您对这些事情的关注。当然。这些事情真的很重要，而且比人们可能意识到的要更有趣、更值得思考。这就是本期
of the 99% invisible breakdown of the power broker. Next month, we're going to cover chapters 33 and 34. That's pages 703 through 806 in my book, two very long chapters. And if you can't wait that long to hear me summarize something and you don't care what it is I'm summarizing, whether it's the Power Broker or say a really terrible movie, why not head over to the Flophouse
《99%无形》对《权力经纪人》的解析。下个月，我们将涵盖第 33 章和第 34 章。也就是我书中的第 703 页到第 806 页，两个非常长的章节。如果你等不及那么久来听我总结某些东西，并且你不在乎我总结的是什么——无论是《权力经纪人》还是一部非常糟糕的电影——为什么不前往 Flophouse
podcast, my other main podcast where you will hear me summarize some kind of terrible movie. And we've got some exciting news. We have new Power Broker breakdown merch for all of you following along at home. Something folks have been clamoring for from the beginning of the read-along. You can finally have something that shows off your enthusiasm for the power broker in addition to lugging around a four pound book. In fact, one of the things we've got is perfect for carrying around that massive tome, that four pound volume, that enormous municipal grimoire that you've come to love so much. And it is a tote bag, but not just any tote bag.
播客，那是我的另一个主要播客，在那里你会听到我总结某种糟糕的电影。我们有一些令人兴奋的消息。我们为所有在家收听的听众准备了新的《权力经纪人》解析周边商品。这是听众从跟读开始以来一直呼吁的东西。除了带着一本四磅重的书四处奔走之外，你终于可以拥有能展现你对《权力经纪人》的热情的东西了。事实上，我们准备的东西之一非常适合用来携带那个庞大的大部头、那本四磅重的巨著、那个你已经深深爱上的庞大市政魔法书。它是一个托特包，但不仅仅是普通的托特包。
This one is from Bagu. It has two sets of handles. It has a zipper. It is pushing the limits of tote bagness in the way only a visionary like Robert Moses would, wondering what's possible with a tote bag and not caring who gets hurt in the process. Truly, this is the carrier that the power broker deserves. We also got a Nine IMPI power broker band t-shirt with Robert Moses on the front
这个来自 Bagu。它有两组提手。它有拉链。它突破了托特包的极限，就像罗伯特·摩西这样的远见者那样，思考托特包的可能性，而不关心在这个过程中谁会受伤。这真的是《权力经纪人》当之无愧的载体。我们还有一件 99PI 权力经纪人乐队 T 恤，正面印有罗伯特·摩西，
and a list of episode dates on the back. It is the most hardcore metal thing that we've ever produced. You can find it all at 99PI.org slash store and we'll have a link in the show notes. By the way, the rest of the 99PI shop is discounted as we make way for some new merch, including a 99PI Power Broker Challenge Coin, which we'll have available for all you guys who have accomplished the read-along with us. The 99% invisible breakdown of the Power Broker is produced by the wonderful Isabel Angel,
背面印有分集日期列表。这是我们制作过的最硬核的金属风单品。你可以在 99PI.org 上的商店找到这一切，我们会在节目简介中提供链接。顺便说一句，99PI 商店的其余部分正在打折，为一些新周边让路，包括 99PI 权力经纪人挑战币，我们将为所有同我们一起完成跟读的你们准备好。由出色的伊莎贝尔·安杰尔（Isabel Angel）制作，
edited by Comiti. Our music is by Swan Real, and our mix is by Dara Hirsch. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director from the Rosso team, includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martine Gonzalez,
由科米蒂（Comiti）剪辑。我们的音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作，混音由达拉·赫施（Dara Hirsch）完成。99% Invisible 的执行制作人是凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）。我们的高级编辑是德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是 Rosso 团队的数字总监，团队成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）、
Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Emmet Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martín González, Christopher Johnson, Vivienne Ley, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered 6 blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the normal social media sites as well as our own Discord server where
克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）、埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín González）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·莱（Vivienne Ley）、拉什玛·道恩（Lashma Dawn）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、妮娜·波图克（Nina Potuck）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99% Invisible 的标志由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯（Stephen Lawrence）创建。该系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市区，向北 6 个街区的潘多拉大厦。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们，我们在那里
we have fun discussions about the power broker, about architecture, about movies, music, all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most of these days. You can find a link to that Discord server, our merch page, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Oh, sorry, I got carried away. I love that. What a great book.
就《权力经纪人》、建筑、电影、音乐以及各种好东西进行有趣的讨论。这就是我这几天大部分时间闲逛的地方。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到该 Discord 服务器的链接、我们的周边商店页面以及 99PI 的每一个往期节目。哦，抱歉，我有点忘形了。我太喜欢了。多棒的一本书啊。
It's a great book, you know. It's a good book. We should devote some time to it. We should talk about it once a month. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一本好书，你知道的。这是一本好书。我们应该花点时间在它上面。我们应该一个月讨论一次。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。